hello everyone
welcome to this exciting live video
series on data science by simply learn
we are going to have daily live sessions
this week that will cover all the
important skills to help you master data
science in a week we are going to learn
the leading data science skills and
Technologies each day with our highly
experienced instructors
we will focus on programming with python
and R data visualization SQL machine
learning and more
so without any further delay let's begin
with day one of our data science week so
in this session we are going to Learn
Python Programming and understand the
mathematical Concepts required for data
science jobs
python is the most popular programming
language for data science and machine
learning and provides a collection of
libraries such as numpy pandas
matplotlib scikit-learn Etc to analyze
data and build prediction models you
will learn all the basics and advanced
concepts of Python Programming such as
Loops functions object-oriented
programming Etc
mathematics is equally essential for
creating efficient models
you need to learn statistics probability
calculus and linear algebra to
understand the working of machine
learning algorithms so let's dive deep
and Learn Python from scratch that's
the core readability and English like
commands that make coding a lot easier
and efficient due to this it is the most
popular and preferred language python is
interpreted high-level general purpose
programming language developed by twido
van Rossum at National Research
Institute for mathematics and computer
science Netherlands in contrast to
popular belief that python was named
after display python was actually named
after the show Monty Python's Flying
Circus
Guido and Rossum formulated python in
the late 1980s as a successor to the ABC
language in 1994 python version 1.0 was
released with features like exception
handling Lambda map filter and reduce
python 2.0 released in 2000 introduced
features like list comprehensions and a
garbage collection system capable of
collecting reference Cycles python 3.0
was released on the 3rd of December
2008. undoubtedly Python 2.x and 3.x
have proven to be the most used versions
as of today python 3.9.4 is the latest
stable version released in the summer of
2019. python is popularly used for
development scripting and software
testing top ID companies like Google
Facebook Instagram Spotify and Netflix
among others use Python some major
applications of python can be seen in
the fields of machine learning
artificial intelligence data science and
iot python also offers many libraries
like numpy sci-fi Keras tensorflow
Django and flask pep 8 is the official
style guide that defines the styling
conventions for python code a few
popular open source python projects
include pic EnV statistics solving the
traveling salesman problem using
self-organizing match and python to BPF
converter some of the trending python
repositories on GitHub today include nip
ml from scratch pytotch Transformers 100
days of ml code among others popular
websites on the internet like Reddit and
quora are built using python
civilization 4 Battlefield 2 Sims 4 and
World of Tanks are some popular games
developed using python according to
indeed the average salary of a python
developer in India is about 5 lakhs per
annum and that in the US is around 124
000 US Dollars users and admirers of
python especially those considered
knowledgeable are referred to as
pythonous pythony stars and pythonians
since its Inception python has come a
long way to become the most popular
coding language and continues to
revolutionize the IT industry so what
really is Python programming language
python is an object oriented high-level
programming language that supports
built-in data structures and dynamic
semantics
it supports multiple programming
paradigms such as structured object
oriented and functional programming
python is often described as batteries
included language because it has a
comprehensive collection of standard
libraries
python supports different modules and
packages which allows program modularity
and code reuse
python was developed by Guido van Rossum
and its implementation started in
December 1989.
python 1.0 version was released in the
year 1994. python 2.0 came out in
October 2000 while python 3.0 was
released in December 2008.
now that you have got an understanding
of the Python programming language let's
now look at the top 10 reasons why you
should learn python
so at number 10 we have ease of use
one of the most common reasons
chicken is that it is quite easy to
learn and code
it provides a simple syntax that
improves readability and makes it easier
to understand so developers can create
any desktop or machine based application
using this language
python is very versatile and is
instrumental in artificial intelligence
and machine learning
we will talk about this later in the
session compared to Java or CC plus plus
it has fewer lines of codes
in the example here we are printing a
hello world program in Java as you can
see
if you have to write a program in Java
you first have to declare the class name
along with its scope
next using curly braces you need to pass
the main method along with its arguments
and then using
system.out.printlen method you can print
hello world that's quite a tedious task
isn't it
the same task for printing hello world
can be done using just one line of code
in python as shown here you can write
the print function and pass whatever you
want to display inside the brackets and
that will print the output it is so
simple
that is why python is considered as a
high level language and its open source
you can just download it from the
website and start using it
at 9 we have active community
you need a community to learn new
technology and friends are your best
asset when it comes to learning a
programming language python has large
community support
it has an extensive and active Community
to assist Engineers developers analysts
and data scientists with expert support
in case of programming errors or issues
with the software
you can just go ahead and put your
queries in the community forum the
community members will address your
queries in real quick time
communities like stack Overflow also
brings many python experts together to
help learners
python enhancement proposals or pep is
where the proposals and the improvements
are announced
also there are a set of recommendations
or core values called the design of
python written by Tim petos that
represents the guiding principles for
python development
up next at 8 we have portable and
extensible
multiple cross language operations can
be performed effectively because python
is portable and extensible in nature
for example if the users have a python
code written on Windows and they want to
execute on a Mac operating system or
Linux operating system or Solaris they
can easily do it without any Amendment
they can also run this code on any
platform flawlessly and without an
interrupt
due to its extensibility feature you can
integrate other programming languages
such as java.net C and C plus plus codes
with python
the components of other programming
languages can be used with python and
thus it can be used to make a
cross-platform suitable application too
so it is a really good feature that
python provides
the next Reason To Learn Python is
testing Frameworks
python supports several built-in
Flawless testing tools and Frameworks
that help in debugging and speeding up
workflows
some of the tools and Frameworks
supported by python are by test selenium
and Splinter
this is the reason for bits every tester
tries to use python-based tools and
Frameworks to test any application or
code or to validate it in an easier
manner
Pi test is the most recommended testing
framework for functional integrational
and unit testing
you can run selenium test scripts using
Python programming language to automate
various tasks and Splinter is an open
source tool for testing web applications
using python
it lets you automate browser actions
such as visiting URLs and interacting
with their items
at number six we have libraries and
packages
another reason why python has become so
popular in the industry these days is
that it has a massive collection of
libraries and packages that make your
task simple and easy
it has a range of libraries packages
Frameworks and modules for data
manipulation statistical calculation web
learn and data science
python programmers have developed tons
of Open Source libraries that you can
use
you can find many of them via Pi text
repository provides the default packet
Anaconda is a third party python
ecosystem other examples include numpy
scipy and xango
then we have scripting and automation
python is not just a programming
language it can also be used for writing
scripts for automating tasks and
workflows without human intervention
the code can be written in the form of
scripts and executed later for it is
interpreted by the machine and checked
for errors at runtime the machine is
used to read and interpret the code
once the developer checks the code it
can further run or be used several times
without any interruption
this allows you to automate a set of
certain tasks within a program or the
same code can be used with other
applications as well
at number 4 we have web development
another reason to Learn Python is that
it makes the web development process so
much easier
it provides a wide collection of
Frameworks that make it easier for
developers to develop web applications
some of the examples are xango flask
pyramid turbo gears cherry pie Etc
these Frameworks are written in Python
which makes the code a lot faster and
stable
the task which used to take hours in PHP
can be finished in minutes using python
python is also used for web scraping
Django offers many elements of intricate
programs such as template design
management panel signing in signing up
signing out URL routing Etc
once the user establishes the framework
all these features become ready to use
flask
is a microwave framework written in
Python
of all the components that are part of
this module they are all ready to
execute in the server context
Pinterest and Linkedin use flask
pyramid offers more attributes than
flask it will assist users with URL
routing and authentication support
turbo gears is a highly recommended and
scalable framework that supports
features such as authentication caching
identification management of sessions
and pluggable applications
up next at number three
we have machine learning
the growth of machine learning has been
phenomenal in the last five years and
it's rapidly changing the world around
us
python is one of the most preferred
programming languages for machine
learning because of its simple syntax
and support for several machine learning
libraries
using different libraries and functions
in Python the system can learn and train
itself from past data
once the system is trained it can then
learn to adjust itself to new inputs
finally it can make predictions and
perform human-like tasks automatically
at number 2 we have data science
machine learning and data science go
hand in hand
python is robust scalable and provides
extensible visualization and Graphics
options hence it is widely used in data
science
python is libraries such as numpy for
numerical computation of data pandas for
operations to manipulate data on
numerical tables and time series it also
provides simpi for symbolic computation
and sci-fi for Technical and scientific
computations
it has another Library called Pi brain
which is sought for python-based
reinforcement learning artificial
intelligence and neural network
liability scikit-learn is the machine
learning library for creating
classification regression and clustering
algorithms and finally it provides Pi
torch and tensorflow for deep learning
finally coming to the most important and
the top reason to Learn Python which is
career opportunities and salary
Python language provides a variety of
job opportunities and Promises a high
growth graph with huge salary prospects
it has been used by most of the tech
Giants
industry leaders using python or Amazon
Google Facebook IBM NASA Netflix and
YouTube
next you can see the Google Trends
but I have considered three programming
languages python Java and C plus I have
compared them for the past 12 months you
can see it clearly on your screens that
python has become a front runner in
terms of popularity and web search
volume
it means people are interested in Python
they want to learn it and use it in
their work
you can also check for the YouTube
search
there also you will find that Python
programming language is the most
searched language on YouTube
now on your screens
you can see the report of pypl which is
popularity of programming language index
it is created by analyzing how often
language tutorials are searched on
Google
it is a leading indicator the raw data
comes from Google Trends
the bar graph depicts that python is the
most popular and widely used programming
language across the globe followed by
Java then JavaScript and c-sharp
the popularity of programming language
index can help you decide which language
to study or which one to use in a new
software project
the next graph shows the popularity of
python and Java over the years starting
from 2004 till the current period which
is 2020 worldwide python is the most
popular language
python grew the most in the Last 5 Years
by 19.4 percent and Java lost the most
by minus 7.2 percent
now let's talk about the different
career opportunities and the job roles
that you can get into If You Learn
Python language
first
you can become a python developer
where you will be asked to write and
test codes debug programs and integrate
applications with third-party web
services
second you can become a web developer
here you will be responsible for writing
server-side web application logic python
web developers usually develop back-end
components connect the application with
third-party services and support the
front-end developers by integrating
their work with the python application
you can also become a data analyst if
you know python as a data analyst you
have to gather data from multiple
sources using scripts analyze that data
develop and Implement databases and data
collection systems
you can become a data scientist
as a data scientist you need to
understand the challenges in business
and come up with the best Solutions
using modern tools and techniques to
analyze visualize and build prediction
models to make business decisions
lastly you can be a machine learning
engineer where you can develop
intelligent machines that can learn from
vast volumes of data and apply knowledge
without human intervention
so there's a lot of Scopes If You Learn
Python
now let's have a look at the salaries of
some of these job roles
so if you become a python developer you
can earn an average salary of 76 526
dollars per annum in the United States
while in India you can earn an average
of 4 lakhs 98 000 rupees per annum
also
If You Learn Python and become a data
scientist
you can expect an average salary of 113
000 per year in the United States while
in India you can earn an average of 10
lakhs 28 000 rupees per annum
let me now go ahead and call out the 10
reasons for learning python once again
at number 10 we had ease of use at
number nine we had active community at 8
we had the portable and extensible
feature of python at number seven we saw
the testing Frameworks
at six we had libraries and packages
then at five we saw scripting and
automation followed by web development
then we had machine learning and data
sense at number three and number two
respectively
and finally at number one we had career
opportunities and salary
so who is a python developer let's
answer this so here are some of the
Technologies used by a python developer
pandas Anaconda tensorflow python Ides
Django web framework and patreon a
python developer is one Who develops
backend components of a web application
using python when working as a web
developer now the web Frameworks like
Django and flask are used for this
purpose
a python developer is also the one who
writes effective testable and scalable
python code he also performs data
analysis when working in the field of
data science
so basically a python developer develops
deploys debugs and maintains a project
so let's go through the skill set of a
python developer now the core python
skills that a python developer possesses
are data structures like arrays list
stack queues trees and graphs there's
oop Concepts like inheritance classes
and objects and abstraction thus
packages and functions that is importing
external packages into a python code
database and its connection that is
connecting a python backend to a
database like MySQL when it comes to
data science skills there's numpy that
is a library for performing mathematical
calculations
let's pandas that is the library for
storing and manipulating data
efficiently this scipy and then there's
matplotlib which is a library for
plotting charts and graphs for a given
data and finally there are machine
learning algorithms which consists of
models like supervised learning
unsupervised Etc now coming to web
developer skills there are Frameworks
like Django and flask for back-end
development of web applications
and then there's web scraping which
includes taking data from websites and
converting that data into usable format
there's API handling which is basically
handling API requests for a web
application to perform server-side
operations and finally there is back-end
connection which basically involves the
backend part of a web application
usually handled by python Frameworks
now moving on let's look at the python
developer job roles
first up this python web developer now a
python web developer usually writes
server-side code works on the web
Frameworks like Django and flask
collaborates with the data team to
gather end users requirements develops
the server-side platform deploys
applications performs tuning usability
Improvement and automation
moving on next job role is data analyst
now a data analyst generally works on
python libraries including matplotlib
numpy pandas Etc carry out data analysis
collect by using the scripting language
explore data sets gather requirements
tune in applications analyze problems
communicate findings with the team or
stakeholders
the next job role is automation test
engineer
now an automation test engineer usually
works on python test framework tools
including Pi test Pi unit perform
complex system tests troubleshoot code
issues create test scripts design the
automation framework perform a b testing
next up is machine learning engineer
now machine learning engineer has the
following roles to perform statistical
analysis of data put machine learning
models into production research and
transform data science prototypes
research and Implement appropriate ml
algorithms and tools perform ml tests
and keep updated with the ml trends
the last job role is software engineer
now a software engineer is expected to
write server-side code collaborate with
the design team to gather end users
requirements develop the server-side
platform deploy applications perform
tuning usability Improvement and
automation
moving on to the next topic let's look
at the python develop Saturns now
software Engineers with python skills
are offered better salaries across the
globe the average salary of a python
developer in India is around 7 lakhs 55
000 rupees per annum the average salary
of a python developer in the US is about
79 000 US dollars per annum
moving on to our last segment python
developer resume
so let's go ahead and understand what a
python developer resume should portray
just keep a few things in mind when
you're preparing your resume
your resume should be clear updated and
concise
you should prioritize the skills
according to the job role you're
applying for and do not write anything
extra that's a big no the recruiters are
smart enough to know that so do not lie
and do not write extra firstly let's
look at the fresher resume so if you're
a fresher these are 10 profile link and
also your GitHub repository link if you
have next up is the projects now clearly
depict the goal of your project so just
in case you worked on like C5 projects
make sure you keep it concise and crisp
next up is your education do not lie
here make sure you give a relevant
education with grades next you have the
certifications if you have any
certifications or achievements go ahead
and write them down next you have the
technical skills now again prioritize
according to the job role and lastly you
have your non-technical skills this
could be your communication analytical
skills problem solving skills Etc moving
on to an experienced developer so again
mention the resume header
then you have the summary again very
crisp and clear go ahead and mention
your portfolios and your links coming to
experience now here you'll have to
clearly depict your work you'll have to
make sure that you write down all your
responsibilities in that company do not
go overboard and write extra keep it
very concise
again relevant education and your grades
you have technical skills the same goes
for this as well prioritize according to
the job role and finally you have your
non-technical skills now let's go over
some of the features of python and these
features are actually why it's
considered that using python is
advantageous over using other languages
so let's start with some of these points
now as we mentioned python is very it's
a very readable program code readability
is very important it's one of the design
philosophies behind this when it was
being developed it's very easy to learn
which is why python is an entry point
for many people that are just beginning
to learn programming and as I mentioned
earlier it's a high level language in
Python we since python is open source as
as I had already mentioned so it gets it
benefits from all the the benefits you
get from any open source technology now
it's also portable so what this means is
that if we create a code in in Python
and we create in a particular system on
Windows we don't need to make any
changes if we wanted to use the same
script or this that same piece of code
on some other system say on a Linux
system or a Mac system python itself
comes with a very large standard Library
this this facilitates us a lot because
we don't need to create our own
libraries or modules or have to download
very specific libraries most of the
problems that we do encounter quite
commonly can already be solved by the
standard libraries that have already
been provided by the developers of
python right right from the beginning
now later later on during the course we
will encounter what is the meaning of a
data structure a data structure is
essentially a manipulation of a if of an
object of an object of data and as as
you will see later python has one of the
most user-friendly data structures that
can be found in any language especially
compared to some of its contemporaries
now python is a dynamically programmed
language and this is very important and
what this means is that in most
compiler-based languages we there are
certain processes that can only happen
during the compilation stage so what a
dynamic programming language does is it
takes all those compilation specific
tasks and processes and it does it for
us as we actually type the code so we
don't need to waste time or spend extra
time to do something that would
otherwise be needed to be only done in
compilation we would have to set out
specific runtimes just for that so this
allows us to create our programs and
solutions much faster and allows us to
debug much easier and yeah so it's a
it's a very important feature about
python Now quickly I will just go over
some of the areas of python where like
areas of or different domains where
python is very heavily implemented and
the first one the first few ones that
come to reminder like web development
and Ai and machine learning so you have
Technologies like Django and Flash that
are built on top of python that I use
extensively for web development when it
comes to something like artificial
intelligence or machine learning you
have distributions such as Anaconda you
have pandas and many other libraries
like scipy and numpy that are used
extensively too so tackle problems in
this domain and similarly python finds
used in most of the scientific work that
goes on nowadays because of again some
of the libraries that I have already
mentioned such as sci-fi interestingly
if you are into game development or
gaming in general you would see that
python actually has certain libraries
and certain technologies that facilitate
game development very very well one very
popular game in fifth in case you are
into gaming is a world of tanks that is
built on python some of the other
applications are of course desktop be
creating desktop guise image processing
graphic design applications and
something that is very relevant to me
and of course you as well is a creation
of education programs and training
courses uh there are many Technologies
in the environment of python that were
almost designed for the specific purpose
of being able to present certain
Concepts or to be able to teach certain
classes and I can't think of too many
programs or too many environments
outside of python that are better to
solve these Education and Training
course related problems and situations
let's uh let's get to actually
installing python so now that so I will
show you how to install python on
Windows since I have a Windows system
however I will also point out the way
you you would have to install python on
a on Mac OS or Linux or even on mobile
so yeah let's get started so to install
python on your Windows computer it's as
simple as going to the website
python.org and selecting the download
section when you reduce click on
downloads you get redirected to this
website that this webpage that I'm on
out here it by default it will ask you
if you want to download python 3.9 which
is the latest version but of course if
you for whatever reason if you needed a
particular version of python you can
download that as well by just scrolling
down and choosing the option that you
want now it's important to note that
whatever option you choose of course I
would recommend the latest one but no
matter what option you choose I would
recommend you choose a version of python
three point something because previous
versions of python namely Python 2.7 and
uh and basically every version of python
two point something has it will not
receive any more maintenance and updates
because the developers have decided that
python will that trying to shift towards
the maintaining and updating python
three point whatever completely right
now so yeah let's not delay this uh any
further and let's download python 3.9 so
once you select the option out here uh
you'll be you'll get an installer all
you have to do is click on that and
it'll give you two options to customize
installation or install now I would of
course recommend this blue install now
since you're a beginner do not worry
about what a custom installation is if
you have multiple drives in your system
by default the python will be downloaded
into the drive where your windows is
actually installed your your main drive
so as you can see now that once my setup
is done it should give me a pop-up soon
so my setup is done for Python and this
is essentially how you would download
python on your Windows system but what
if you had Mac OS or if you were using
Linux well for Mac it's a it's actually
almost as simple you just go if you see
our here below this download button
python option you get the website asking
you are you looking for python on a
different OS and it gives you the
options of Linux Mac and even other os's
but for Mac if you wanted you would just
open this tab and just like the windows
option you would choose a version and
you would choose an installer for that
version so if I want to say python the
latest one I would just download this
installer and I would install in my Mac
system now when it comes to Linux I
cannot show you exactly how you would
install it there are certain commands
that you have to execute but essentially
again if you would just choose the Linux
option out here it will take you to a
page with a different installers and
essentially packages for Linux systems
in specific what I would recommend to
you if you are a Linux user and you need
python is to go over to the
realpython.com website and they have a
very good essentially instructions on
how to install Python and since I don't
have a Linux system them I cannot
directly show you how to install python
on Linux so yeah if you do have Linux
please head over to this website and
this should be of a lot of help to you
now as I had mentioned you can actually
install python on your mobile devices as
well so if you were say an iOS user you
would go to the iOS App Store and
download an app called the python is the
app for iOS it essentially is like a
full-fledged python environment where
you can develop in Python on your iPhone
or even iPad and if you're an Android
User you could you would go and download
an app called the pi Droid 3. there's a
free version and a paid version for this
app and of course the difference between
the free and paid is that the paid
supports uh code analysis and code
prediction these are certain details you
don't have to worry about right now and
honestly if I wouldn't worry too much
about installing python on your mobile
devices currently since I am assuming
most people would be learning Pro
programming and programming in Python on
their PCS or laptops what I had actually
shown you was installing what is called
an implementation of python on your
system and implementation is essentially
a program or a software or an
environment that allows you to actually
work in Python so what I showed you was
how to install the by default or the
most basic or reference implementation
that has been created by the developers
which is actually called C python even
though you were not you would not have
seen the word the letter c or the prefix
C but yeah that implementation that I
had I had downloaded myself and I had
shown you to download is actually the C
python implementation which is python
built on top of C the the C language
essentially there are other
implementations such as iron python
which uses the.net for network and J
python that uses Java virtual machines
that you could use if you were
interested but again these are things
that I would not worry about too much
check now so now that we have tackled on
how to install your implementation of
python I want to introduce what is
called a distribution to you this
distribution is called Anaconda Anaconda
is a very important distribution
especially if you are looking to use
python in data science and machine
learning and AI which I am assuming is
the motivation for many of the people
that are actually watching this video
that they actually want to move into
data science and they need to learn
python as a foundation towards moving
towards data science and if that is your
goal or in any case whatever your goal
may be I would recommend that you
install Anaconda distribution now do not
get confused between anaconda and python
their Anaconda is python with in the
form of a bundle and this bundle
contains not only the basic python
implementation that I had shown you to
download but it contains a lot of extra
libraries and Technologies and software
as well so of course this means that
what you need to download both of course
not if you download a python you do not
need Anaconda to work on Python and if
you have already downloaded Anaconda
which I will show you how to do it in
some time if you have already downloaded
Anaconda you don't need to download
python separately so I'll just speak
about Anaconda little briefly so as I
said it's a distribution it it contains
a bundle which includes the basic python
implementation and a lot of Technologies
and softwares and applications that have
essentially help us to use python in in
in specifically managing Big Data
applications and data science related
projects so so now I will show you
actually how to install python I mean
anaconda on your system it's as simple
as it's actually as simple as
downloading just this thing so if I did
a quick quick Google Anaconda
so the website that I'm looking for is
anaconda.com and I'm looking at products
and I'm looking at individual Edition
there are other editions as well like
commercial Team edition these are for
companies usually or uh for more
professional sort of projects so of
course we are looking at the individual
Edition and if you selected this page
you would be taken to this particular
web page where It'll ask you if you want
to download and again there are options
depending on which machine you're using
if you're using a Linux you would choose
one of these two if you are using Mac OS
you would use one of these two and since
I am a Windows user and I have a 64-bit
system this is the option I would use so
again it will it will first download and
install it for you and as you can see my
installer has been downloaded so upon
opening it it will open up this
installation thing you can you can just
click next on most of these again if you
want to specify your destination folder
you can change it here mine will be with
a default folder in the C drive and you
can leave this unticked you can you can
change these options much later so this
is how you install anaconda on Windows
and it's pretty much the same on other
systems as well now once it's done I
will show you what exactly what are some
of the things that Anaconda contains
that are not there if you installed
python like the way I had shown you
earlier just the bare bones python
implementation so as you can see here my
installation is actually complete and
now I will open anaconda and I'll show
you what how you can actually use this
Anaconda so if I search for an account
on my system I would look for something
called Anaconda navigator to actually
get started with this and when I open
that it should open something like this
so this is what opens when you click on
the Anaconda Navigator and as you can
see there are a bunch of applications
you don't need to worry about what these
mean right now just understand that this
this is essentially a bundle of
different applications and technologies
that come along with just the normal
installation of python that you get when
you install Anaconda Navigator now now
that we have actually tackled where
we've seen how to install and I'm hoping
and I would recommend definitely that
everyone is watching this video installs
Anaconda not just the normal python
installation or implementation now that
we have gotten all the introductions and
the basics and the installations
regarding python aside let's get right
let's get down to actually creating our
first script so now the question is how
do we actually start doing this task of
creating our first python script how do
we how do we realize uh now that we've
installed uh python like uh now let's
how do we start doing something so the
answer to that question is that
typically when you're working on python
the one of the most basic thing that you
can do is create a python script and
execute a script script is essentially a
sequence of commands and instructions
that you give for python to run and
execute to give you a certain result so
I will show you how you can create a
python script now there are multiple
ways of creating a python script you can
create it directly from command line
which is obviously something I would not
recommend because it is not convenient
and easy and it's not very useful for a
beginner another way is using a text
editor such as the one I have opened
right now which is the notepad plus plus
text editor now it's very important to
not get confused between notepad plus
plus and the standard notepad that comes
with your windows or wordpad for that
matter in fact text editors such as
notepad and wordpad that you are more
familiar with create text and files in a
form that is called Rich Text Now Rich
Text is something is text that contains
format and fonts which is actually a
hindrance when it comes to creating
actual code so what we need is a text
editor that creates or writes text in
what we call as plain text plain text is
obviously text which does not contain
these fonts and these formattings and it
only respects white spaces and
indentations those two being actually
useful towards creating code unlike
fonts and formatting which are only a
visual thing so notepad plus plus is
obviously a text editor that creates a
plain text documents that is very that
was actually created with programming in
mind obviously you can use a bunch of
other text editors such as whim and atom
and you can Google for these there are
plenty of them so without any further
Ado let's create our first python script
so one of the most common one of the
most famous examples of a first program
in any program for that matter not just
python is creating a print statement
that gives us a statement saying hello
world so enter in Python this is how you
would go about oh this is the syntax you
would use to create this statement
all right now weight is very important
when you are saving your Python program
that you use the dot py prefix so so if
I were to save this I can choose
whatever folder I am going to choose
yeah this folder seems fine so now I
give the file name over here as say I
want to keep it as test I need to prefix
this Dot py and this uh tells any uh
sort of interpreter or anytime we need
to read the script to know that it's a
python script we need to add a DOT py
otherwise it will not be treated as a
python script will be treated as some
normal document sort of a thing so now
that I have stored it as dot py I have
created my first python script now
obviously the next question is I need to
see what happens when I execute this
line when I run this script essentially
so to see that there are multiple ways
the first way that I will show you is a
command line method which is obviously
again before we get into it it's not
something that I will be using to teach
you it's not something I would recommend
you to immediately start using
um but for the sake of showing I will
show you how to execute a script in
command line well to do this you go
since I have installed anaconda in my
system and I will be using Anaconda to
work in Python what I will look for is
something called the Anaconda prompt as
you can see this is the option that I
get Anaconda prompt this will
essentially open you a command line
under the environment of anaconda or
python so in this now I am already in
the folder I believe that had my script
so how do I call this script or how do I
run this script well the command is
python space the name of my file which
was test of course the prefix is very
important so I enter test.py if you if
this was in a different folder you would
have to change your folders in command
line which is again something that I may
show you later but since my my file is
already in the folder that I am in in my
command line I would just have to enter
this Command right now so if I execute
this as you can see it's given me an
output of hello world which is which is
what I wanted I wanted it to print this
uh these two words and of course the
command line is now waiting for the next
command for me so this is uh one of the
most simple ways of or the most
rudimentary ways of executing a python
script now another question would be
well this isn't the most visually
appealing or not the easy to read or
easy to use way of executing scripts and
I would agree and that's why I'm going
to introduce a another technology or a
software called the IDE so the IDE in
python or in any programming language
stands for integrated development
environment it's essentially a software
that not only allows us to run scripts
but it allows us to create the scripts
it allows us to debug it allows us to
see outputs it allows us to see in
intermediary outputs it allows us to do
a wide variety of tools and tasks and it
comes with a bunch of robust features to
enhance our Python programming
experience so let's let's see so I will
show you a an IDE called spider which
comes bundled along with the Anaconda
distribution that I had mentioned
earlier so if I open the Anaconda
Navigator as you can see the Anaconda
Navigator shows me a bunch of
Technologies and options and I'm looking
for something called the spider IDE
which is over here as you here it's a
Scientific Python development
environment this is exactly what I'm
looking for so I am looking to launch
this so now that I've launched it you
can see out here this is what an IDE
looks like now this looks very
sophisticated and it's a it's a one and
any almost any IDE is a wonderful
software that where you can create your
code you can debug your code you can
check the results you can make
adjustments changes and you can do a
wide variety of tasks and functions with
relation to your programming so this is
the spider ID in particular and this is
how it looks don't worry about the exact
details just know that on this left hand
pane is our current script that is open
out here and out here we will get the
results in this this is what we call a
common solar console essentially
so now that we have we have already
created our script in notepad plus plus
and I want to open that script and I
want to see uh how an i how it would the
result of that script would look in an
IDE so let's just open it so we can
browse for our file and as I had named
it test this is the file over here I
open this and as you can see out here in
the left hand pane my script has opened
and the commander had given or had
written is out over here now if I want
to run this application I press this
green button and as you can see the
result of my my execution essentially is
over here it's in slightly small font
but as you can see over here it says
hello world and its way and the next
line is essentially it's it's waiting
for me to do another execution of the
script and then it will give me new
results so let's actually give the
system new results so now that I have
printed something called hello world
let's let's change what's written over
here let's say I will perform
basic maths all right and let's actually
perform the basic maths again don't
worry about the details the syntax uh
what I'm exactly doing these things that
we will actually cover in the in
upcoming videos and modules so let's
create a variable called a let's store a
number three let's create a variable B
Story number five all right let's create
another variable C uh which will store
the result of what's in a and b in the
addition of A and B all right and let's
print the result or print what's in uh
this variable C or what's the result of
a plus b I will print a statement saying
the result of the addition of three and
five is all right and I will put my
result over here as you can see I should
get the result in this pane so let's
execute this and you can see uh my first
line is executed saying I will perform
basic maths and the next line says the
result of the addition of three and five
is eight so this in this script what
I've done is I have performed uh two
print statements and I performed a basic
expression some variable assignments all
of these things we will be doing later
this is what I what I'm essentially
trying to show you is that Ides are a
very convenient way of not only creating
the scripts but actually seeing the
results and then making adjustments as
well we can come we can create a
completely new script we don't need to
create a script from some special file
or text editor I can just create a new
file here and this is my new script
essentially so I can start working on
with this new script right over here
from the get go so Ides are very
powerful spider IDE comes bundled with
Anaconda there are other ideas such as
the idle IDE it stands for indicated
development and learning environment so
the idle IDE comes as part of the basic
python implementation that I had shown
you in the previous video where if you
just installed a basic uh python
implementation it would come along with
a basic IDE known as Idle or integrated
development and learning environment but
of course since we are using Python and
this is what I would recommend it comes
with a more robust IDE called spider
which is actually very very helpful for
scientific and numeric applications and
was designed specifically with that in
mind now this is not the only way we can
actually work with python there's
another very interesting and a very
educative method of it in Python let's
say python programs and it's something
that I will be using extensively
throughout this course to explain
different concepts so this technology is
called or the software is called uh
notebooks now before I get into the
details I will state I will just open
node a basic notebook so the notebook
that comes as part of anaconda is called
the Jupiter notebook and when I open or
when I launch the Jupiter notebook this
is what I get now a very important
feature or a a feature of notebooks is
that notebooks are a web browser or a
web-based application so you it's not
something that you can use if you are
offline or disconnected basically if
you're disconnected from the internet it
is something where which for which you
would need an active internet connection
however it is way more robust and it has
very very good properties that allow it
to be used in education or for
presentation and such so as you can see
this is my Jupiter notebook these are a
bunch of folders don't need to worry
about what these are right now I will
show you how to create a fresh notebook
so if you go here now you go to new and
you select under notebook the Python 3
option it will open you your first
notebook as you can see this line is
essentially waiting for me to enter some
sort of a command or a statement that I
would give in a normal python thing now
if you would have noticed the diff in uh
until now everything that we were doing
involved us creating a script which was
the whole series of commands and
functions so if I go back to my spider
IDE as you can see like this is a whole
script and this script contains multiple
different tasks and functions that are
individually being performed so this is
a separate print function this is a
separate Edition another separated print
function and for longer programs what
larger programs you like you'll have
multiple different tasks being done and
if you were using a script you can only
see the result of something like this by
executing the whole thing at once you
cannot see exactly like uh what is the
result of just this print statement or
just this uh it's not typically what an
IDE is used for and this is where
notebooks come in super handy if I had
to break down my previous script
essentially where I first did a print
statement where I said some random thing
say hello
yeah so if I execute this particular
line you can see it gives me the result
now I want to do what is 5 plus 3 it
should give me the result over here
eight now in the next another part of
your program might be storing five and
three into variables so I can do this
and I can do this so now this line will
store the variables now I want to do the
addition of what is five plus three but
I want to use the variables and I want
to see what's the result as you can see
a plus b means 5 plus 3 which is 8 and
I've essentially broken down various
different parts of my previous script
into into its individual tasks and I'm
able to see what each part of that
script does and this is very good when
it comes to making presentations or
trying to teach a class so I will
personally be using notebooks a lot to
explain different different concepts of
um different concepts when it comes to
Python and I would recommend that you
get used to notebooks in general because
it's an amazing way to Learn Python
Programming or programming in general in
fact and again as I had mentioned
earlier notebooks are something that
it's an online application it's a
web-based application so I will have to
need a active internet connection to be
able to work on a notebook which could
be a disadvantage if you do not have a
consistent internet connection and in
that case you would probably use your
Ides or text editor which you can be
used offline as well in this video we
will be introduced to the concept of
variables and expressions let's start
with Expressions well an expression in
Python is anything that results in a
value its difference although the
difference between an expression and a
standard statement in Python is that a
statement in Python is something that
results in an action or an execution of
a command there is no calculation per se
or any sort of manipulation or as I said
audio calculation resulting in between
two different say numbers or other
objects that results in a value and this
happens in the case of an expression so
for example if I were to add two numbers
say 5 plus 10 this is an expression
which should where two objects 5 and 10
are being added and a result has been
given to me which is 15. now let's see
an example of a statement well a
statement could be something like a
print statement so when I ask python to
print something for me it's not
calculating anything it's not evaluating
anything it's simply performing an
action that I have or a command that I
have given the system which is to print
whatever I have entered over here as you
can see so this is a statement similarly
there are another type of statement
known as assignment statements which we
will learn actually right in the next
section well let's move on to variables
right now now earlier you might have
learned about objects in Python so
objects are essentially data that we can
work with a manipulate in Python now
variables are a place to store these
different objects
usually it's much easier to store
objects in Python instead of using the
objects explicitly themselves because
objects may be very compute complicated
whereas variables are very simple to use
and very simply very named in a very
simple manner so that we can use them
quite often in our programs now it's
important to note that in Python we do
not have to explicitly declare or Define
a variable to create them in fact
variables are created in the same
statement where we assign some object to
the variable in Python the assignment of
variables happens using the assignment
operator which is the equals design so
if I were to if I wanted to assign a
number say 100 to a variable say B well
it would be as simple as doing this now
anytime I want to know what is stored in
B I just have to enter B and I will get
the value that is stored in it and we
can store different types of objects
inside any variable let's say I store I
want to store this particular word in
the form of a string now this is stored
in X and if I want to know what is an X
I can just see what is here and it's a
string hello which I had stored earlier
now it's very important that we follow
certain naming rules when it comes to
naming our variables in python or else
we may be thrown errors or we might get
some problems in our program
so the first rule is that you cannot
start your variable name with a number
so if I were to give a variable name
like 4 num is equal to something say the
same string hello this would be an
illegal variable name and I would get an
error when I try this so if I were to
choose a num 4 is equal to hello this
would be perfectly fine I won't get an
error the second rule is we are not
allowed to use any
non-alphanumeric characters except the
underscore character while naming our
variable so for example if I were to
name my variable num underscore 4 and I
stay I said random some random string
this is perfectly fine however if I
change num underscore 4 to num hyphen 4
this will throw me an error as you can
see over here next the third rule is
that variable names are case sensitive
so if if I have a variable called num or
say n-u-m if this was one of my
variables and I stored say the value 50.
this is not the same as me writing num
all in capitals and say storing some
other value 60 these are two different
variables so it's very important that
when you name your variables you are
aware of what case you are writing them
in because python variables are case
sensitive now the final and probably one
of the most important rules in Python is
that you're not allowed to use what we
call Reserve words in Python now python
has a bunch of reserved words these
words essentially are
before or they are certain and I use
their identifiers for certain special
functions in Python that we that have a
special purpose like that particular
word has a special purpose within the
Python programming language and he
cannot use them to name our variables so
a list of them as you can see over here
some of them are like false deaf if uh
Del Rays and there are like are there
are around 33 of them and sometimes some
of these words are taken out sometimes
there are more words added as python
gets updated now let's let's move on to
a concept uh where we try to really
understand what do we mean by storing
data inside a variable now when I say
that we are storing something inside a
variable you get an image or you get an
idea in your head that this variable is
like a container where we store or we
put a particular object inside it so
does this mean that variables have a
place in the memory or they are also an
object that is placed in the memory
where we can put other objects inside of
well I'll show you an example where this
idea is kind of disproven or where I'll
show you that the idea of variable is
kind of different than what we
understand by storing something inside a
variable now let's say I'm storing the
same object I will take this object as
some random number let's say 100 and I'm
going to store it into two different
variables so I take X is equal to 100
over here and in the next line I will
store 100 in y as well now if objects
were I mean if variables were objects
that we placed in our system then X and
Y should have two different IDs but
let's see what happens when I check the
ID of X and the ID of Y they should be
different in case variables were their
own objects however as you can see the
ID of X and the ID of Y are exactly the
same so well obviously we know that two
different objects in Python cannot have
the same ID e so does this so what does
this mean when it comes to the nature of
a variable well the the fact is that
variables are not actually objects in
Python in fact variables are more like
pointers or references to the actual
object so when I said X is equal to 100
and Y is equal to 100 what I am actually
telling the system is that there is this
variable name called X that I want to
refer or Point towards the actual object
that is in my memory called 100 and I do
the same thing with another variable y
so I am not exactly creating a different
space in my system for these variables
these variables are more like
placeholders or references that point to
a particular place in the memory where
this object is located and that is what
happens when I do ID of X and ID of Y
it's not giving me the idea of something
called X or the ID of something called Y
is giving me the ID of 100 each time
because 100 is stored in X and Y so as
you you can see this is something like a
visual representation of what I'm trying
to say and similarly if if I were to so
in this example on the left as you can
see I've used the value of 50 to explain
my point so as you can see initially X
and Y are pointing towards this value 50
because I have stored 50 and 50 in both
X and Y now what if I changed the object
that is stored in X well that means X is
now pointing towards this new object and
I have stored this new object called
hello the string called hello as you can
see here so now X is pointing to a new
object in this system and it's called
hello and I haven't changed anything
with respect to Y so y will Point
towards the same thing and I can also
make the pointer of Y different or what
I'm trying to say is I can store
something else in y see I stored this
list in y 50 60 and 100 and when I do
that now Y is pointing towards a
different object in Python and actually
also pointing towards something else so
what happens to this object 50 well now
that there's no variable referring to
this object 50 it becomes what we call
an orphaned object and we can actually
see that when we do the ID of X now
let's go back to my example on the right
where I stored X is equal to 100 so as
you can see it gives me some ID
represented by this number now let's say
I stored x i stored something different
in like say 200 now if I do the idea of
X it should give me a different ID
because as you can see the values are
different and this is because this
object 200 is what is stored in X and
when I do the ID of X I'm actually
getting the ID of this new object now
200 so as you can see Point as you can
see variables are they should be and
they are treated more like references or
pointers instead of containers for a
particular object in this video you will
be introduced to the concept of objects
in Python now what are objects in python
well all the data that we manipulate or
use in our operations in our code are
represented as objects or relations
between objects so if you want an
example two numbers that you add in your
code well both of them are objects and
the usually numeric type objects
similarly if you want to store someone's
name or an address of your hometown in
your code you usually store it in a form
of text and that text is also an object
usually a string similarly you might
want to create a container of different
smaller objects inside them and that big
container is also a type of an object
and one of those containers are called
lists and similarly we have many
different types of objects which we will
be covering during the duration of this
course the following pictorial
representation gives us a broad
classification of different python data
types and objects as we can see there
are five broad classifications numeric
which contains integers complex numbers
and floats we have the dictionary data
type we have the Boolean which
essentially consists of objects that
have only two valid values true or false
then we have sets and we have sequence
data types such as strings lists and
tuples every object in Python has three
important properties that kind of Define
that particular object they are its
identity its type and its value the
identity of an object is it can be
considered as a place in the memory or
its address in the memory where an
object is stored an object's identity
does not change one at once it has been
created so for example if I took an
example of say a string called hello I
can use the ID function which is this is
how you use the ID function to find out
the ID of this object and it should be
the answer should be in the form of a
particular long in integer so as you can
see the ID of hello is this integer two
three two six four seven six six two
three zero two four similarly all
objects in Python have an identity we
have another operation with uh regarding
the identity of an object is the is
operator and the is operator compares
the identity of two objects so if two
objects have the same identity it should
give the answer true otherwise false now
the next property of objects is the type
type of an object is essentially what
defines what kind of values and
operations that that object can have so
for example in numeric data type in
Python such as an integer would allow us
to do arithmetic operations and
similarly string object type in Python
will allow us to do concatenation
operations much like its identity the
type of an object cannot be changed as
well now let's see what's the type of
that particular object that I had show
shown you above as you can see it should
be straight Str stands for string
similarly if I did a type for a number
say 50 it should give me int as you can
see now the third property of an object
in Python is its value now the value is
the actual data that is contained in the
object it's the thing that we use that
we display that we can manipulate and
that we can perform operations on so for
example if I were to talk about this
string this string is hello so the value
of the string is the word or the
sequence of letters that spell out hello
and similarly this particular object is
a numeric object with the value of 50.
let's see in this in this pictorial
representation I have shown you that you
can assume this dodge Blue Area as the
memory of the system now within this
memory we have objects created called 50
and hello and this list containing
smaller objects called cat pen and 40.
now what I'm trying to show you here is
each of these objects have a type and ID
and a value and let's see what they are
so if I wanted to see as we had already
seen the type of 50 now let's find the
ID of 50 as you can see we get this
unique ID for the object 50 which is
obviously not the same as the ID of the
object hello above and the value of this
object is the value of s50 itself so
that was a brief introduction into
objects in Python in this video we will
cover the topics of numeric object types
and type conversions in Python now let's
get started numeric object types in
Python are a broad classification of
objects plenty of common real life
applications that we associate with
numerals such as arithmetic operations
and calculus are done in Python using
numeric object data types there are
three main types of numerals or numeric
data types in Python they are integers
float and complex integers as the name
suggests represent all integer values in
Python these can be such as 100 minus 3
to 305 and so on floats are used to
represent new rules that contain decimal
points such as 100.3 3.9 4.8 minus 6.8
and so on then there is the complex
object type which is used to represent
complex numbers in Python and this is an
example of a complex number 3 plus 7j
this is a complex number three plus
seven J where the real component is 3
and the imaginary component is 7. all
complex numbers have a real and an
imaginary component and this is how we
denote them now it's important to note
that this J is a very common symbol in
maths and Engineering used to denote the
imaginary portion of a complex number
and it's the same in python as well so
moving on let's talk about type
conversion in Python type conversion
refers to the conversion of an object
from one data type to another for
example from sting to an integer and
there are different types of conversions
and let's go through some of them first
of all let's consider the conversion of
something to an integer and more
specifically let's consider the example
where we convert a string to an integer
so let's consider my example string to
be some something called 145 and I'm
sewing this within a string for a reason
because I want to convert a string to an
integer so as you can see I have stored
this one for 5 within my within a
variable X and if I were to confirm that
is actually an integer I can use the
type function and see that it is
actually an integer Str now let's
convert this into an integer using the
int function so how would we use it is
simply passing the End by passing the
variable that we want to convert into
the in function and as you can see this
is what I've done over here but before
this I will also store it into an
another variable all right now let's see
what's in y well y gives us 1 4 5 but
are we sure that it's an end we can just
check it by using the type function and
as you can see the type gives us the
answer int that means that we've
converted the string to an end
interestingly we can convert something
and also specify what base we have to
treat the number as by default when we
pass something in the in function the
programmer python will treat whatever we
have passed within the string as
something in base sub decimal but what
if we were to pass something that is
well not in a decimal we could do it
like this now let's store Y and in y
let's store
let's do this and I will show you what
this means X and I will give a comma and
eight what this tells python is well I
want to convert the string in X into an
integer but I want to treat whatever is
an X as a number of Base 8 so 145 is
actually 145 in the base 8. now when we
see what's in y we get 101 which is
different to 145 because well 1 0 1 is
actually the decimal equivalent of 145
in the base 8. similarly if we were to
give it in the base 2 we would just
replace 8 with 2 over here now next
let's talk about converting something to
a float now as we know float is just
simply something that has a decimal
point so let's convert an integer into a
float how would we do that simply by
using the float function so if I give
120 and I pass this integer through the
float function I should get 120.0 and
these two are not the same though they
may mean the same things to us but in
for python 120 is an integer and one
with 120.0 is a different object which
is a float and this is how we convert
something to a float now what if we
wanted to convert an integer to a string
well we can use the Str function we can
also use the hex and the oct function if
we want to convert a particular number
to a hexadecimal or an octal string
respectively let's look at all three
examples say I have a number 688 and I
want to convert this into a string I
just use the Str function around this so
as we know just to confirm let's see
what the type of 688 is this is this
should be an end as we can see but when
we pass when we let's say we convert it
into a string 688 and let's store it
into some variable let's call it a all
right now let's see what's in a it gives
688 in the form of a string but we can
confirm by checking the type of a it is
an Str so it is a string similarly we
can use hex if we wanted to convert an
integer into its hexadecimal equivalent
in the in in as an output of a string as
you can see this comp this or is sort of
complicated thing is actually telling us
that we have converted 688 in terms of
hexadecimals now how do we read this
output this zero should not be treated
as anything it's more like a an
identifier which says that the letter
after this first 0 is the base of this
whole number so it's saying that x x
stands for hexadecimal so it's saying
that 2 B 0 is to be treated as a
hexadecimal number and if you did basic
maths you would find that the decimal
equivalent of 2b0 is 688 similarly if I
did opt if I use the oct function for
688 it will give me the result something
like this so again how to read this the
first 0 is to be treated as an
identifier and not part of the number
what it's saying is the letter after the
first or after this 0 is the base of the
number of the fourth character I enter 4
here so as you can see it gives me A R A
and D which is everything from the
fourth character of my string random to
the left similarly if I wanted something
to the right of it I would just do it
like this I would enter some index here
and I would leave the portion to the
right of the colon blank so this will
give me everything including the third
character since this is how we treat the
indexing in Python everything including
the third character all the way to the
right so this is Dom as you can see now
another perfectly valid um slicing is
same I want to slice or take out
different characters from the string but
I want to skip certain characters like I
want this one then I want to skip one
and I want to take the next one and then
I want to skip one well in that case we
have to introduce a step so one way of
doing this is now how do we read this so
as you can see I've written 0 colon six
colon two so what this is telling python
is I want every character from my string
test uh starting from the zeroth
character up until the sixth but not
including the sixth after skipping or
taking two at a time taking two at a
time can also be assumed as skipping one
at each step or skipping one character
at each step so what this will do is it
will go to random it will take zeroth
one we'll take R and then it will skip
the next one so it will not consider a
and then it will pick n and then it will
not consider D and then it will consider
o up until the sixth character which
whichever that may whichever that may be
and if you see the output it gives us R
and O which is exactly what we wanted we
wanted R we wanted n we wanted o where
we skipped uh A and D or we skipped the
every second character essentially so
this is the way of
um slicing strings while also skipping
certain characters or skipping's
characters and steps now python is also
an uh there's another interesting
technique that we can use in Python to
where we can start retrieving characters
from the rightmost side of a sequence or
a string we can use negative indexes so
if I were to for example show you let's
see what this what this gives me test
what what is a minus one index it gives
me the character M now remember a string
Is Random so minus 1 gave us the last
character of the string random which was
m so this is a way of using negative
indexes and similarly if I used test
minus 2 it would give me the second
class character which should be the
character o as you can see here now
there are some other important functions
that you may use in Python for that
let's create another let's create
another string let's call it upper lower
all right I'm sorting it again in the
same variable test let's see what
happens when I use the upper function
and what happens when I use the lower
function
now I'm going to use the lower function
for this these two functions will
respectively give out or give us the
result or give us our string in
uppercase and lowercase respectively so
as you can see the upper function
created the first string in full
uppercase and the second one created
this by the string in four lowercase now
another important and probably one of
the most important methods that we use
for Strings especially when it comes to
data science is the split function so
let's see what I mean by split function
let me create another string let's call
it hello world
all right and I'm going to use a split
function and I'm going to see what
happens when I use this function
essentially so what I'm doing in these
in this these three lines is I'm
creating the string hello world I am
storing it in test and then I am using
the split function on the test and
whatever result I get I'm storing
another variable called sliced and then
I'm just going to show you what is in
sliced as you can see what's happened to
the string hello world is that I have
broken it into its components or its
component words if that makes any sense
into hello and world and I've stored
both of these into what we call a list
now you might ask well how does python
know that it has to separate at a blank
space well the split function by default
will break up a string at its blank
spaces but if we wanted we could break
it up using or at every comma so for
example if I wrote hello world using
comma and if I put a comma inside over
here and now if I try to execute this
like for example I am going to find I'm
going to look for commas in the string
and I'm gonna try to split it as you can
see there's no splitting happening I
have one list with my original string
itself because it's not found a comma
what if I introduced a comma over here
now let's see what happens as you can
see the splitting has happened it's
found this comma and is caused a split
between hello and World similarly if I
in my string if I put this comma again
and I put something else it should give
me the split over there again so we can
Define our split using some whatever we
put between these Circle brackets after
the split function it's just important
to note that by default if in case we do
not enter anything over here it will use
blank spaces to do the splitting uh
another very important operation and
very common operation in strings is what
we call concatenation so if I have two
strings first and say another string
second and I want to join these together
well the operator I would use to do this
is called the plus symbol this is the
concatenating operator when it comes to
Strings so what is the result of this
let's see let's print this out let's
print this whole thing and let's see
what is the result as you can see what
this has done is it has combined the
first string first and the string second
into one string called first second so
this is the concatenated concatenation
operator now finally uh the last Topic
in this lesson is the topic of Escape
sequences now Escape sequences are
special commands that tell python to
either suppress special meaning of some
character or symbol in a string or give
or give the special or give some special
meaning to an otherwise ordinary
character in a string so let's look at
the first example now remember my in my
for earlier in this video where I was I
was telling you like what what is the
way of writing or how do we introduce
single quotes or double quotes into a
string and I had told you the trick if I
want to use single coat in my string I
just close it using double quotes or if
I want to use a double quote I close it
using single well another way of doing
this is using what we call an escape
sequence and an escape sequence in
Python is the backslash character all
right so let's see what happens when I
use the backslash character where I want
to introduce my single code so if I use
my previous example where I wanted to
introduce a single quote and say I am
going to close it using single quotes as
well so I'm gonna go back to my error
example so as to speak now this would
throw me an error right as you can see
it has thrown me an error so what if I
used the escape sequence that I
mentioned the Escape sequences is
backslash character now this is the
point of the string where I want my my
single code so I introduce a backslash
now I have my single quote and I
continue writing the rest of my
statement let's close the string now
will this work as you can see this has
worked so what this has done is this
backside character has told python to
not read this special character or the
single quote to not treat it specially
and let it be as a part of the string so
as you can see that's what's happened
here now the next case or the other uh
use case of Escape sequences is when we
want to give a particular character that
is otherwise just ordinary some special
meaning so let's take the example of the
character T and the character n we use
the character T to introduce tab space
and Views a character in to introduce
what we call line break well let's see
by an example so normally the character
T has no special function so the
character T within a string will just be
outputted as the character T itself
however as you can see here I'm going to
introduce a backslash before this
character t
let's see what it does it introduces
this thing that we called a tab space
which is a larger than normal space
similarly if I were to use the backslash
n combination this would introduce what
we call a line break
and if you were to see the output of
this you can see at the point of the
string where I have this combination of
backslash m a line break has occurred so
uh there are plenty of other Escape
sequences that you may choose to learn
and uh these are just two of the
probably the most common ones that are
used in this video I will give you an
introduction into lists and tuples
starting off with lists lists are a
collection of ordered orbit arbitrary
objects that are similar to what we call
an array in other programming languages
but lists are way more flexible when it
comes to python python lists are a type
of sequence and we might have you might
have seen what the sequence is when we
were learning about strings and much
like in sequences or any other sequence
list objects are assigned a numerical
index and whenever you want to
manipulate an object in a list we use
its respective index how do we Define
lists the lists are defined using square
brackets so this is a way or a simple
list that I have just created and
assigned to a variable a which contains
three objects one two and three let's
talk about some of the features of
python lists python lists are ordered
and what this means is that even if two
lists contain the exact same elements if
they if the elements are placed in a
different order the two lists are
actually unique and different and I can
check that over here I have created a
list one two and three and see if I
create another list two and one and
three the same elements were in
different order I will use the is
function to check whether these two
lists are the same and if they are the
same when I use is function it should
give me the value or the answer true and
if they are not the same it should give
me the value false and as you can see I
get the value false because even though
I have two lists with the same elements
they are in different orders and so they
are different and that's what we mean by
lists are ordered the next property for
lists are that they can be manipulated
using their indexes or the elements and
the objects inside a list can be
manipulated using the indexes and we
will see that in the section where I
show you list operations the next
property is lists are mutable what this
means is that once we create a list
object we can actually make changes and
modify them without having to create a
new list object the next property is
that lists a dynamic and what this means
is that as we are making or as we are
programming we can actually make changes
to an already created list as we are
programming without having to go through
a compilation stage so if we had to say
increase the or we had to add certain
elements to an already created list that
original list grows in size to
accommodate for these new elements the
next property is that lists can contain
any arbitrary objects so if I created a
list right now where say if I want to
store some numbers
say some floating Point numbers now
and I can put strings as well into my
list all of these are valid uh when it
comes to objects that can be put inside
a list we have no such restrictions so
we can put any arbitrary objects inside
our list the final property that I want
to talk about is that lists are they can
be nested to any arbitrary depth what
this means is that I can put a list
within a list and I can keep nesting it
essentially by putting as many lists I
want within my list and I'm only
essentially restricted by my systems
memory so if I created a list like this
within this say I put any other list and
within this list I put another list I
can keep going on to by keep going on
doing this and I'm only restricted by
the memory of my system that I'm using
so moving on let's move on and talk
about some important list operations
that we will be doing when it comes to
lists so let's create a basic list
called a where I'm storing six numbers
so now say if I want to retrieve a
particular element say if I want to find
out what's on the index 3 this is how I
would do it if I wanted a slice of my
original list and much like strings I do
it the same way so what this does is it
tells python that I want all the
elements of list a from index 1 to index
4 but not including index 4. so it'll
give me one two and three index objects
so it should give me 2 3 and 4 in this
case as you can see here two three and
four I can do the same thing by
considering elements say two at a time
if I wanted to consider elements or
consider every second element what I
would do is this syntax I would use this
syntax and when I give this command to
python what it tells what it understands
is I want every element from a from
index 1 to index 4 but not including
index 4 but I am going to consider
considered to every second
element essentially so what it will do
is it will go here and then it will skip
one and then go here and then Skip One
and that's essentially what we uh what
it's essentially what we call
slicing by using strides so I'm taking
strides I'm not considering elements
consecutively but I'm skipping certain
elements in between if I wanted to
consider every third element I would
change this to three and fourth element
double changes to Fourth all right so
let's see what happens when I take every
second element it should give it should
give me uh it will consider say from one
to index three right so you should
consider essentially this section but
since it's going to skip one it's going
to consider this skip this and then
consider this it should give me two and
four as you can see it has given me two
and four and like in other sequences we
can use negative indexes as well
negative indexing essentially starts
looking from the right hand side of the
list so when I say A minus y one it's
essentially looking at the last element
of the list so it gives me the sixth or
the last element which is the which is
the object six if I did a minus two it
gives me the second last element
similarly another neat trick that we can
use for sequences is the following
syntax double colon and we give a minus
one what this tells the what this tells
the system is I want the list a but with
all the elements reversed so as you can
see I get my element uh my list a but
the elements have been reversed right
now let's move on to uh concatenation
and replication well concatenation much
like in strings is done by using the
plus sign so as we know on either side
of the plus sign should be two similar
objects so if I'm doing a plus something
a being a list on the other side it
should be a list as well so let's add a
list like this now let's see what's in a
as you can see my origin list has a 789
added to it and I can also add things to
the beginning of a list similarly so if
I wanted to add say zero you know at the
beginning for this I just do it like
this
and I get the element 0 added to it it's
very important to note that I I actually
added 0 within a list because if I did 0
like this it will throw me an error
because like this 0 is just an end
object and it's not a list but when I
put the square brackets I make it a list
and then this concatenation becomes
valid because a is also a list similarly
if I did a star 2 this is essentially
replication or a replication function
where I'm repeating the values in a
twice if I did a star 3 it's the same
function but now I'll have the elements
repeated Thrice as you can see here
let's move on to modifying list values
uh this also shows the mutable property
of lists that I had mentioned earlier so
let's consider this example so I created
a list with elements where there's the
three strings eggs apples and carrots
and I have five int objects one two
three four and five now if I wanted to
change say the first element all I have
to do is take the 0th index and say if I
want to replace eggs with same mango
this is how I would do it now replaced
eggs with mango if I check what's in B
you can see the eggs have been replaced
with the element mango similarly I can
use the slice syntax to replace a
particular slice from my list with a
slice essentially so let's look at this
I'm replacing I want to replace the
first three elements I want to replace
mango I want to replace apple and carrot
so what I will do is I will consider
this since this carrot is the second
index so I will consider 0 to 3 because
third is not counted now I'm going to
replace this with three different
um let's see kiwi
and say sponge now let's check what's in
B you can see my three elements have
been replaced in fact I don't have to
replace like for like if I want to
replace say three elements with only one
or two elements that is also possible so
now if I want to replace the first three
elements kiwi orange and sponge
with um just one element this is how
I'll do it let's say wine now let's
check what's here as you can see three
elements have been replaced with one
mine I can double vice versa as well I
can replace smaller number of elements
with a larger number of elements but
here there is a slight caveat that I
want to show you so an obvious way of
doing this would be say if I wanted to
replace the first element wine with
three different elements an obvious way
would be just consider that elements
index and then put whatever objects you
want say I want to add instead of wine I
want to add beer I want to add ball and
say Club yeah well let's see what
happens now if I say B check what's
inside my you can see my elements have
been added but they seem to have been
added as is you know I had entered a
list over here and that whole list has
been replaced uh or this wine has been
replaced by this whole list in the first
position but that's not exactly what I
want wanted I wanted the elements within
this list to be individually placed into
my list and the way to do that is not
this syntax but actually what I'm going
to show you now if you want to replace
one if I want to replace the index of
the object at index 0 I would give this
statement a slice statement where I will
give 0 colon 1 so when I do this and if
I
um so let's create my old scenario again
where I had wine and I had one two three
four and five now if I do this B 0 but I
give a slice then this slice is
essentially a single object slice it's
essentially the zeroth index again but
because of this formatting or this this
type of syntax that I'm using what
python will do is now when I say peer
and ball and club now what python will
do is it will not consider this whole
list and add it to in place of uh wine
or whatever I want to replace it will
actually consider the elements inside of
this individually and then replace so if
you see here now if you see my list I
actually have the I've removed wine and
in place of it I've put beer ball in
club but these three are actually
individual objects within my list and
not objects within a list that is then
placed within my original list so this
is an important caveat that you should
take note of so moving on let's talk
about certain methods Associated to
lists let's take a simple list now one
two and three the first operation that I
want to show you or the first method is
the append method so when I do a append
and say if I want to append the list by
one object called four I just do it like
this now let's see what's in a I put so
as you can see the append has put the
object 4 into my original list now say
if I wanted to append three different
objects I want to append five six and
seven now let's see what a pen function
does oh no as you can see it's done a
similar operation to what we have seen
earlier when we gave a single index or
the single element replacement uh that
we saw earlier it essentially put this
whole list into this particular spot
into the list and this is not what I
wanted I wanted five six and seven to be
individually placed and we do have a way
of doing that and the way to do that is
the extend function that is what I'll
show you next now if I want to extend
Say the original list by three different
elements eight nine ten when I use the
extend function it will not put this
whole thing it will consider each object
inside this thing individually and then
add it to a so if you see my result this
is exactly what I wanted now the next
method that I want to discuss is the
remove method so the remove method is uh
what you how you use it is within the
parenthesis you put the object that is
present in the list that you want to
removed so you don't give an index over
here you give the object itself so if I
want the object eight all right this
number if I want 8 itself removed what I
will do is put the value 8 here and it
will remove it from my list so if I
check my list a as you can see the value
8 has it's gone an X another similar
function to remove is the pop function
now the pop function by default will
remove the rightmost value from the list
but unlike remove the pop function
actually outputs a value and that value
is what we have popped out of the list
so by default it will pop out the right
route right most value of a list all
right most element of a list and in this
case that element is 10 so it should
give me 10 but of course if we want to
pop out any particular object in this
case we will not give that particular
object we give its index so now say if I
want to remove this uh this list object
from my bigger list
um as I can see it's in index 0 1 2 3 4.
it's the fourth index so if I want to
remove the list which is at the fourth
index I give the index value inside the
parenthesis and it pops that out for me
as you can see over here so this was it
for list let's move on to tuples next so
tuples are another ordered collection of
objects much like lists but they differ
from lists in two Key Properties first
of all the tuples are defined using
parent thesis instead of square brackets
so this is how I would Define a tuple
with elements one two and three and the
next very important property that is
different or that differentiates tuples
from lists is that tuples are immutable
and what this means is that once we
create an object of type Tuple we cannot
make any modifications to it we would
have to only create create a new object
if we wanted something different and
this is obviously a key difference
between a tuple and a list but apart
from this every operation that we have
done on lists are actually possible to
do in the case of tuples as well so any
operation that we did to lists that did
not modify the list or that does not do
any modification we can actually apply
to tuples as well so if I wanted the
first element of this difficult all I
have to do is call it by the index 0 it
should give me the value 1 as you can
see if I wanted a slice I can do that as
well it should give me 2 and 3 and if I
wanted to reverse my Tuple well I can
use my same neat technique that I've
used for lists and that I can use for
the sequence I mean strings as well so
it gives me my old Tuple but with the
elements reversed so now the natural
question is why do we use Tuple server
lists well one important difference is
that when we can when we make a program
execution where or where we are
manipulating a tuple if we did the same
thing for the exact same objects in uh
that if it were present in a list it
would be much faster in a tuple
essentially program execution is just
faster on tuples when compared to an
identical list so use tuples over this
when we want to be efficient while we
are creating an ordered list of objects
so whenever we create an order ordered
list of objects that we don't need to or
we don't want to make any further
modifications to we don't need to create
a list we can create a tuple and another
very important area where we use tuples
over list or why we need a tuple instead
of a list is when we are using
dictionaries dictionaries as we will see
later is a data type in Python that
needs an immutable component while we
are creating the dictionary so if we
want to use something that is like a
list but since lists are mutable we can
use a tuple instead and use that when we
are creating our dictionary and we will
see like what what I mean by the
immutable component for a dictionary
when we actually learn about
dictionaries but yeah these are some of
the places where we would use a tuples
over a list a brief section on Tuple
unpacking and packing is what I would be
doing right now and what that means is
that when I create when I give this sort
of a statement
you can assume this to be me packing
this Tuple into a object or a
variability now what's very interesting
is and this is something that's very key
to tuples is that I can unpack a tuple
onto another Tuple so let me show you
what I mean by that so now that I have
packed one two three and four Tuple into
T let's unpack it into another Tuple
let's call this let's uh put these
elements into this Tuple and I put this
into T alright now let's see what I mean
by unpacking something onto something
let's see what's the what what happens
when I put a if I just want to see
what's in a it actually gives me the
value one if I see what's in B it gives
me the value 2 if I see what's in 3 will
be value three and D gives me value four
so essentially if you think of it what I
have done is I have matched this Tuple
then put it into T and then put that
Tuple T into this Tuple a b and c d so
what it's what what has happened
essentially is the element a has been or
a better way to say this would be the
element one has been packed onto or
unpacked onto a two has been unpacked on
to B three has been unpacked onto C 4
has been unpacked onto D to show you
what I've done in a single line is
essentially this this is essentially
what I've done
I have assigned 1 to a 2 to B 3 to C 4
to D I have matched these two tuples
together like this and this is a very
neat feature of tuples the only only uh
important thing that you have to keep in
mind is the elements of this Tuple and
the elements of this Tuple uh should be
equal so if there are four elements here
there should be four elements here all
right in fact another very important
thing about or a neat feature is that we
don't really need to mention the
parenthesis when we're doing this uh
unpacking or packing so if I did X comma
y comma Z if I did it like this if I put
say 5 and 6 and 7 this is also a valid
way of packing and unpacking so now if I
see what's the value in X it is actually
five if I see what's the value in y it
is six if I see what is the value of x
and z it should give me a tuple
containing five and seven as you can see
over here so this is a neat feature of
tuples called packing and tracking in
this video we will cover Concepts
surrounding dictionaries dictionaries
are another type of composite data type
in Python there are also a collection of
objects much like tuples and lists and
like lists they are also mutable Dynamic
and can be nested however a key
difference and property of dictionaries
is that they are unordered items and
dictionaries are paired using keys
unlike enlists and tuples where the
objects are assigned numerical indexes
to define a dictionary we use curly
braces each key value pair in this
dictionary in a dictionary is separated
using commas and the key and values
themselves in a pair are separated using
a colon let's look at an example this is
a dictionary where I have three key
value pairs as you can see they have
been separated by colons and each repair
themselves are separated by commas and
these are enclosed in curly braces to
define the whole dictionary in this
example the these are the keys banana
apple and grape and their respective
values are yellow red and green so this
is very important that in this
particular data type we have what we
call a key and that key is assigned a
value and we can have multiple such
pairings and we have three such pairs in
this particular example another example
or the or another type of way to define
a dictionary is using the dict function
this is how we use it as you can see I
have inputted two value or two object
tuples this is a tuple this is atopal
and this is a tuple and when I use it in
a dict function when I place it within a
list what python will do is it will
consider the first element of each Tuple
as a key and the second element of each
Tuple as its respective value now if I
check what's in D as you can see the key
banana has a value yellow the key apple
has a value red the key grape has a
value green so this is another way of
defining dictionaries an important note
over here is that the the objects that
we use for Keys have to be of an
immutable data type so we cannot use for
example lists as an example of keys but
we can use say integers or strings for
our dictionary Keys also Keys have to be
unique when it comes to a dictionary you
cannot have two different keys with uh
or should I say the same key having two
different values you can have only one
key and that one key will have a unique
value assigned to it duplicate keys are
not allowed however when we speak about
values we have no such restrictions you
can have immutable or an immutable data
type as a value in a dictionary and you
can have duplicates as well so if I
created a dictionary with a key say
banana and if I give if I associate it
with it
a value green I cannot create another
key banana and Associate a value yellow
let's see what happens when I actually
do this if you actually see what has
happened here is python has considered
the second case so it's it first looks
at the first pair it goes okay so my
dictionary has a key banana with a value
green but right after it it sees another
key banana with a value yellow so it
overwrites my first key banana with the
second key and it overwrites the first
value green with the second value and we
essentially get one key banana with the
second value yellow so obviously this is
a python does this to avoid duplicacies
however if I created a dictionary with a
key banana again if I created I gave it
a value yellow or say green if I created
another
key and if I give this also a value
green this is perfectly fine and this
will not nothing special will happen in
this case because values do not have to
follow such rules let's speak or let's
see certain dictionary operation
operations and functions now so let's uh
bring back our original dictionary which
we had created earlier with the three
pairs all right so what if I wanted to
we can use keys to essentially do these
operations and functions let's see what
happens when we so much like how we use
sequence how we use indexes in example
of sequences we use Keys when it comes
to dictionary so let's see what happens
when we use a key over here so we as we
know banana is a key in this dictionary
let's see what happens when we do where
we give this command it actually gives
the value associated with that key which
is yellow what if we wanted to change a
particular value Associated to a
particular key I would give I would do
this I would give the key and assign it
uh the value that I want to change it
with all right now if I check my
dictionary you can see the key banana no
more has yellow value but the value gold
what if I wanted to add a new pair you
know a new key with a new value
completely I would do it pretty much the
same same way as I did in the previous
step I would
um essentially write my new key whatever
I wanted say if I wanted a new key
called watermelon I would assign it a
value red and now if I check my
dictionary at the end of the dictionary
you will see that my new key pair key
value pair has been added watermelon red
as as you can see over here now what if
I wanted to remove if I wanted to remove
a key value pair from my dictionary I
can use the delete function which is
called by using this the Del function
now how do I do it say if I want to
remove the key value Apple in Red so all
I have to do is do del d and within
square brackets I have to only mention
the key I don't even need to mention the
value just the key so you can probably
draw parallels in how we use indexes
when it comes to lists and tuples and
even strings and how we use Keys when it
comes to dictionaries they are quite
similar so if I did this and if I
um oops I think red is actually not a
key as you can see red is a value my key
is Apple actually it's not red it's
apple as you can see now if I see my
dictionary the key apple and its value
red has been removed so these are some
of the operation questions that we can
do for dictionaries using keys what if
we wanted to use certain inbuilt
functions that are associated with
dictionaries well some of the examples
are as follows there is a get function
when we use a get function all we have
to do is enter a key inside the
parenthesis and it will get the value
associated with that key so if I gave
the key grip let's see what value is
associated with it as you can see it's
green there is also a function called
items that Returns the key and value
pairs in our dictionary as a list of two
object tuples where the first object is
the key and the second object is the
Tuple so let's see what it does as you
can see it gave me a list and in this
list the objects inside the list are two
object pupils where the first object is
always the key and the second is the
value and and it's the same for each of
the tuples so this is what items
function does let's see what uh the next
so the next function is Keys let's see
what the keys function does as you can
see it returns a list of all the unique
Keys within our list I mean within our
dictionary similarly we can there is a
function for values as well and as you
can see it returns all of the different
values that are present in our
dictionary in the form of a list also
it's important to note that if we have a
particular value that has occurred
multiple times in a dictionary it will
appear as many times it has occurred in
the dictionary or appeared in the
dictionary in our list over here when we
use the value function so if say a
particular value say I had another key
where its value was green again so I
would have the value green appear in
this list once more essentially our next
function is pop item what this does is
much like the pop function in list it
gives us the last entered key value pair
that is present in our dictionary so the
last centered pair was watermelon key
watermelon with the value red and that's
what has popped out when we give this
function another important function
associated with dictionaries is the
update function and the update function
is a very neat function that is used to
merge two dictionaries together so say
if I had a dictionary let's say I'm
creating a dictionary using the dict
function where I have say some key
called key V so as I had mentioned I
will use two object tuples in this case
and say I give this also a value green
all right and another pair would be say
mango and
let's give it a value yellow
all right so this is another dictionary
that we have created as you can see over
here we have created a dictionary with
the key called kiwi with value green and
another key mango with a value yellow
and I already have a dictionary D with
uh these values all right now if I want
to merge these two dictionaries I can
use the update function what I do is say
if I want to merge D with X or x with d
only the ordering will change and that
doesn't really matter when it comes to
dictionaries so if I want to merge D
with X I use D update and then inside it
I put my target dictionary now when I
check what's in D I have the the
dictionary X and its key value pairs uh
merged inside my original Dictionary d
as you can see I have my original ones
here and I have the merged ones over
here so this was the update function in
this brief video I will explain what we
call the type hierarchy or the standard
type hierarchy and item it's also known
as the data model in Python and it
probably has other names so essentially
in the what we do or what we speak about
in this is uh how the different types
that we use in Python are categorized
and classified and what are their
subtypes so it's important to note
before we continue further that there in
future versions of python there might be
new types that are introduced or the
existing ones may be modified but it's
safe to say that what I will speak about
in this video will still form the core
of what we call python standard type
hierarchy so let's begin so the first
type is the non-type uh it's accessed
through the built-in name none its truth
value is false it's essentially used to
denote
um functions or it's you it's returned
as the value for functions that don't
really return anything so if you have an
expression or a function that returns no
particular value you actually get a data
type called none that is how python
interprets it uh then there's the
ellipses uh ellipse is something that
you might encounter later uh it is
accessed through the built-in name
ellipses
um it is used to indicate the presence
of this particular
um syntax this particular symbol or
expression uh or syntax in a slice its
truth value is true again don't worry
too much about ellipses right now next
is numbers and numbers is something that
we are very familiar with we've seen
we've worked with numbers a lot they are
an immutable type they are created
through numeric literals and they are
the outputs of arithmetic expressions
and built-in arithmetic functions its
subtypes are integers floating Point
numbers and complex numbers
um within integers you have plain
integers that represent numbers in the
range this number and this number so
this this number is basically the
largest positive value that you can
represent using 32 bit notation induce
complement and this is the equivalent a
for the the negative the negative side
long in teachers on the other hand are
used to represent numbers in an
unlimited range that is only subject to
the available memory of your system so
these are two types of integers and as
we know floating Point numbers represent
Machine level double Precision floating
Point numbers or numbers with a decimal
point and a component after that complex
numbers are numbers that contain a
floating Point number that represents a
real part and a floating Point number
that represents a an imaginary part so
these are the types of numbers then we
have sequences sequences are finite
ordered sets indexed by natural numbers
so each element in a sequence has an
index and that index is a natural number
the different types of sequences are
based on the mutability whether the
objects can be changed or not is
essentially what we mean by mutability
right once we create an object whether
we can modify I don't know and that is
how we differentiate different types of
sequences so there are mutable and there
are immutable types now the different
types of immutable ones are strings we
know what strings are they are sequences
that contain characters Unicode is the
other immutable sequence and then there
are tuples uh tuples are a collection of
arbitrary python objects and unicodes
are sequences that contain Unicode
characters then we have mutable
sequences and uh there is only one
currently there is only one built-in
mutable sequence in Python and that is
lists lists are also again collection of
arbitrary python objects finally we have
well not finally but next we have
mappings and mappings are again
um sets of objects but these objects are
now indexed using arbitrary index sets
you know the difference between a
mapping and a sequence you could
consider sequences are ordered but
mappings are not ordered and the index
is given to the objects in sequences are
always numbers they're natural numbers
whereas in mappings they are not natural
numbers but they are certain arbitrary
objects that we can set for ourselves
again in Python there is only one
built-in standard mapping type that is
the dictionary dictionaries are there
they represent finite sets of objects
indexed by nearly arbitrary values the
only condition is that these indexes
must be of an immutable data type so
these uh so what I have mentioned until
now are probably the most common data
types that we encounter or that we have
encountered now so next types are like
callable types such as user defined
functions user defined methods built-in
functions built-in methods classes and
class instances so again callable types
as a whole are referenced using the call
function and this is something that we
will learn when we start learning about
functions when we learn about object
oriented programming and methods and
functions and such the other type of
modules so modules are module objects or
modules essentially are referenced or
called using the import function again
modules can be considered as these large
libraries or larger pieces of code or
applications that we that contain
various different methods and functions
and objects and classes within them
again modules are something that we will
think about a little later files are
data types that are called using the
open function so anytime we and as we
will well during the course of this
tutorial we or during the course of this
this course essentially we will be
working with a lot of files these some
of these files are text files some of
them are comma separated files so all of
these files that we open using uh the
function open or some other certain
specific functions where we create file
objects out of these files these are
what we call file data types finally
there are internal types that are used
by python interpreter again this is
something that does not concern us right
now but just know that The Interpreter
for python uses these data types for its
functioning in this video I will show
you some of the categories of operations
that are possible in Python so let's
start off so the first category of
operations are arithmetic operations and
as you can see in this table there are
different types such as addition
subtraction multiplication so let's go
over them one by one so so a simple
addition operation would be like five
plus six giving me the value 11 I can do
5 minus 3 and that's subtraction
similarly I can do a multiplication
using five say five into two there's
division where I use the backslash so
say I did division of 8 divided by 2.
now you might encounter another type of
division which is called the flow
division where we use a double backslash
and what this does is it returns us the
largest whole number that is lesser than
the result of our division so the
division difference between the float
Division and and the normal fluid and
the floor division or the single and the
double backslash is this say I did 9
divided by 2 using a single backslash it
should give me as you can see 4.5 right
so this is the actual value now let's
see what happens when I do 9 double
backslash 2 it will give me 4 which is
the largest number lesser than or equal
to 4.5 that is also a whole number so
this is what we call Floor division
essentially finally we also have if we
want to raise something to the power or
something so if I want to do fire say 6
raised to the power 3 that I would use
double asterisks and this is how I would
do it it'll give me 216 as you can see
uh if I wanted remainder between the
division between two different numbers I
will use the percentage sign so if I
wanted the remainder of the division
between seven and three this is how I
would do it I get the answer 1 as you
can see so next category of operations
are logical operations the first one is
the logical and operation where we use
the operator end all right so let's see
what we mean by this I am creating so as
we know the and operation Returns the
value true if both the operands are true
so that's actually let's actually do
this for an example let's give this
variable the value true and this the
value false so it should be done like
this false so now think of it like one
and zero so a one and zero is obviously
zero right so if I did A and B I should
get the answer false or zero because I'm
doing true and false so it's like doing
one and zero so if you see this I should
get the answer false if I change this to
true as well now if I do this I will get
the answer true as you can see uh the
next logical operation is the or
operation where well logical or is if
either of the operands are true then we
should get the answer to our or
operation as true as well so in this
case obviously if I did or over here it
will naturally give us true if I change
this to false
it should again give us true and it will
only give us faults if both are false as
you can see here now it's false the next
operation is The Logical not uh it's
done by using the not operator so in
this case the value that we get is true
if the operand is false so let's take a
as we know a is false over here so if I
did not a I should get the answer true
but if I change this to true now if I do
not a I should get false as you can see
so this was The Logical operations let's
move on to the next set of operations
that is comparison operations so there
are a bunch of them let's go over them
one by one if I want to check if two
operands are equal so if I did X is say
equal to 2 and now Y is equal to 3 if I
want to check if they are equal I will
use the double equals to sign and if
they are equal I will get the value true
if they aren't either I'll get value
false as you can see since X is 2 and Y
is 3 as you can see X and why are not
the same so there's false they are not
equal if I change this also to 2 now I
will get the answer to another the next
comparison is the not equal to or where
we use the exclamation sign so over here
this is this the result of this is true
if X and Y are not actually it's the
same so I should get false over here as
you can see but if I change this to say
5 now I will get true because X is not
equal to Y in this case the next one is
greater than so if I did X greater than
y as we can see 2 is not greater than 5
I will get false over here similarly
there is a lesser than if I did X less
than y I should get true over here as
you can see well there's also a greater
than or equal to and lesser than or
equal to we simply add the equal to sign
here so let's see now if I say x is less
than or equal to 3 I should get true
because X is 2 and if I put 2 here I
should also get true but what if I put 1
here since X is equal to 2 and 2 is not
less than equal to 1 this is a false
statement and I can do the same thing
with like this using the greater than
equal to now it's true because 2 is
actually greater than equal to 1 and so
this was comparison operations the next
set of operations that we can do in
Python are assignment operations we've
already seen a whole bunch we've already
been assigning values to variables we've
been doing assignments throughout
already but let's go over them and see
some of the assignment operations so as
we already know the equal to operation
is assigning everything that is on the
or the value on the right hand side of
the equal to sign to what is on the left
so if I did a is equal to 5 plus 6 it
will assign the value of 5 plus 6 or 11
to a let's check what's in a as you can
see it is 11. there is a plus equal to
sign and what this does is so for
example if I did say a now since a is 11
let's create another variable called B
and call this 5 all right so now if I
did a plus equal to B what this will do
is it will add B to a and then store it
in a so let's see what this does once I
do this now let's check what's in a it
should be 5 plus 11 as you can see 16.
so this a plus this is this plus equal
to sine is essentially the same as doing
a is equal to a plus b it's essentially
the same thing they're both the same uh
there's a similar thing for this the
negative or subtraction as well minus
equal to so now that a is 16 and B is
still 5 of course if I did minus equal
to B now I'm subtracting the value 5
from 16 so I should get a is equal to 11
again as you can see here and this is
the equivalent of doing a minus B A is
equal to a minus B I mean as you can see
so uh the next similar like assignment
operation let's create a is equal to say
6 in this case and say B is equal to I
will say 2 right now if I do a star star
equal to B what this does is it
multiplies B to a and then assigns it
back to a so if I see what's in a now it
should be 12 as you can see here
similarly there is similar thing for
subtraction as well so if I did a is
equal to 6 and B is equal to 2 and if I
did a sorry for division so if I did a
division symbol and equal to sine and
then if I give B what it will do is it
will divide a by b or 6 by 2 and it will
assign that back to a so my value in a
should be 3 as you can see here 3.0
obviously this is a single uh single
backslash so this is a float division
the resultant of a single backslash is
always a float I can do the same thing
with a double backslash so let's see if
I did a is equal to 7 now and then B is
equal to 3. now if I did a double
backslash equal to B now it will do the
same division but uh it will do a floor
function so it should give me 2 in this
case if I did the same thing with a
single backslash just to show you the
difference between single backslash and
double backslash division in this case
it will give me
um the value around 2.3 or something a
float basically 2.33 as you can see here
then there is the modulus you can use
the modular sign as well with this
assignment uh say a is equal to say 5
now B is equal to 2 now if I do a
percentage symbol equal to 2 I mean the
it should give me it will assign the uh
it will take the modulus in both sides
and then assign it to the left and the
upper end now let's see what's in a as
you can see it it did a divided by 2 the
modular symbol is basically the
remainder of the division between two
objects so in this case it will divide a
by B and then give me the remainder and
then put the remainder back in a and as
you can see the remainder of 5 divided
by 2 is 1 and we get that over here
similarly we can also do exponential so
if I have a is equal to say so 5 b is
equal to 2 and I want to raise a by if I
wanted to raise the value of a by the
value of B and then store that back in a
this is how I would do it so it should
be 5 to the power 2 which is 25 as you
can see here so this is assignment
operations so finally we move on to uh
two special sets of operators one is the
identity set identity operators and the
other is the membership operators uh
let's look at the identity operators so
when we talk about identity operators
what we when what we mean is the is and
the is not operator so what the is
operator does is it checks whether two
operands uh have the same location in
the memory essentially this does not
mean that it does not check for whether
two objects have the same value and this
is very important so let's look at this
if a is equal to one thousand and one
and B is equal to
1000 plus one all right if I did a is
equal to 2. this is an equality check
are they the same values true now if I
say a is B let's see what happens as you
can see it's false this is because this
object and this object are not the same
and this is what the is Operation does
uh we can confirm this by checking the
ID of a the ID of a gives us some value
like this and the ID of B gives us as
you can see a different value so the two
objects are not located in the same
place of the memory as we have seen
using the ID function and that is what
we check uh through the is operator and
the is not is essentially just the
opposite of that so so that is the
identity operator now the membership
operator is used for checking whether
something is present in a sequence or
not so let's create a sequence I will
create a list to show in this example my
list is one two and three basically
simple list with three integer objects
one two and three I will check whether
now say 2 in a so H2 in a if it is it
will give me true as you can see is 5 in
a it should give me false because 5 is
not in a and the a naught n operator is
just the opposite of that it checks the
other condition essentially so this is
the membership operators in Python in
this video we will be looking at the
math module in Python and we will look
at some of the math functions that are
associated with this module in Python so
starting off what is this math module
well uh the python map module is an
important library or a feature that is
uh designed to deal with mathematical
operations this math module is part of
the basic python installation so you
don't have to install this separately to
use this math module all you have to do
is import this module and this is how
you would do it you just do import math
and this will import your math module
for you to use in your programming and
in this in the course of this video I
will be showing you certain Concepts
surrounding the math module such as what
are the constants that come with the
mass module some of the arithmetic
functions the logarithmetic functions
power functions and even trigonometric
functions that we can do using this math
module and the function inside the math
module so starting off let's look at
some of the constants that are part of
this so as you can see the standard
constants are available in this module
are Pi there is Tau there is Euler's
number Nan which is a special it's a
it's a programming specific concept and
infinity so let's look at this one by
one so starting off our first constant
is pi
um Pi is as you know in maths it's the
ratio of the of a circles circumference
to its diameter and Pi is an irrational
number you know the value of pi is 3.14
something since it's an irrational
number it does not we cannot Define it
in terms of a specific fraction but it
can be approximated to the fraction 22
by 7. so how do we access this Pi
constant is as simple as this once you
have imported maths uh the match module
all you have to do is do match dot pi
and it will give you the value as you
can see so as you can see the value
returned to us is a float this is
important to note and the number of
number of decimal digits uh the number
of digits after the decimal point that
we can see here are 15 and this is like
a by default thing for python that if
you call the pi constant it will give
you the value of pi correct up to 15
decimal points so an example of where we
can use this thing is say we have the
radius of a circle 3 it can be an N
units three meters or whatever you want
and you want to find out it's say
circumference so as we know the
circumference of a circle is 2 pi r so
if I had to find the circumference of a
circle in my C in my code for some
application with the radius 3 however
all I would have to do is use the
formula 2 pi r and to call the value 2
pi r instead of specifically writing
3.14 something I can just use this
function math dot pi over here and then
I can enter the r as you can see it will
return me the radius as you can see so
moving on uh the next constant that we
will talk about is Tau Tau is similar to
Pi in fact tau is the ratio of a circle
circumference to its radius Pi is the
ratio of a circle's circumference to its
diameter and tau is the ratio for
circles circumference to its radius so
important to know this difference so
because of this definition tau is always
2 times the value of pi this is by
definition and much like Pi if you call
the Tau constant in you from the math
module it will also return you a float
number and to find that this is the
function that we use this is the syntax
so as as you can see this is this is
actually two times the value of pi 6.283
and even this is returned correct up to
15 places to the right of the decimal
point and this is by default uh next
constant is the Euler's number the
Euler's number is a it's one of the most
widespread constants used in the world
of uh in the scientific community in the
mathematical Community
um you will be using the Euler's number
probably a lot as a if if you move into
data science or AI or something like
that so what is the Euler's number it is
uh it is the base of the natural
logarithm if you know what the natural
logarithm is it is used to calculate
rates of growth or rates of Decay and as
with numbers or constants like pi and
Tau even the Euler's number is an
irrational number with infinite decimal
places uh the value of the Euler's
number in short it's denoted by the
small letter e so this value of e is our
usually approximated around 2.718 so how
do we call this constant is simply as
math dot e this is how we do it so you
get this value again this is also a
float and it's correct up to 15 decimal
places so the next concept that we will
be talking about is infinity now
Infinity is a it's more of a
mathematical concept and this is very
important to note because Infinity
doesn't is not really a number there is
no number called Infinity it is it is
used to define something that is
infinitely large or infinitely small so
positive Infinity is something that is
higher than any known number to us and
the negative Infinity is lower than any
known number to us so this is the
concept of infinity and how do we call
this uh function well so let's see what
happens when we call the math function
math constant Infinity so this is how we
do it and as you can see it will return
us this it might look like a string to
you but this is actually a special type
in Python
um which is not a string this is all
also a float it's a type of a float in
fact this Infinity value it's it's a
it's like a special data type it's a
special data type that you can you can
consider as an equivalent to a float but
um it's not it's not a typical float
that we know like you know 3.14 or 2.71
the value of method.in will give us INF
and this is this INF is actually not a
string so we can we can confirm that
over here as you can see when I do a
type when I check the type you see it's
actually a float in fact this was
recently added in Python 3.5 a special
type known as math.inf it returns this
INF data type which is the equivalent
waste float so this is this is how we
use Infinity if you wanted to get the
value of say minus infinity all you
would have to do is match dot INF with a
minus sign preceding this constant and
you will get minus INF now let's check
if the concepts or the properties of
infinity are maintained you know like
every a positive Infinity is greater
than any number that we know and
negative Infinity is greater than any
number that we know so let's just
confirm this
um so I will take method in and I will
do a check is this greater than say some
really large number something that comes
off the top of my head immediately okay
so let's see if it's if this is true
then this is conceptually correct and as
you can see it is true in fact I can
change this number to anything as large
as I want this will be true because
Infinity is true is larger than any
number that we know and similarly if I
did minus maths dot in INF and I checked
some very small number you know a very
very small negative number so just
consider some minus uh 10 to the power
something right this should also be true
uh sorry it should be a smaller same
symbol this should also be true because
I'm checking minus infinity is smaller
than any known number to us and it is
true as you can see so it's very uh also
if you did a if you did something like
so let's say if we do let's add
something to this you know it's a number
so we should be able to do arithmetic on
this let's actually see what happens
when I add say 10 to positive Infinity
it actually gives us the same value back
infinity because uh intuitively we know
that infinity plus anything is still
going to be Infinity right and this is
exactly what python does for us even if
we add a number to this the math dot INF
or the infinity constant in Python it
will still give us uh the same value the
same data type of INF or Infinity
similarly if we subtracted something
from the negative of maths.inf you know
say minus say again let's say minus 100
so if you subtract something from minus
infinity we're technically still minus
infinity itself so this will again give
us minus and minus minus INF as you can
see and this is absolutely what we need
and this is a very very interesting
feature in Python uh finally the last
constant that we will discuss is the na
a n or the not a number constant so this
is not really a mathematical constant
there is no constant in maths called not
a number this is a computer science
related concept that it's used to is
used to denote invalid inputs or in is
used to indicate a certain places where
say a variable that should have a number
it's been corrupted for whatever reason
and it it now has a text or a symbol and
our code throws an error then in these
in these cases where python expects a
number from us or from your code and it
does not get it it will throw you a n a
n value and this is usually used in
cases where you have errors in your code
so again just to check like what this
this constant like how to call it this
is how you actually do it maths.nan and
it will give you a data type called Nan
also much like the infinity cons
constant let's see what's the type of
this this constant again might look like
a string to you but of course this is
not a string this is enough a numerical
concept and as you can see it's still a
float so this is like um it's another
special uh data type that was created
for specifically this case where uh it's
some it's the equivalent of a float but
um it's not really the typical float
that we are that we associate with so
this is a constants in the math module
so our next topic will be arithmetic
functions that we can do in the using
the math module so some of the common
arithmetic functions that are available
to us are factorials the ceiling
operation floor operation uh there's
permutations there's combinations you
can find the greatest common divisor or
the gcd and the LCM or the least common
multiple and you can truncate numbers so
let's look at them one by one so
starting off with the factorial
operation the factorial operation is
done using the factorial function as you
can see here actually is defined like
this math dot factorial all right so now
what we pass in between the parenthesis
will be uh what we calculate the
factorial for uh as you know factorial
is so factorial is always for a positive
integer and the factorial for say a
number 10 would mean 10 times 9 times 8
times 7 so on until the number one
obviously factor is only defined for
positive integers uh it is not defined
for negative values or it's uh and it's
also not defined for decimal values so
let's see let's look at an example so as
we know um so let's say we pass match
dot factorial for six and let's see
what's the value so this is exactly what
we expect so we expect the value of 6
times 5 times 4 times 3 times 2 uh that
is actually 720. let's see what happens
when we pass 0 this should give us one
since we know zero factorial is one now
let's see an error case where we pass a
minus 5 as you can see this will throw
us an error because factors are not
defined for negative numbers now Moving
On Let's uh so the next function that
we'll talk about is the ceiling function
so the ceiling function is defined using
math dot CL as you see here so again we
pass the number that we want the ceiling
for in between the parenthesis so what
is the Searing function it gives you the
largest uh sorry excuse me it gives you
the smallest number that is uh greater
than or equal to what we pass over here
so for an example if I gave you 6.6 and
I asked you okay what is the ceiling
function for 6.6 it should give you 7
because 7 is the largest integer in
integral value that is greater than 6.6
or equal to it obviously if you give the
ceiling function for an integer it will
give you the integer itself so let's
look at an example 7.8 so this should
give me the value 8 as you can see here
let's look at it now a negative number
so minus 12.3 uh an integer that is
greater than minus 12.3 is minus 12 the
smallest integer that is greater than
minus 7.3 and this should give you 12 as
you can minus 12 as you can see here a
similar function is the floor function
which is defined like this
again the floor function what it does it
gives you the greatest number that is
smaller than whatever value we pass
between the parenthesis so if I gave it
2.3 it should give me the value 2. again
if we pass integers it will just give us
the integer itself again it is to
retrain this ceiling and flow functions
uh they give you into integer values so
the floor function will give you the
largest integer that is smaller than
what we pass over here so let's look at
6.7 so the largest integer that is
smaller than 6.7 is 6 and as you can see
this is our answer over here uh the next
function that we will look at is the
truncate function the transcript
function is defined using this truncate
is very similar to what we have seen
this is how we Define the rocket
function uh it is very similar to the
ceiling and floor in the truncate
function what we do is
um we pass a decimal value a float
number to the between between the
parenthesis and what we get back is the
number without the decimal component so
only the integral component so if I gave
it 7.8 for example it will give me only
the seven part it will return me only
the seven part and it will chop away the
point eight part if I gave it minus 12.3
uh it will chop away the 0.3 part and
give me only minus 12 back so let's look
at an example 8.9 it should give me only
8 as you can see here see I did minus 8
or minus
6.9 this will give you minus six so you
can think of truncate function as it
does the floor function for positive
values and it does the ceiling function
for negative values because it rounds
down and rounds up respectively for
positive and negative values so now
let's look at the next set of arithmetic
functions let's move on to permutations
permutations are defined using this as
you know so in between the parenthesis I
have to pass two values n and K okay so
I have to pass n n and a k the K has to
be less than or equal to n because the
permutation as you know is uh the number
of ways in which we can permute from n
objects K Tire K different objects uh so
what this mathematically what this is is
um permutation of N and K is n factorial
divided by n minus K factorial so if I
pass say 10 and 6 it will give me the
permutation of 10 and 6. so let's look
at what's the value as you can see it's
a very large value fifteen one fifty one
thousand two hundred similarly there is
a combination function and this is a
combinations of permutations I use a lot
in probability so if you're going to
move into that sphere which you will
encounter a lot in machine learning AI
you will be using these functions quite
a bit
um so the combination function again you
pass an n and a k again the N should be
greater than or equal to this K what
this evaluates is n factorial divided by
n minus K factorial times K factorial so
again this is a mathematical concept so
let's look at the permutation sorry the
combination of 10 and 6. so as you can
see it gives me 210 which is the
combination of 10 seconds in the
arithmetic function section
um our gcd and LCM as we know gcd is the
greatest common divisor LCM is least
common multiple so as of the newest
version of python in three point python
3.9 the math module gets these two new
functions that were very lately added
actually
um since uh I cannot show you that
because I don't have the absolute latest
version of python on my system but using
the
math.gcd function this is the function
and in between this we would what we
would do if we had the latest version is
we would pass two numbers or as many
numbers in fact and what this function
will do is find the common divisor
amongst them so if I give these say for
example if I gave these numbers it would
give me the value 10. similarly the LCM
function again added in the python 3.9
finds the common multiple amongst or
whatever we pass over here so if I
passed say 20 and 30 this will give me
uh the value of 60 which is the LCM of
20 and 30. so again these are it's
something neat that if you say you have
python 3.9 or uh if you have python 3.9
or after that uh you will have access to
these functions as well if you when you
import the math module so that was for
the arithmetic uh functions let's move
on to the next section which are power
and logarithmetic logarithmic functions
so let's start off with the power
function
um there are two there are multiple ways
you can actually do a power function in
math in Python so you can do something
like this which is the equivalent of 2
to the power 3 or you can use the
inbuilt module math and you can use the
pow or the power function which is this
is how you do it and if I had to do same
2 to the power 3 I would just pass 2 and
3 has arguments like this and it should
give me the value as you can see 8 over
here what if so there's actually one
more function which is simply the pow
function and this is uh not part of the
math module it's a function not part of
the math module but it's still part of
the base python use this as well and you
can do the same thing pow 2 and 3 it
should give you the value 8 again the
you know you might ask what's the
difference between these two functions
well it's not much for at least in a
beginner standpoint it's not that much
just note that the maths dot power
function is slightly computationally
faster than the simple power function so
yeah moving on their next topic would be
the next function that we'll discuss is
the exponential function which is
defined like this again exponential
function is again e to the power
something so if I did exponential of 3
this would give me e to the power 3. so
as you can see oh of course I did not
Define the module beforehand so math.exp
now when I do this it should it will
give me some value which is basically
Euler's number or e to the power 3. so
this was the exponential function and
let's look at an example so we will look
at the example of rate of d k and we
will use the uh this function in that
example so the exponential rate of Decay
um uh for uh is used to calculate the
amount of radioactive elements that is
present in a substance after a certain
amount of time so the the the the the
expression is uh something like the
initial amount of radioactive elements
that were present uh right at the
beginning times the exponent of minus
693 times t t for time divided by the
time period the half-life time uh so
let's just write it down to make it
simple so again as you can see the uh so
this will give me the remaining amount
of radioactive elements right so let's
uh let's write down remaining let's
assign this to a variable remaining so
the initial again
um initial is the initial amount of
radioactive elements so let's give it
some value say 100
um the time let's assume it's 10 years
and let's say the half-life
um Half-Life is around I don't know
let's give some value say three or
something again this is uh the details
are not important so this will I'm using
the math dot exponential function over
here as you can see and for these values
uh now when I check what's the value of
remaining after I calculated it's
something uh so this is it's basically
what this tells me is that I started off
with 100 units of some radioactive
element
um and in 10 years is this is what is
left so yeah so this is how we would use
say the X exponential functions in a
particular example of us so next the
next type of again functions are
logarithmic functions so let's look at
some of the logarithmic functions that
are part of the math module so basic log
function would be written like this math
DOT log in in between this I would pass
the number that I want the log for by
default if I just pass one number it
will it will calculate the log of 8 to
the base of e as we know e is the
Euler's number so let's see what it does
in this case gives me some value what if
I wanted to specify a particular base
well I would pass a second argument in
this case I want to find the log of a to
the base 2 this should be the value 3 as
you can see over here uh there are two
specific functions that are also
provided in this math module that is log
2 uh what this will do is again it will
again I have to just pass one argument
and this will automatically find the
value of the log of 8 to the base 2 as
you can see here similarly there is a
math DOT log 10 function if I give if I
did this I will find the value of
something here to the base 10 as you can
see so this was a logarithmic functions
then you have the finally you have the
square root function so how would we use
the math the square root function is Max
dot sqrt again we passed what we want
over here if you want the square root of
say 49 this should give me the value 7
as you can see finally maybe move on to
the final set of functions that we could
do using this math module uh they are
trigonometric functions and they are
hyperbolic functions so let's start off
with some of the trigonometric functions
as we know
um we can do sine we can do cosine and
tan uh some of the basic functions the
way we would do it is math DOT sign in
between this what we this is to
calculate the sign of a particular angle
and this angle must be passed in radians
and this is very important to note we do
not pass it in degrees but in radians so
if I say past sine of 3.14 as we know
3.14 is an approximation of the value by
sine Phi is supposed to be in fact it's
supposed to be zero so let's see we get
something close 0 again since this is an
approximation it won't give us the exact
value similarly we can use math dot cos
to find the value of a particular angle
if you want to find yeah if you want to
find the value of the sorry the cost of
a particular angle we can use the tan
function in case we wanted to find the
tan similarly we have the next set for
arc sine and the arcosines of the
certain of angles so to use to find the
arc sign for example we would use a DOT
sign I mean sorry a sign for R cosine we
would use this and for r10 we would use
this the next set would be hyperbolic
functions again hyperbolic functions are
are basically the sine and the cosine
and the time calculated not circles but
on hyperbolas again the details don't
have to be you don't have to know the
details you just should you should know
that if you wanted to say for example
find out the hyperbolic sign of n and a
of an angle we would use math dot sine H
and we would pass what we wanted between
this similarly if we wanted to find the
cosine it would be cos H tan it would be
tan H and if we wanted to find the
inverse of the hyperbolic inverse we
what we would do is what we would do is
use a so we would use a tan H if you
wanted to find the hyperbolic inverse uh
of sine we would use a sine H and
similarly for cos it would be cos a COS
H in this video we will learn about
conditional statements and we will learn
about how do we create these control
structures where we have these
conditional statements we will learn
about the keywords if we use in Python
to create a conditional statement block
the if keyword the alif keyword and the
else keyword we will also learn about
indentation and its importance in Python
so let's get started so the basic uh
syntax if you will for a if statement in
Python consists of the keyword if
followed by an expression as you can see
from this pictorial if there's an if
statement there is a expression uh there
is this a block of code which if you can
actually see is slightly indented to the
rest of the code uh and then we have the
rest of the rest of our code after that
so what we're looking at is this so this
is our if statement block
um now let's let's break this down so
what is this expression that we're
speaking of uh an expression in this
context is a Boolean expression which
evaluates to a true or false statement
so when we are speaking about the if
statement we have an expression and if
this expression evaluates to true then
we X execute everything below the if
statement otherwise we skip that portion
as you can see if the statement is true
we execute this statement or these
statement blocks uh otherwise if it's
false we move on to the next the next
statement block or the beginning of a
new statement uh so let's look at an
example to further understand this let's
take this if statement over here as you
can see in this if statement I have this
expression 50 greater than 30 so what
python is going to do now is it's going
to check whether 50 is greater than 30
and it's going to check in a Boolean
context if this is true then we can move
on to the next portion which is this but
if it is false then we will skip this so
let's see what this uh what happens over
here so since we know that 50 is indeed
greater than 30 this is a true
expression we move on to this block of
code which is saying that print 50 is
indeed a larger number than 30. so let's
see if this actually gets printed so as
you can see we get this uh the result
which is this is a true statement and we
get our print statement getting executed
what if we give a false expression over
here so let's look at what happens if I
gave a false expression now I'm checking
if 50 is lesser than 30 which is a false
statement so if it's a false statement
we do not move on to this portion of our
if statement block and we we directly in
fact we directly skip so if I have to
execute this you will see nothing gets
executed and in fact my print statement
is just not executed because we never
entered this because our expression over
here was indeed false so yeah this is
how a basic if statement block looks
like in Python and this is how the uh
how we move on to how we check for the
true the truth truthfulness or the
falseness of a particular expression in
the if statement so moving on
um let's move on to the topic of
indentation in in Python so as you can
see this uh this if statement is an
example of a control structure so
without moving without defining uh what
a control control structure is in detail
control structures consists of these
conditionals or Loops or iterations if
you will uh so all of these control
structures involve heavy indentation so
so what does an indentation mean well
what if I gave you an example say I gave
you some variable called H and I wrote
20 over here now if I gave you an if
statement saying if age is greater than
10 now uh it's very important to note
that when I'm defining an if statement I
need this colon otherwise this if
statement is not defined so this colon
is important uh anyways so now I'm
checking this expression if age is
greater than 10. now what is this what
happens if H is greater than 10 now what
if I want python to do something only if
age is greater than 10 well how do I
tell python that there is a piece of
code or a section of code that I want
executed only if this condition is met
well this is where indentation comes
into play so if I want say if I want
this line this person is an adult again
this is some random line where I'm
assuming age is pertaining to this adult
all right or this person so if I have uh
this variable age where I write this
number 20 which denotes the age of some
person and I'm doing a check if age is
greater than 10 actually let's be
specific here well the adult age for
most people is 18 in most countries so
let's see if age is greater than 18. now
if I'm doing this check uh I want to
print this statement only if this person
is a person's age is above 20 above 18
so how do I tell python that I only want
this statement to be uh executed only
during this if this condition is met
well this is the indentation comes into
play and as you can see exactly as you
can see uh this part this portion of the
code is slightly indented compared to
the if statement so when this condition
is met then only do we move on to this
if this condition is not met we move on
to whatever the next section of code
will be like whatever whatever code that
we have after this if statement so let's
see so this since this condition is
actually met as you can see this print
statement is actually executed so this
is the importance of indentation now we
will see uh in as we move as we learn
more about if statements and else
statements and alif statements how
indentation plays a key role in defining
what we want as an output when a certain
condition is met all right so for now
it's very important to understand that
this is how indentation is used in
Python in other languages we might use
uh we probably don't use indentation in
fact popular language the C language
does not use indentation at all but some
languages and python in probably the
trademark language for indentation and
programming so you might say that so
different people have different opinions
on an indentation the general consensus
is that indentation helps make the code
look very presentable and very readable
and this actually is one one of the
facets of Python Programming is the
indentation and the easy readability of
it anyways moving on so what if we have
um multiple conditions in our code or if
in our if statement block that we want
to see so let's create this list or
let's actually just copy this example
that I have written over here as you can
see what I am doing in this piece of
code is I have a list X where I have
this integer 50 I have two strings cat
and apple now I want to check a bunch of
things so I want to check if 60 is an X
and I also want to check if the string
cat is an X and I want a final sort of
like if none of these conditions are met
I want something to happen so how do we
do that well we start off our state our
if statement block with the standard if
keyword all right now if we have one
more condition that we want met then we
can use the L if which is kind of a
short form for else if uh so we use the
L if keyword so it so what this python
uh what python reads is it checks this
condition then it will check this
condition and then finally we have this
else keyword and else is a keyword used
in our block to tell python that if none
of our earlier Expressions have been
true then do what is in the uh there
that is within the else keyword that is
indented within the else keyword so
again we don't pass an expression for
else because else is uh only we only
Reach This LL statement in case all of
the earlier conditions have not been met
or have come to be false and not true so
let's look at uh this particular code
example so we have a list of 50 cat and
apple and I'm my first expression that
I'm checking is uh is 60 in X so this is
how we check actually so if 60 and X
should be read as is 60 in the list X so
is this 16 elix list X well actually no
we don't have the object 60 so this part
is not executed we move on to the next
condition is the string cat in X well
actually it is uh the string cat is
indeed in X so we move on to this
statement block which is within the
condition that is met which is print cat
is in list X and you will see that none
of the other statement blocks will be
executed because we have met our
condition over here so if I execute this
as you can see that the print statement
cat is in this text is what is actually
executed and we do not execute this
obviously because it is false and we do
not even check or we do not even move on
to the statement because well we have a
condition mat over here so it's a one
thing that is important to note is that
we can use as many alif statements to
check for as many conditions that we we
want to check for but it's very
important that we only use and if we are
using that we only use one else
statement and only at the end end of our
block okay so moving on now I'm going to
show you a very neat example about how
python actually does its uh these
condition checkings so it's very
important to note that once a condition
is met none of the other conditions are
even checked for so
um we do not even consider the next
statements and we directly leave this if
statement block so let's look at this
example over here now in this example
that I have over here is where I've
stored the string cat in X now I have
three uh I have three conditions that
I'm checking I'm checking is 50 greater
than 60. I am checking if the value of x
is indeed cat and I'm checking I'm some
random expression 1 divided by 0. this
is not even a check this is literally
just checking if 1 divided by 0 is true
or false and as we know we cannot divide
anything by zero so let's see what
happens when I execute this statement
now typically if I wrote 1 divided by 0
python will throw me an error because 1
cannot be divided by 0 that is an error
statement so let's see what happens when
I do this actually as you can see I have
a statement being printed but I have no
error even though I gave it wrong I gave
an error statement in 1 divided by 0.
well now you might ask why is that so
well it's simply because I have actually
never reached this condition I have not
even python is not bothered looking at
this because if you actually see there
is a condition previous to this over
here which is met and which is true so
we move on to this block we execute this
block and we forget about the rest of
the code so we don't actually get to
this error statement which is an
interesting thing and which is an
example that I have shown uh to show you
that once a condition is met in an if
statement block we do not look at any of
the further conditions that are being
checked okay so finally
um I have one one small topic that I
would like to share with you is the
conditional expressions or the pythons
ternary operator now this is slightly
different to the if statement that we
have talked about up until now in the
sense that it is not a control structure
so what this actually is is more of an
operator that defines some expression so
let's see what I am trying to say over
here so as you can see over here
highlighted is the Syntax for what I'm
trying to talk about this ternary
operator so let's look at this example
and let's see what I'm trying to do over
here so I have this variable age all
right and this age is 26 now X now just
just read this statement X is equal to
adult if age is greater than 18 else
child now I could have done an elaborate
control structure with an if statement
then an indentation within that if
statement and then I could have written
else and then another indentation and I
would have written another statement
over there but instead of that I have
used this operator to assign a
particular value to the variable X and
this uh what value I'm assigning to X
depends on if this condition is 2 or 4
false so as you can see the condition
says is age 18 greater than 18. so if
this is true then I assign this
particular string if it is false then I
go on to the else statement and I assign
this so since age is 26 is greater than
18 I should assign the string adult to X
and as you can see if I execute this and
check what is an X you can see adult is
indeed in X so this is a very neat a
very needable readable and a very um
it's a it's probably a more it's it's a
better looking way to perform simple
else uh Sim simple if and else
statements where you don't want to
create a whole um if stay if if else
statement control structure block so
yeah this was the ternary operator
finally we Let's uh we we make a short
note on the pass statement uh in Python
so the path statement or the pass
keyword is a a place where it is is a
placeholder of sorts so what if I had an
if statement and I'm writing a piece of
code but I don't know what to do with
this if statement so if if a statement
is correct if a statement is true but I
don't know what to do if this statement
was true how do I tell python well let's
just keep it a hold for now and I might
put something into this block later in
the future well I would use the pass
statement so if I had this say this some
condition again so I'm checking age is
greater than 18 but I don't know what to
do with this I would just simply use
this pass statement and this basically
does nothing uh it it's a way to it's
like a way to create a placeholder where
maybe in the future I might have I might
write some sort of a say a print
statement or some sort of a different
function or something else within this
indentation so but in the meantime like
currently I don't have anything to place
over here so I just leave it with a pass
statement so this is a way where you can
use a pass statement in if and else
statement or if an else control
structures in this video we will be I
will introduce you to the concept of
iterations in Python and we will be
speaking in specific about the
indefinite iteration in Python otherwise
known as the while loop so let's look at
what an iteration means an iteration is
executing the same block of code over
and over potentially many times a
programming structure that implements an
iteration is called a loop now in
programming we have two types of
iterations definite and indefinite
iterations and in this example we will
be speaking about indefinite iterations
in definite iterations in Python is the
while loop where we use the while
keyword to Define an indefinite
iteration so let's look at the basic
syntax as you can see this is the basic
syntax where we have the while keyword
followed by an expression and again the
colon and below that is something
indented again we encounter indentations
the psych NFL statements a set of
statements where what happens here is
following the while keyword we have this
expression where this expression is
evaluated in a Boolean context again we
check if this expression evaluates true
or false and if it is true V we execute
all the statements or the statement
block that is indented below this file
statement this is another example of
control structure much like FNL state in
blocks where we use a lot of indentation
so let's look at a basic example now of
while loop so let's copy this example
and let's see what this does so I have a
variable n where I am assigning it a
value 0. this is called an initializing
process and it's very important to note
that most while Loops consist of an
expression which contains a variable a
control variable uh which is usually
initialized prior to starting the loop
and then this control variable is
typically very modified somewhere within
the main Loop body so in this case my
control variable is n and I am
initializing it by assigning it the
value 0. so let's move into the loop now
so the loop has this wire keyword as you
can see followed by a an expression n
lesser than or equal to to 5. now what
this is is an expression which is going
to check if it's true or false is n
lesser than or equal to 5 and as long as
this expression is true we will continue
doing whatever is indented below this y
statement and what is below this y
statement is a print statement first of
all which says value of n is and it
basically prints a value of n in that
particular iteration and as you can see
this uh compound assignment where we add
the value of n by 1 and we assign it
back to n so what this is uh let's see
what this does actually let's execute
this and see what this does important to
note the value of n again is initialized
at 0. so this while loop will keep going
on until the value of n remains lesser
than or equal to 5. so as you can see I
have the execution of this uh particular
block of code or this while loop where I
get the a multiple different iterations
of this print statement that you can see
here the first iteration it says value
of n is 0 then it will value of n is 1.
what I am doing is I am writing I am
assigned I'm writing uh the value of n
multiple times uh and each time the
value of n is written over here based on
what iteration it is so what is
happening actually is uh the initially
value of n is 0 and I print the
statement value of n is 0. now I add uh
the value of what is In N by 1. so now
what is the value of n so again we do
this check so after this first iteration
we come back or like once this whole
code block of code is executed we again
come back to this expression and we
again check if this statement is true so
now that the value of n is actually 1 if
this statement is still true so again we
execute this and that you can see over
here value of n is 1. now again we add
the value of n by 1 and again we go back
here once this uh this block is executed
and we check if this statement is true
again and as you can see the value of n
when it's 2 is still making sure that
this expression is true and this keeps
happening until the value of n is
greater than 5 so once the value of n
becomes 6 this condition is no longer
met and finally we do not execute the
statement because this expression
evaluates to false and we do not do this
anymore and we finally leave our while
low so let's check what the value of n
is just to confirm this as you can see
the value of n is indeed 6 and that is
why we have left this while loop over
here so this is an example of a basic
while loop where we check for this uh an
expression if it evaluates to true we
evaluate everything within it once this
is done we go back and we evaluate this
expression again if it is again true we
again go back into whatever is indented
within it and we keep doing this until
the expression gives us false and
interestingly we don't uh we don't
necessarily have to Define these control
variables always we can actually use uh
iterables and we will learn about
iterables actually in a future video but
we can use iterables and an example of
an iterable is the list so let's look at
this list and let's look at this whole
block all right so I created this list a
which contains five objects one two
three four and five all integer objects
and I have another variable X where I
store the integer one now I'm this wire
statement now it might look confusing
now it's it says it says while a now
what is a well a is not uh your typical
expression where you're making sure if
some condition is being met or not but
this the way you read this is while a
exists so in the context of a list as
long as a which is a list contains
objects within it a is true if it does
not have any objects within it a is
false so while a basically what it means
is while a has objects within it and if
it does have objects within it or as
long as it does we continue executing
whatever is indented within this while
statement and this y statement is a
print statement again we do like we we
have this value X where we we're doing
this this web printing this is iteration
number and uh we pass X so the first
iteration obviously pass X is equal to 1
and then we add X by 1 and then the
second iteration should pass this is
iteration number two and then so on and
finally we have another statement within
this block called the a call the uh pop
statement where we're popping the
elements of a now as if you would have
seen the list the video on list the pop
statement removes the rightmost value uh
from a list so if I do a DOT pop
initially it will remove 5 from this
list and I will have the rest of them
and again if I do pop it will remove
four from this list and then you will
have the rest of these so let's actually
see we'll actually check what's left in
this list each time we do this pop
statement so I'll also print the list a
it's uh during each iteration and let's
see what happens over here as you can
see what is happening out here is while
a or while a has elements we are going
to continue doing this y statement
whatever is within it so in the first
iteration obviously we have all of it uh
and it is iteration number one and as
you can see the list contains everything
then I pop it then iteration number two
it again has elements but it has lost
its most rightmost element and this
keeps on happening until the list
finally has no elements left and once
the element or invents a list has no
elements left we this expression while a
evaluates to false and we do not execute
this anymore and we leave the while loop
and again let's check what is in a a
should have no elements as you can see
it's an empty list when I check what's
in a is an empty list and that is why
while a return near false and we do not
print any further so this is an example
of using a virus statement using lists
and of course the next topic would be
discussing nested while loops and this
is a broad topic what I mean by this is
that when when I'm saying nested while
Loops I'm actually talking about nested
control structures so we can have while
Loops within while Loops not only that
we can have FNS statements within while
loops we can have while Loops within if
and L statements and we can have FNL
statements within FNL statements so if
you think of all of these loops and we
will even speak about four Loops in the
in the in in a in another video for
Loops again a type of control structure
so all of these are control structures
while Loops or control structures for
Loops or control structures if and else
statements are control structures all of
these are control structures and nesting
can happen within them and it does not
matter uh which is the like the parent
of the nest and then the child of the
nest we can have a while loop within an
ifnl statement you can have for Loops
within a while loop all of this is valid
in Python and uh it's one of the one of
the great features of python that is
very flexible in this way so let's look
at an example where I have a while loop
within another while loop so I am
copying this piece of code where I have
this list one two three four five and
another list first and second now my
first while loop I print I print what is
pop from a so I take a then I pop the
zeroth index so basically from the left
hand side and I print what is that all
right and then I have another while loop
where I have this list B and I'm doing
the same thing but this while loop is
within the first while loop and let's
see what happens out here so as you can
see my first uh my first iteration of
this parent while loop causes me to pop
what is the first element which is one
then I do these while loops and this is
completely executed and only then do I
go back to this first one and then I
come back and do all of this again then
I go back to this one and then I come
back into all of this again and that's
why you can see this repetition so I
have this first iteration and then I do
uh the second while loop then I have the
second iteration and then I do the
second while loop and I keep doing this
and this is an example of a nested while
loop okay so our next Topic in this
second this video would be break in
continue statements now break in
continue statements are ways to abruptly
end iterations uh in in a particular
Loop you can use break in continue
statements not only in while loop where
you can use it and also in for Loops so
let's look at how we use it in while
loops and let's look at what we mean by
breaking container statements first of
all well the break statement terminates
the loop entirely so once the break
statement is found the the complete
while loop that we are using is
completely terminated and the continue
statement on the other hand terminates
only the current Loop iteration and it
goes back to the beginning or the
expression and it checks whether the
expression or the the controlling
expression is again re-evaluated and it
is checked whether the loop will execute
again or terminate this pictorial that
you can see here actually emphasizes or
it shows the difference between break
and continue so I have this while loop
and I have an expression all right I
have a bunch of statements and I have a
break command over here and I have a
continue command over here so if I
encounter the break command it will not
execute any of this in fact it will not
execute this wire statement at all and
it will move on to the next piece of
code that we have but a continuous
statement if a continuous statement is
encountered in a while loop will not
completely break away but it will not uh
it will not execute the the rest of the
statements in that iteration only these
two but it will go back here it will
check this expression again and again we
will do this all over again so this is
this small uh difference between the
break and continue statements but both
are used to abruptly end an iteration in
a loop so let's look at an example of
how we use the break statement so I will
use this example where I have again I
have initialized some controlling
variable n to 0 my first Loop will check
whether n is lesser than equal to 5 if
this is true then I will print this
statement then I will what I'm doing
over here is I am incrementing it by one
now in my previous my earlier example
using a similar uh using the similar
example I had no like this this part was
not there so what you got was I was
printing the value of n so it was
printing as like value of n is one I
mean 0 and then one and then two and
then three four and five but over here
I've included a small I've nested an if
statement and within that I put a break
statement and this if statement is
checking if if n is equal to equal to 2
so once n is 2 I move on to this and I
do the break statement so let's see what
happens now as you can see once so when
I have executed this I don't get the
whole value of n is 0 and then one and
then two three four five I I stop at one
and that is because once n is equal to 2
I actually do not execute this while
loop again I do not go back and execute
print value of n is 2 now in fact I
break from this whole while loop and my
while loop terminal is right then and
there and that's why you only get these
two iterations value of n is zero and
then value of n is one okay so now I'm
going to show you a neat example of what
happens or what is the difference
between a break and a continuous
statement okay so let's uh go back to
our initial example where we're printing
this value of n is 0 1 2 3 4 and so on
but I have added one more statement
where I print hello at each iteration so
let's see what happens when I do this as
you can see it will print hello after
each of whatever I was doing already now
let's introduce our break statement
first of all so when I do break well
let's go back to this if statement if
his if we check this condition then we
break let's see what happens now as you
can see something interesting has
happened where we have this first
iteration completely being executed but
the second iteration kind of stops where
there's no hello and that is because we
have broken from this while loop before
the second iterations hello was printed
let's see the difference between a break
and continue now so now I have this
continuous statement and instead of a
break let's see what happens here as you
can see it seems familiar to our first
example where we do not have any break
or continue but there is a small
difference that I want you to catch and
that is very important about this
continue uh statement so as you can see
the first iteration has value of n is 0
and then hello and value of n is 1 but
there is no hello and this is because
this is because once this condition is
actually met we do not move on to this
statement but we go back to this
expression and we will evaluate this
expression and then once we evaluate
this expression again and it's found to
be correct we do everything the same
again when we print hello but except for
that one step where this if statement
was met and we did continue and this
following statement was not executed and
that happens only for one iteration and
that is when n is equal to equal to 2
and as you can see that is what happens
over here in one of the iterations we
may say hello and that is the difference
of the continue statement between uh
there is a difference of the continuous
statement with the break statement this
video will be an extension into that
topic where we will be looking at three
examples where we are using while Loops
along with other stuff like say FNL
statements so our first example will be
where we calculate the factorial of a
number in this example as you can see
here we are first going to ask the user
to enter a particular number for us now
this number is supposed to be an integer
once we have this integer we store it to
a variable called number now we have
this you can say this variable called
fac which stores 1 and you we will see
how we are using it later now we know
that the factorial of 0 is 1 that's how
it's just defined so we have an if
statement checking whether our entered
number is 0 and if it is 0 we say that
the result is 1 or the factorial is one
however if we enter a number that is
greater than 0 we must calculate the
factor oil for this number and that is
what we are going to do in this else
statement block over here now in this
else statement block we have a while
loop in this while loop the condition is
checking while number is greater than or
equal to 1. so as long as this condition
is true everything within that while
loop will be executed so as long as
number is greater than equal to 1 we are
going to execute these two lines now
what do these two lines do let us see so
the first line takes the variable fac
where we had the number one stored and
we are going to store FEC times number
into it number being the number that we
have inputted so in case for example we
still we entered 8 then what this will
do this line will do is 1 into 8 and it
will store that back into fac now once
that is done we move on to the next line
where we are decrementing the number
variable by one so if we have stored 8
or we have entered 8 into our input it
will become 7. now as we know 7 is still
greater than equal to 1 so this
condition is still being met and then we
do this process again where we are going
to multiply fac this time fac stores the
value 8 and we multiply it times the new
number which is 7 now so we do 8 into 7
and then again we decrement this uh also
once we do 8 into 7 we store it back
into fac and we keep doing this where we
keep multiplying 8 times 7 and then we
decrement the number variable uh by one
and then we check this condition again
so what ends up happening is we are
going to keep doing 8 into 7 into 6 into
5 into 4 into 3 into 2 into 1 and once
we are at 1 again when we do this
document operation the number variable
we store the value 0 and then this
condition will no longer be met so
number will be 0 and this condition will
be false and we can move out of this
while low then finally we store the
result into a variable called result
which stores the result of 8 into 7 into
6 into 5 into 4 into 3 into 2 into 1
this is of course if we did enter 8 when
we were asked to give an input so let's
see this
um in real time once we execute this so
I'm executing this the first thing it
asks me is to enter a number so let's
say I enter my number 8 as I was
speaking about eight all right now that
I have entered 8 as you can see the
result that it gives me is factorial of
8 is 4 0 3 2 0 which is correct and you
can check this for yourself where it
will show you
um 8 times 7 or 8 factorial is basically
this this number okay so now in our next
example we will be looking at how we can
generate Fibonacci numbers for this
example we will be using bunch of if and
else if statements along with a while
loop so let's look at this piece of code
where we are actually doing this so as
you can see the first part of the code
is basically an input statement asking
us how many Fibonacci numbers we would
like to generate and then the user it
would be asked to give an input which is
stored as an INT into a variable count
now in this if a statement the first if
statement checks whether what we have
entered is 0 in which case we just store
an empty array in the variable called
FIB next if our entered integer is 1 we
just store the value 1 in this array
called FIB if our enter number is 2 we
store 1 and 1 in the array FIB all of
these are different sets of Fibonacci
sequences this obviously an empty an
empty array shows that well there is no
numbers to be generated in this sequence
if we have one we just print the first
number of the Fibonacci sequence which
is one itself if it is 2 we print the
first two numbers which is one and one
now the actual calculations happen when
we say we want a Fibonacci sequence for
more than two numbers now in that case
we move on to this block in this
statement block we initialize the FIB
variable with the first two Fibonacci
numbers one and one and we store in this
very in this array now we are going to
do a while loop within this and in this
while loop we're going to keep executing
this statement block as long as this
condition is met or this condition is
true and what this condition is is it's
checking this variable I which we have
initialized as 1 over here and we're
going to check whether that is lesser
than count minus 1 count being the
number that we have been asked to input
if the statement is true and as long as
the statement is true we will be
executing this statement block which is
basically us appending this expression
into the array FIB now what this
expression is is basically it's going to
keep adding so each subsequent numbers
and we are going to store each
subsequent numbers back into the array
Fib so in this case if you see the
fourth the first step will do is it will
take the value at the first portion of
the array film and it will add it to the
value at the 0th position of the array
fib and both of these values since they
are 1 and 1 when we add them we get 2
and we append that to Fib so now our FIB
will look like 1 comma 1 comma 2 then we
increment this by one and what we do is
we do the same process again so in the
next step what will be what we would do
is we would do 2 plus 1 so we would get
three now this would keep going on until
this condition is met or basically until
uh the numbers that we actually want to
generate in our sequence so let's like
let's let's uh execute this and let's
see an example of what happens so it
asks me how many Fibonacci numbers I
would like to generate and I will say I
want the first let's say six Fibonacci
numbers so I execute this as you can see
this gives me the first six numbers in
the sequence which is 1 and 1 and then 2
which is basically one plus one and then
three which is 1 plus 2 and then 5 which
is 2 plus 3 8 which is three plus five
so if we wanted more numbers we would
just enter over here like say if we
wanted the first 10 numbers it would
give us the first 10 numbers in the
sequence as you can see here now in our
next example what we are going to do is
we're going to write a program which
takes two digits that represent the
dimensions of an array so for example if
we want a three by three array we will
enter three comma 3 and we are going to
generate a two dimensional array in
which each of the elements of the array
are basically the row times the column
position of that particular element and
what I mean by this is say we have a
position I comma J on the array the
value of the element at that position
would be I times J so for example if I'm
looking at something at the third row
and the fifth column or say the third
row and the third column for example the
value of the element would be 3 times 3
and if I'm looking at something at the
second row and the fourth column I am
going to do 2 times 4. so let's uh let's
see how we can do this using Code so if
you look to the right over here I have a
piece of code where I'm going to uh in
where it asks me to input two numbers
two integers to represent the dimensions
of my uh example my sample array now
once we have done this we are going to
store these uh these dimensions in the
inputs in in a variable called input
string so obviously when we enter say 5
comma 5 that will be stored as an INT in
this particular string or this variable
what we want is we want five save a
enter 5 comma five we want five as a
separate integer and the other five as
another separate integer and that is
what we do in this particular statement
where we are going to split up our input
string based on the comma separator and
we're going to store the first part of
that string into the 0th position of
Dimensions which is an array and the
next dimension in the first position in
this particular array now we are going
to store the number of rows as row
number and that is the zeroth position
of this array and we're going to store
the number of columns as the first
position of Dimensions or whatever we've
mentioned in the input so now we we have
this our results array called multi list
which is basically what what our final
array is going to look like and we are
going to store into multi-list and in
this example we will be using for Loops
to do this or to create this particular
array so as you can see here our first
uh we have initialized our multi-list
saying that we're going to have only
zeros in our sample array so initial
really once we have initialized this
array all multi lists will contain is a
say for example we have inputted a five
by five array it will have basically a
five by five array with all elements as
zero and that's what this line does once
we have done this we are going to move
on to the for Loop portion where we are
actually going to create our array that
we want so as you can see we are our
first for Loop is going to say four row
in range row number so obviously uh
range will generate a an iterator which
can be iterated over and since it says
range row number and say our the number
of rows that we entered were five what
it's going to do is it's going to create
an iterator containing the value 0 1 2 3
and 4. so for row and range it will
basically basically row will take the
value 0 1 2 3 and 4. and a similar thing
is going to happen in this nested for
Loop which is within this where we're
going to again uh create a an iterator
using this range function and for the
column number once we have this we're
going to do the simple process of
multiplying the uh the value of the
element based on its position so if it's
at the position 3 comma 4 we're going to
store the value 3 times 4 into that
particular position of the array and
we're going to do this for every
position which is what happens in these
two for Loops we are going to first go
by each row and then within that we're
going to check each column and we're
going to perform these calculations and
finally we print our result so let's
look at an example now I'm going to say
I want a 3 by let's say a 2 by 4 Matrix
so let's see what the results will be
when I give this as uh so what I'm
saying is I want two rows and four
columns now as you can see here it might
not be very clear to you right now but
what you can see here is this is the
first row and this is the second row and
each row contains four columns so these
are the this is the my final array that
I get so what you can see here is this
is the zeroth position and the uh or you
can say this is the first row First
Column first row second column and since
python is zero based so this is actually
the zeroth row and this is the first row
so as you can see uh this this value
basically is zero times one this value
is zero times two zero times three zero
times four and over here it is one times
zero one times one one times two one
times three so similarly if I did for
example a five by five Matrix what you
will get is five rows now five rows and
five columns and for example like this
particular value is uh one two three or
zero one two three so zero one two three
and the First Column so this is three
times one
um if I took this value this is like the
fourth row for example fourth row times
the um zero one two three third column
so this would be four times three which
is twelve so and uh each value of this
has been generated in the similar
process so this is an example of how we
can use for Loops
um for a particular exercise that I have
shown you right now in this video we
will be covering the topic of definite
iterations using for Loops in Python so
starting off we know that there are two
types of iterations in programming uh
definite and indefinite we have already
covered indefinite iterations in the
form of while Loops definite iterations
on the other hand are done using the
keyword for and the basic syntax or the
standard syntax for a basic for Loop in
Python is as you can see over here we
have this four keyword we have some
variable we have the in keyword and we
have this iterable and we of course
Define this control structure with the
colon and then indented we have this
statement block so once this for Loop
has started we execute all of these
statements within the statement block as
part of the for Loop iteration so yeah
let's uh now let's to understand like
how for loops work uh exactly let's look
at the concept or meaning behind what we
call iterables and iterators so so think
of it in a stepwise manner all right so
we in Python we have different objects
that can be used as iterables and an
iterable is basically some object that
uh it's it's a collection of other
objects so you know think of your lists
uh think of dictionaries and sets so all
of these are essentially collections of
objects so once we have these collection
of objects we can create an iterator out
of it uh how do we do that is we use the
iter function so for example if I pass
this list a if I pass this list a
through the iter function and I store it
in some variable iter underscore a and I
see what is it underscore a it is
actually a list iterator at some random
memory location which we don't really
care about similarly if I give a tuple
and I did the same thing I will create a
tuple iterator and in the left if you
can see over here I've done the exact
same functions with sets and
dictionaries as well so I'm creating
iterators out of these
eternal variables so as to speak uh now
what is an iterator well an iterator is
an object that yields values
successively so if my list contained
five values or five objects an iterator
of this list will yield these values uh
one after the other and that is kind of
how or that is the basis for which we do
we create Loops let's see what we
exactly mean using this uh using another
function that we call the next function
so the next function keeps moving from
object to object within an iterator so
since I've created this list iterator
let's just do it once again so as you
can see I've created this list iterator
underscore a now with this item
underscore a what I'm going to do is I'm
going to use this next function what
next function does is starting from the
leftmost object within this iterator I
will keep yielding or keep producing the
values so let's let's just see what
happens when I do next item when I do
next for this particular variable it
gives me this object first now let's see
what happens when I do it again
now it gives me the object second what
if I did it again it gives me third now
if I kept doing this it will keep giving
me the different objects that were
initially stored in a that is first and
then second third fourth and fifth one
after the other so let's actually
perform that now I get fourth now I get
fifth now a natural question is now that
I've exhausted all of these values what
will happen if I perform the next
function again well let's see what
happens I get a uh an error or and this
error is the stop iteration function
error which basically is telling me look
you have exhausted all of the objects
that were initially present in this list
a and you cannot you cannot keep doing
the next next function anymore you
cannot keep going further so yeah so
this is uh what the next function does
when it comes to the concept of
iterators all right so now we've learned
two things what is an iterator and what
is the how do we create an iterator out
of different collections of objects like
a list or a tuple and we've also learned
how to use the next function now let's
uh move or let's come back to our for
Loop that we started off this video with
so our for loop again let's consider our
for Loop over here
as you can see some for loop with the
objects again one two three four and
five all right this is a list now I'm
going to do for X in a print X and let's
try to see what happens when we do this
okay as you can see when I have executed
this it gives me one two three four and
five so I have first of all let's look
at this for loop I in this for loop I
Define a new variable X and then I say
for X in a print X and what's happening
well in each iteration I am printing
whatever the value of x is at present so
in the first iteration it is the first
object one in the second iteration it is
the second object two then three four
five and then finally uh on its own like
uh this for Loop knows that okay now
once I have exhausted all of the objects
within my iterator I can stop doing this
for Loop and I can move on with the rest
of the code all right so think of it
like a three-step process uh a for Loop
in Python the first step is it calls an
iter function to obtain an iterator for
whatever we pass over here this iterable
second step it calls the next function
repeatedly in each iteration all right
to keep getting the next item from the
iterator so it gets one then it calls
next then it gets two then it calls next
and it gets three and then four and then
five and so on and then finally the
third step is determination step is when
after we do the final next where we get
this error as you can see the stop
iteration error or exception finally
this does the for Loop function or the
for Loop that okay we have reached the
end of our definite iteration or the end
of our definite for Loop and this is
where we must terminate our Loop and
then continue with the rest of the code
all right so this is how a for Loop
Works in Python now it's very important
to note that whatever we have discussed
when it came to while Loops such as
nesting of while loops and nesting of
other control structures is also
applicable in the case of for Loops so
if I had a for Loop in another for Loop
that is perfectly fine if I had a while
within a for Loop that is perfectly fine
so all of these are valid statement
blocks that we can do and again for Loop
is another control structure and so we
must follow the concept of indentation
when it comes to writing our statement
blocks within a for Loop okay so now I'm
going to speak about in specific I'm
going to speak about the this uh
something called the range function that
is uh quite you could say it's used
definitely it's used in other areas of
programming but it's widely used in
Python uh I mean I mean the for Loop in
Python uh what I mean by this is that um
Range this range function is very
important for the for Loop and we will
see why okay so let's look at one of the
examples of using the range function so
what does the range function do is if I
give range 5 let's see what it does it
gives me range 0 to 5. what this
basically tells me is that this will
create an iterator that contains uh
integers from 0 to 5 so it will contain
the object 0 1 2 3 4 and 5 and we can
use this as an iterator so let's let's
look at this uh I have Range Five let's
store this in X okay now let's do a type
just to see what happens when we do Type
X it should give me the type of range as
you can see and this is a type of an
iterator in Python now let's see what
happens when I do for I in X print I
okay let's see what happens as you can
see it prints the number zero one two
three four an important caveat when it
comes to the range function is when we
say range 5 it creates an iterator from
0 to 5 but it contains the objects 0 1 2
3 and 4 only it does not contain the
object 5 itself okay this is something
that is very important to so once again
I created I use this range function to
create an iterator from if iterator five
objects from zero to four zero one two
three and four uh I use that in my for
Loop and that's what that is what you
are seeing here now let's use this range
function in the context of something
else for example let's see so I had my
earlier list a right look at my list a
here
so you can see list a contains these one
two three four five five objects okay
let's see what length of a is length of
a is five okay uh let's use the range
function on top of the length of this
list a and this is uh like I can't show
you an example right now without any
context but this uh this form of using a
for Loop is used is widely used in
Python Programming you will use it so
much in data science you will use so
much in machine learning and AI I cannot
tell you uh this is so this is a very
important like sort of uh for Loop
expression so you have four let's say I
in range Len a let's see what's going on
here first I create uh first I do length
of a that gives me 5 then I do range of
5 that creates an iterator between 0 and
4 right when you do Range Five it gives
you an iterator of zero one two three
and four as we saw earlier and this is
what we're doing over here we have
created an iterator out of the length of
a list now when I do print I it should
give me again one two three four zero
one two three four of course so as you
can see here it will give me zero one
two three four and this is a very neat
way of using the range function on top
of the length of a particular collection
of objects in this case we're using the
list a this is something that you will
use a lot so I I would recommend that
you get used to this form of creating a
for loop as well using the range
function also of course
um there are uh the you can use break
and continue statements as you have in
the case of while Loops uh exactly this
it works exactly the same in the case of
for Loops wherein the break statement
will abruptly stop the for Loop
completely and we will move on to the
next piece of code whereas the continue
statement will break that particular
iteration and then we will resume with
the next iteration so yeah that was
breaking continue statements and for
Loops finally I would like to show you
something about uh how to use
dictionaries as an iterator or or as an
iterable when it comes to for Loops so
let's create our dictionary let's go we
have a dictionary already here in fact
create this dictionary again we'll store
it in a okay so I created this
dictionary a all right so I have
dictionary a uh what I'm going to do is
I'm going to pass it through the iter
function as you can see and now I'm
going to just for the sake of showing
you it will show I'll show you that it
is actually an iterator of type of a
specific key iterator type all right so
now let's uh let's do something on this
so as you can see in the dictionary I
have the key first that has the value 1
I have the key second that has a value 2
I have the key third that has a value
three and then fourth for four fifth for
five now a good question would be when I
do iteration or when I do a for loop on
top of this a well what is it going to
pick up is it going to pick up first uh
is it going to pick up the keys like
these or is it going to pick up the
values or is it going to go one by one
key and then value and then key in the
subsequent value uh let's see what
actually happens let's do 4 I in iter
underscore a print I let's see what what
is The iterations Happening upon using
this so as you can see we're using the
keys so by default when we do this when
we perform when we create an iterator
out of a dictionary we use only the keys
as our iterator elements or at iterator
values but of course like if you wanted
to use values all you would have to do
is pass a DOT values over here and if
you remember from a dictionary video
this uh a DOT values gives us a list of
or it it gives us the essentially a list
of the values in our dictionary so when
we pass this to the iterator uh iter
function and we create an iterator out
of it let's see what happens over here
now let's see what is ETA underscore a
you can actually see it's now the dict
value iterator at a particular memory
location in so it's not the dict key as
we saw earlier it's a dict value
iterator so now that we have this by
dictionary value iterator now let's
print what are our iterator elements and
as you can see now we are printing
values and not the keys so this is how
to this this is basically two different
ways of iterating through a dictionary
one through keys and one through values
in this video we will be doing a small
exercise on if statements now in the
previous video you might have already
seen some of the basic concepts
surrounding if statements however in
this video just to drive home the point
or the purpose of an if statement we
will be doing a small exercise so let's
first revise some of the concepts of an
if statement so basic if statement can
be something like this we have a small
condition where we are checking if a
variable X is greater than 5 or not and
if it is greater than x we print a
statement over here so if this condition
is met we print this statement as we
move to the statement log now our
variable X has the value 5. now since X
is not greater than 5 what this will do
is it will check the statement and since
this will be false we skip the statement
block and move on to this statement so
as you can see here similarly we can do
something where we are checking multiple
statements we use the L if statement in
such a case so now in this block we are
checking in one of the one of the
conditions we're checking is if x is
equal to 5 or if x is greater than 5 and
then finally if both of these conditions
are not met we say else and we print
whatever or we do whatever is in this
particular statement block which is a
simple print statement so as you can see
X is indeed good is equal to 5 so this
is the block that will get executed as
you can see here now another example our
nested if statements so Nestle if else
statements are if else statements within
if else statements so let's look at an
example
as you can see here we have a string
stored in a variable called orange
quality and the string is fresh now we
have an integer or a float in this case
4.0 stored in Orange price now our first
statement is checking whether orange
quality the variable orange quality is
it equal to the string fresh now within
that if the statement or if this
condition is met we do another check
where we're checking what is the price
is it lesser than 5 if it is V2 this
block else we execute this block finally
if our initial uh statement our initial
condition is not met we move on to this
else block now when I execute this what
should happen is I will enter this block
because this is true and finally I will
enter this block because this condition
is also true so I should have this
printed I will buy five dozens as you
can see here now let's move on to our
main exercise for this video so this was
all just the revision now we're going to
use some or all of these Concepts in a
sample project or a sample exercise to
for your further practice so in this
exercise what we're going to do is we're
going to request the user to enter a
number between 1 and 20 and our our code
is going to check whether this number
entered is an even number or an odd
number so as you can see there are two
sets of checks that we're going to do in
this code the first check is going to be
whether the number that is entered is
between 1 and 20 or not and if it is not
we have to say it's an invalid number
but if it is entered between 1 and 20 we
have to move on to the further checks
which is whether it is an even or an odd
number so let's see how we do that so in
this piece of code what we start with is
a print statement saying please enter a
number between 1 and 20 and then we add
an input command this input command will
open a box where we can enter whatever
number that we want to enter now we use
this int keyword to make sure that
whatever we have entered into the input
box is stored as a int data type in the
enter num variable once we do that our
first if statement is going to check
whether the entered number is greater
than or equal to 1 or lesser than equal
to 20. sorry and less than equal to 20.
so both of these conditions have to be
met if this condition is true then we
have a valid input and this statement is
printed that we have entered a valid
number and then we move on to the rest
of the statement block within this if
statement which is another set of if and
else if statements if our number is not
between 120 we move to this block and
this block prints that we have entered
in invalid number now once we have say
entered a valid number we move on to
this block this if if else if LF
statement block now what this block is
checking is whether the entered number
is an even number or not now as we know
an even number is divisible by 2 when we
the remainder 0 when divided by 2. so
this is what this check is doing if this
check is true that means our number is
even and we get printed that our number
is even the other other check or the
other uh if statement is checking
whether it's an odd number and that
means when we divide by 2 we should get
the remainder 1 as you can see here and
we get printed your number is odd so
let's execute this and see what happens
when we enter a number now it's asking
me to enter a number let's say I enter
17.
now that I've entered 17 as you can see
it's a valid number that I have entered
and the code is telling me that my
number is indeed odd let's look at some
other what if I entered something else
here let's say if I enter 16 now since
it's an even number as you can see 16 is
also a valid number as it's between 1
and 20 and my number is even and the
code checks for that let's see if I what
happens when I enter an invalid number
let's say 25 an hour into 25 as you can
see it says I have entered invalid
number and in this case what has
happened is this condition itself is not
met and I have moved on to this
statement block so to give you a
breakdown as to how our code has
executed this let me show you an example
for the number say 9 when I enter nine
the first check that happens of course
is this check whether it's a valid
number or not and since it is between 1
and 20 we move on to this block and in
this block it's checking whether our
numbers divisible by 2 or not and since
it is not it will remain it will leave a
remainder 1 and we execute this block it
says our print our number is Odd as you
can see here in this video we are going
to learn about the topic called file
handling now file handling is basically
needed because so most of the times when
we are handling large and different
types of data in python or in general we
cannot store everything into a variable
and we will have to use files now there
are two types of files that we are going
to deal with they are binary and text
files so binary files are some of the
files that we most of the files that we
commonly encounter like document files
image Files video files Etc now all
binary files are encoded in a particular
format and they cannot be read by a
normal text editor and we would be
needing certain specific softwares for
specific files text files on the other
hand do not have any specific encoding
and they can be opened in the normal
text editor itself and they are like XML
CSS HTML files and so on now there are
four main operations that we can do 2 on
file in Python on files they are open
read write and close there are certain
other operations as well though like
rename delete so some of the most basic
operation that we can do is obviously
creating and opening a file and the
syntax is as you can see here where we
store where we use the open command and
we give a file name and we give a mode
and we store that in a particular
variable now a mode is uh basically
telling python how to handle this
opening so we can have a read-only mode
which is done by this letter r a write
only mode which is done by letter W and
for there are a bunch of other modes
such as read or write mode which is done
by R plus and we're going to see them as
we encounter them now that it's
important to note that what I just
mentioned is for text files if we are
going to do for binary files we are
going to do this file handling then we
would be using the letter B in front of
whatever we were using in the case of
text files so if we were doing a
read-only mode for opening a binary file
um we would be using RB and if we were
doing read and write mode a read or
write only mode for a binary file we
would be using RB plus so basically just
adding the b in the case of binary files
let's look at a basic example when we
want to open a particular file we are
going to open like in this example I'm
going to open some file called
firehandling.txt in a read and write
mode read or write mode and I'm going to
store it in fo so this is as simple as
it gets similarly if I wanted to do it
for the binary file since I'm using a
binary file I will use the letter B as
well in the mode and that's how you do
it here now let's look at different ways
in which we can read from a file and
there are three commands that we can use
we can use the read command followed by
a optional number of characters we can
use the read line command followed by an
option number of characters and the read
lines command so this optional number of
characters denoted by n over here
um and basically telling us how many
characters we want to print so let's
look at a simple example of where I'm
going to print something called so I'm
going to take this and I'm going to do a
print on top of this so I have done
first I've opened it and I've stored it
in my file and then I'm going to do a uh
a method or a function called read and
I'm going to say like in this example
just read the whole thing so as you can
see my file that I have opened has all
of these lines this is like the whole
file basically but now what if I wanted
to open only the first five characters
of this file which is basically this
well in that case let's open this once
again now let's do the same read command
except we will give the character number
which is five as you can see it's only
printed five now let's do a print read
command and try to read the whole thing
again and you will notice something very
interesting now when I do the read
command you can see it's kind of picked
up from where we left off you know from
our previous command and that is the
nature of how python handles files so if
I wanted to again take the cursor back
in such an example I will have to open
this again and then I use this read
command once again to get back to where
I started from as you can see here now
another command that we can use is the
read line command so let's uh once again
next time if I do it it should say big
data as you can see here okay so this is
the read line command now within the
realign command also we can enter uh
characters and that will tell us
basically
um that we want these number of
characters from the next line so if I
want the first six characters of the
next line I will say six I've learned to
six here and it will give me the first
six characters of this particular line
which is the next line that is to come
as you can see here now another way in
which we can print whatever is there in
our file line by line is by using a for
Loop so again I'm going to open this
file I'm going to store it here now I'm
going to use it for Loop saying that
well for a line in my file and what this
does is basically at each each iteration
it's going to take each line and store
it in this variable that we enter over
here which is called line itself and
we're going to print that at the end of
the loop what we'll have is all of the
lines have been printed one by one and
another thing that we can do right now
is say we want to read a particular line
see I wanted you to read the fifth line
of my file I can use this technique
where
um I just say okay I'm going to store 5
in this variable called line number and
I have this another variable called
current line which I'm going to
initialize with one and I'm going to any
I'm gonna what I'm going to do is I mean
but I'm gonna add a condition saying
that only if current line when it's
equal to line number am I going to print
the line and then I'm going to break out
of this whole thing and at the end of
each Loop I'm going to say current line
is going to be incremented by one until
basically these two variables are equal
so when I do this I get my result which
is machine learning which is the fifth
line of um my which is the fifth line of
whatever file I had now we're gonna move
on to the topic of um image file
handling so we saw how we handled and we
we saw certain operations around text
files and text files are obviously
something that we're going to use a lot
but we are also going to be using files
such as images a lot and let's look at
certain examples and certain use cases
around image file handling so my first
step is going to be importing a bunch of
modules and packages now the details of
these modules and these packages are not
important as of right now because they
will be covered in a future video but
just keep a note of some of these
packages such as
um they say numpy and image the image
package so once I've done this let's
move on to my example so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to store certain file
locations in two variables so it's
basically two strings I've attached the
uh this prefix R to say that this is a
read-only uh sort of a prefix so the
next topic that we're going to be
handling is image file handling now we
have already seen many examples
pertaining to text files so text files
are obviously something that we're going
to be using a lot but image file
handling is something very important as
well and we're going to see certain
operations that we can do around image
file handling so starting off I'm going
to import a bunch of packages and
modules what these packages exactly are
and what these modules exactly are are
right now not of that important of not
are not that important to you right now
but it's something that will be covered
in a future or in future videos uh it's
important to just keep note of what
these are such as numpy and image so
once I've done that what I'm going to
store is I'm going to store two
particular file locations into variables
location one and location two and I've
prefixed them with r just to say that
these are raw strings so once I've done
that I'm going to use the image from the
image package I'm going to say open and
I'm going to say open from this
particular location and this particular
location and I'm going to store these
image images in I M1 and im2 over here
very similar to a normal text file
opening now once we've done this we can
access certain properties of this image
using say format which tells us the
format of the file it attributes the it
identifies the source of an image and if
the image will not read from a file it
is set to none we can also see the size
of the file using the size attribute and
we can see the mode which basically
defines the number and names of the
bands in the image and also contains a
pixel type and depth certain common
modes are like L for luminescence RGB
for true color images and CMYK for
pre-press images so let's look at them
so when I access this you can see my
first file is of jpeg of this size and
an RGB format image and my second image
is another jpeg slightly bigger image
and again RGB now we can also of course
display these images and to do that we
can use the PLT again PLT is the is
supposed to and for matplotlib DOT
pipelot it's a particular for a
particular package that again you don't
need to know the details of right now
but this is how we would do this so I'm
going to use a bunch of commands and
methods such as figure and subplot and
then I am sure so once I have done this
as you can see both of my images with
this being im1 this being im2 I have
been produced on the screen as you can
see I can also use display this display
function followed by the name of the
file and this will simply display my
image as you can see here now I can
obviously save a particular image using
the save function which is as simple as
just doing this so I'm going to save the
image as I am underscore save.jpg over
here now if I wanted to crop an image I
can do that as well so I initially I
stored the dimensions that I want
cropped in the form of a tuple as you
can see here and I'm going to pass that
Tuple to the crop function and I'm going
to apply that on top of im1 and I'm
going to store that to region once I've
done that as you can see so basically
what I've done is I've cropped this
image based on whatever I've passed here
and I've stored it into region and now
if I wanted to see what was actually in
that crop I can just do the IM show
function and I'm going to pass the
particular cropped image which is
denoted by region as you can see here
and you can see my cropped image is
basically a certain a left portion of
this whole image has been cropped out
and I have produced it over here now I
can also use the copy function using
it's a simple basically copy basically
you use the copy function and it copies
an image onto another variable that you
have assigned and when I use the IM show
function I am going to show you the
copied image which is basically the same
now we can do the transpose operation as
well so let's see some of the let's see
what we have done here so in this
transpose opposite operation so in this
basically I've done a bunch of operation
editions such as rotating by 90 degrees
rotating by 180 rotating by 7 270 and
finally once I've done with all of these
multiple operations I am going to show
you the final output which is basically
a certain transposed image like this
which is basically the result of
whatever I have done before this so this
is it for this video on file handling I
have shown you two slightly more
comprehensive examples on text files and
even certain examples on image files
however we can use file handling in
different libraries pertaining to file
handling for audio files and even for
like stuff like PDF files and this is
like this is just only the beginning and
I'm sure you will encounter a lot of
different use cases different examples
as you continue learning Python
Programming this video is going to be
the first of a part of a series on
object oriented programming so to start
off with let's try to understand and get
an introduction into what is object
oriented programming well as the name
suggests object oriented programming is
all about creating objects an object is
a group of interrelated variables and
functions variables can be referred to
as the properties of the object whereas
the functions can be referred to as the
behavior of an object so if we were to
treat say for example a car as an object
its properties would be its color its
model its price and its brand whereas
Its Behavior or functions for that
matter would be like accelerating gear
change braking similarly if I give you
an example of a dog as an object we
could consider the properties of the dog
as its weight or its name its breed its
color whereas its functions could be say
barking playing eating walking Etc
objects provide a better and a clear
structure for a program now let's move
on to what is a class and an instance
now a class is like a blueprint or a
template of certain functions and
entities whereas an instance is a
particular realization of a class
classes are used to create user-defined
data structures and Define certain
functions called Methods within the
class whereas instances are realizations
of these classes and when we are
speaking of classes and instances
classes don't contain any real data they
are just merely templates instances on
the other hand contain real data to
think of an example of the difference
between a class and an instance think of
a class like a empty form or a
questionnaire now an empty form of a
questionnaire does not have any
information but it does have a template
to it it tells you to fill in certain
information and based on who is filling
in the information that information or
the data on a particular form will be
different so an instance is like a
filled out form with its own a unique
set of information that is one way of
treating or understanding what is a
class and in instance now for our first
example on classes I will be taking you
through a class where I've defined based
on the circle object so this class is
going to define basically information
about your general circles such as this
radius and this area so let's go through
it now obviously to define a class we
need a keyword well in the case of
classes we use the class keyword
followed by a name for that class so in
this case my name is circle now after
the colon every every information that
is part of the class has to be obviously
indented as is typical for python now
you can see over here A bunch of Dev
keywords followed by something that you
might not be familiar with and I will
try to get you through this so if you
see here you have a def keyword followed
by init and this init is prefixed by a
double underscore and it's suffix by a
double underscore and you can see the
same thing for Str and repr well this
double underscore is called it under and
any method these are of course methods
this is a method this is a method this
is a method this is a method now any
method that is prefixed and suffixed by
double underscores are called Dunder
methods these Dunder methods are or can
be thought of like predefined or
built-in methods for any class that you
define so these we have like three
render methods over here and we have one
user defined method that we will get to
so this first method that you see here
is the init method or the initialization
method and this is invoked or called
whenever we create an instance of this
class Circle and what we do here is
basically we pass when we create this
instant Circle we are what what happens
is that we are we get an option to pass
an a value for a what what is this uh
keyword or variable radius so if I pass
so you will see me later on creating an
instance where um I will be passing a
value and that value is basically stored
as the radius and by default the radius
that will be passed whenever we create
an instance for this class is one the
Str method is basically used to return a
descriptive string for the the instance
of class
um our API is not something that you
have to bother with right now and uh now
get area is something that you should
follow because if you see here I have
not used any double underscores so this
is a user user defined method user
defined methods are so methods that we
Define and these are like tasks that we
Define on our own so in my user defined
method called get area I will be
returning the area of this circle based
on the radius that I pass to it now if
you notice here the before every in
every method I have the self keyword
before any other attribute so like this
has self this has self even the get area
herself now what this means
um self is like an optional keyword that
is used to improve readability of a
program for first of all and it's also
the function of the self keyword is
basically
um telling python that well any of the
methods that we are invoking in this
class or the instance of this class has
to refer to attributes and variables
within that instance of that class so if
I'm going to use get area function I am
going to get values and attribute values
and variable values based on only the
current instance of that particular
class self is obviously optional we
don't really need it but basically the
first attribute of any method is is
basically the is basically what the meth
is the instance that the method is
invoked upon so if I say self I am
telling this particular function that
okay all the value that you're going to
get for performing whatever task you
want is going to be found in that
particular instance where you have been
invoked itself now don't worry if all
this is very confusing
um this might be in the beginning but
just try to understand that this is
something that we do for good practice
and you will understand uh when when to
yourself or when not to yourself as you
learn about objective oriented
programming so if you see here my get a
job function is supposed to return the
value radius times radius self dot
radius is basically telling um whatever
value I've passed for radius for that
particular instance you can read this as
radius times radius times pi as well so
obviously this is pi R square which is
the area of a particular circle now let
me show you an example where I am going
to perform some of these functions so if
you see this first line I have created
an instance of the class Circle where
I've passed 2.1 for the radius of the
circle so now the value of the variable
radius in this particular instance is
going to be stored as 2.1 and this
particular instance is going to be
stored in the variable C1 now the print
C1 function invokes the Str self defined
or predefined function now if you
remember Str was it's basically used to
return a particular string that
describes like what the class will do
and this is something that we Define on
our own in our example Str will return
the uh the string saying this is a
circle with radius of and then it will
return the radius that we passed so in
this case it should say this is the
circle of radius 2.1 as you can see over
here so if I execute this you can notice
this line This is a circle with radius
2.1 and this is invoked by the print
function the print basically invokes the
dunder Str function which does all of
this now in the next line we say print
C1 dot get area so this is going to
print the value of the what what gets
returned when we invoke the method get
area for this particular instance C1 so
obviously in this particular instance
our radius is 2.1 so the get area
function should do pi times 2.1 square
and the value is as you can see here is
some 13.85 so that is the area that we
got now if we want to print a particular
radius we just say print C1 dot radius
so this will print the value of what is
what is stored in radius for the
particular instance C1 now you might
notice me using a DOT whenever it comes
to defining a certain function or a
keyword well any time that we want to
invoke or use a method of a particular
class we have to use the dot keyword so
we use the instance name C1 dot followed
by whatever method that we want to use
so if we want to use the get area
function we say C1 dot get area if you
want to find out what is there in the
radius key radius variable of a
particular instance we say C1 dot radius
now before we move on let's talk about
some of the naming conventions class
names are initial capitalized so if our
class name is for example
um like for example if it's camel case
well each word that is part of this
class has its first letter capitalized
variables and Method names are in lower
class so if my class was called Circle
we say class circle with C being in
capital now moving on let's talk about
how we initialize or Define instance
variables now instance variables are
declared within the init method if you
remember from the earlier example of
circle init is a Dunder method it's
followed and it's preceded by double
underscore as you can see here now if
you see in this particular case I have
again used the self keyword and as I
mentioned earlier the self keyword is
the first parameter of all member
methods
um and it this basically binds that
particular method to the particular
instance itself during invocation so
every time a new Circle object is
created the dot init function sets the
initial state of the object by assigning
the values of the object's properties so
if the init function basically
initializes each and every new instance
of um whatever of our class so we can
give in it any number of parameters but
the first parameter must always be a
variable called self now when a new
class instance is created the instance
is automatically passed to the self
parameter in init so that new attributes
can be defined on the object inside the
init method the self.radius basically
means that we want the value of radius
based on the current instance itself so
as you can see radius defines an
instance variable radius and we're going
to use the particular instance and its
value of 4 radius in our variable radius
now instance uh the inner I mean the
init function is not a Constructor but
it is an initializer to create instance
variables the init function also will
never return a value and it is optional
and can be omitted if there are no
instance variables now let's move on to
class variables so now as we mentioned
earlier all the attributes that are
created inside the init function are
instance specific attributes and the
instance attributes are obviously
specific to a particular instance of the
class for example all objects now if we
have a class called dog then all dog
objects have a name and age but the
values for the name and age will vary
depending on which dog we are talking
talking about or basically which
instance of the dog are we talking about
now class attributes are attributes that
have the same value for all class
instances and we define a class
attribute by assigning a valuable value
to a variable outside of the init
function so if you look at this example
over here we have created another class
called Circle and we have this
initializer again where we have class
specific variable called radius which
whose value will change depending on
whatever we pass for that particular
instance however if you look before the
initial the init init function or the
initializer function if you see here we
have another variable called shape
object which stores the string Circle
and this variable is going to be the
same and constant for every instance of
the class Circle and unlike the variable
radius we will not have different values
depending on a particular instance okay
now let's talk about instantiating an
object and let's see what happens when
we create two different instances of the
same class so as you can see here I've
created an instance C1 for class Circle
and I'm going to check its ID well if
you see the ID is something like this
now if I create it another instance over
here called C2 and if I check its ID
well it's something different now so if
you see each instance basically has a
different memory location in our memory
um and each instance is this is how each
instance is different each time we
create it and they are created in
different memory locations finally
before we conclude this topic on the
introduction into oop let's talk about
class methods instance methods and
static methods now class methods are
usually declared are actually declared
with the at class method operator or
decorator as you can see here it accepts
the class as its first argument so in
this case I am going to say I'm going to
define a class called my class I'm gonna
use this at class method decorator to
say that whatever follows here is going
to be a class method and I've defined a
class method called hello that takes in
a um that uses against self and a name
attribute so what this does is it prints
um whatever I have passed to it in the
form of hello from self.name now what
this this is going to do is basically
it's going to give out a string saying
hello from name of the whatever class we
have and whatever we pass the attribute
name so oh in this my particular in this
case I'm going to invoke this method
using the class name itself I'm not
going to use an instance name because I
have no instance in this particular
example and since this is a class method
it can be invoked using the class name
itself so I'm going to pass Rakesh and
let's see what happens when we do this
as you can see the first print will
basically give us the information of the
class itself it's saying that the class
is called my class and the second print
statement is basically a string saying
hello from uh the string name my class
with a comma and then whatever we passed
initially which was Rakesh next is then
instance methods and these are the most
common types of methods um these are
invoked by an instance object so we have
to create an instance to actually use an
instance method and it takes the
instance or the keyword itself as its
first argument so if I say class dot
class if I define a class my class in
this example and I'm going to Define
another function called hello as you can
see I have not used any decorator like
at class method so this is going to be
an instance method and it's going to be
invoked by the particular instance so in
this case it's going to print hello from
and it's going to basically say the name
of the class again so I create my
instance called my instance one and it's
an instance of this class and then I'm
going to invoke the instance method by
using this drop dot operator and the
instance name and the result will be
basically this string over here as you
can see now finally we have another type
of method called the static method which
is declared using the add static method
decorator so a static method does not
know its class and is just attached to
the class for convenience it does not
depend on the state of the object and
could be from a separate function of a
module a static method can be invoked
via a class object or an instance object
so if you look at this example over here
I have defined a static method I've
defined hello and it basically says
print hello world so it's going to
basically just print this so if you can
see here I created my instance and I'm
going to say dot hello it should
basically pre print print hello world
that's all in this video we will
continue the discussion on oop with
inheritance inheritance is used to
describe the relationship between two
classes wherein one class takes the
methods and properties from another
class in this relationship we have
something called the base class or the
parent class from which we will derive
all our sum of the properties and
methods and the class which actually
derives these properties and methods is
known as the derived class so you can
think of the derived class as a
specialized version of a base class to
explain what inheritance is in a basic
way I will show you an example where I'm
creating a cylinder class which is going
to be a subclass of the circle class
that you might have encountered in the
earlier video on op so what we're going
to do is create a cylinder class that is
a subclassive circle where we're going
to get the attributes radius and get
area from Circle class and we're going
to add the attributes height and get
volume to the cylinder so right off the
start you can see we have our class
Circle that you might have seen in the
earlier video so this class Circle has
the familiar initialization where we are
supposed to enter a value for a radius
that gets stored in self dot radius now
we also have a description string which
basically is a Dunder method that
returns a string when we invoke the
print command on a particular instance
and we have the get area method as well
now if we move on to this cylinder class
you can see that I'm defining this class
with the class keyword with the cylinder
name but you can see that I have added a
parenthesis and within it I have
mentioned the name of the superclass
that I want the cylinder class to be a
subclass of so this is how we actually
Define a subclass in the most basic way
you want two different attributes for
our cylinder instances now if you see
here there's a line which says super dot
in it now this is like um this is a
command which we use to invoke the
superclasses initializer so anytime we
create an instance for cylinder we also
want an initialization for the circle
method as well as a part of our cylinder
instance next you can see that much like
how we store itself I mean the radius
attribute in cell dot radius we're also
storing the height attribute in self dot
height now even this cylinder class has
an Str method to return a particular
string if you use this print function
and finally we get on to a more a new
method that we have defined only for the
cylinder class called get volume now if
you see the get volume it returns as
basically the volume of the cylinder
that is being described in the
particular instance for which we enter
the height and the radius so if you can
see here what we've basically added
extra is an a height attribute and
another method called get volume and the
other parts of the circle super class
such as radius and get area are also
going to be a part of cylinder even
though you do not explicitly see them
anywhere here and we will see how in uh
in the form of an example that's coming
up so let me just execute these classes
now that that's done I'm going to create
an instance for cylinder I'm going to
store it in cy1 and I'm going to pass
1.1 for the radius and 2.2 for the
height and once that is done let's just
print to invoke the HDR method and as
you can see the Str method basically
tells us the information that is a
cylinder with radius 1.1 and height 2.2
so now let's print what is the value we
get when we use the get area method now
it's important to note get area was not
explicitly defined in the cylinder
subclass but it's a method that is a
part of the circle superclass and we can
see that we can actually access methods
that are part of the superclass simply
by accessing any other method so if you
use the dot get area you can see that we
get a value for the area of the cylinder
so this basically this area is basically
the area of the circle face of the
cylinder the top or the Bottom now let's
use now let's invoke uh the subclass
specific method which is the get volume
method in a similar manner as you can
see just by doing invoking this method
we get the volume as well now if we want
to see what is the radius in the height
we can just do a simple print statement
followed by cy1 dot radius C1 dot height
and it gives us both of these values as
you can see here now over here what I'm
going to do is create another instance
of cylinder but I'm not going to pass
anything for radius or high right so
basically it's going to take the default
values for radiation height which was 1
and 1 respectively so once I print
um this is good this statement is
basically going to print the Str method
or whatever we stored in the Str which
is basically the description of the
object followed by what is its radius
and height this method will give us the
area and this method will give us the
volume so once I execute this as you can
see here this is what we get and this is
what we expect as well so now in this
example what I'm going to show you is uh
now I'm going to go back and I am going
to create another instance for circle
now this is the super class of course
and I'm gonna give it and since the
superclass has only one option uh one
attribute that we can enter which is for
the radius so I pass 3.3 and I'm gonna
print what what happens when I just
print uh this instance it's going to
basically give us whatever was a part of
the HDR method after that I'm going to
print is instance this is basically a
check on whether C1 is an instance of
this class Circle and X I'm going to
check if C1 is an instance of its
subclass cylinder now when I execute
this you can see that well this is what
we this is the Str method that gets
printed but if you see here you can see
that it says C1 is indeed a an instance
of circle when it says 2 over here but
when we look at the next line is C1 and
instance of cylinder it says false and
this is obviously because
um a super class object is never an
instance of a subclass object well as
whereas vice versa it would be true now
in the next part of this video what
we're going to do is look at the
different types of inheritances in
Python so there are basically five types
of inheritance in Python there is the
single inheritance there's multiple
inheritance multi-level inheritance
hierarchical hierarchical and Hybrid
inheritance so we will go one by one and
see each of these examples starting off
we have the single inheritance this is
simply where we have one Base Class and
one derived class from That Base Class
so this is a simple single inheritance
and in this example you can see I have a
class called country week where I have a
method that I've defined called show
country which is basically going to say
print this is India it's basically going
to print this every time we invoke this
show country method then we have a class
called state which derives uh from the
super class called country where we have
a method called show state which is
going to say print this is state every
time so you can see I created an
instance of the class State and I'm
through that instance I can access the
superclass and the subclass methods over
here next we have the multi-level uh
sorry multiple inheritance and this is
when a derived class contains more than
one Base Class so let's look at an
example to understand this so if you can
see here I have a class called student
with the two methods defined called
method one and Method two in method one
we can pass two attributes Sno or I
think is this this is supposed to be
like an ID I guess like SN number and we
have S name so this is basically two
attributes we can pass that are probably
descriptors for each student and in the
next method you have basically two print
statements which Says student number and
then they will print the student number
and it will also print the student name
next we have a class called marks this
is also
um so these these two classes are
basically what our super classes are
going to be and we're going to derive a
third class from these two so this
second class is a class called Marx and
we have two methods again one method is
called set marks which has the option of
putting in two attributes M1 and M2 both
are representative of the two marks and
we store them in self.mark1 self.mark2
the second method is put marks which is
going to print the marks namely mark one
and then it's going to tell us how much
marks are there in the first subject for
example and another print statement
doing the same thing for the second
subject of Mark two finally we have a
third class called a result which
derives from two classes marks and
student as you can see here in my
parenthesis I've passed in marks and
student it both are super classes and
our class result is going to derive from
both of them this is an example of
multiple inheritance and within this
class result I have two methods specific
to this derived class called calc
wherein I'm going to basically calculate
the two the total marks of um uh the the
total marks which is basically the
addition of Mark 1 plus Mark II and I'm
then I'm going to have another method
called put total which is going to print
me what is the total so if you can see
here I have created an instance of this
derived class called result I am storing
it in R then I'm going to access method
one which is obviously a method from the
first superclass called student and I'm
going to store okay so this is name is I
guess lucky and he has 60 marks secondly
then I'm going to do our set marks which
is the method from the second Super
class which is going to set the marks uh
respectively so you have lucky student
and his ID is 60 and he has got 50 and
60 marks respectively in say the first
two subjects and finally I'm going to
access the derived class method called
calc so this is going to do the sum
finally I'm going to also do our method
2 which is I'm going to print our
student number and student name next
we're going to have put marks which is
going to tell us the um what are the
individual marks for Mark 1 and Mark 2
and then finally we're going to print
the total marks with the put total so
once I execute this you can see here it
says student number 60 student name
lucky marks 1 is 50 as I wrote In Here
Max 260 as I passed here and then total
is 110 which is basically 50 plus 60.
now the next type of inheritance is
called multi-level inheritance now
multi-level inheritance can be assumed
as where you take a super class let's
call it a and you derive a Class B from
net class A now what if we derived a
Class C from B and we kept doing this so
until say a Class E now each of these
steps is in its own an inheritance but
this whole relationship can be described
as a multi-level inheritance so let's
take an example again so after this this
time I've defined a class called student
where I have defined two methods called
set stud and put stud or you can call it
set student and put student in my first
method I have two options of adding two
attributes again this is the story
number this is the student name in my
second method I am going to print what
is the student number and what is the
student name finally uh so sorry next we
have another class called marks which
derives from the first class called
student this has two methods called set
marks where I'm going to again get the
option of adding two integers for M1 and
M2 which is going to represent Mark 1
and Mark 2 and finally I have put marks
the method which is going to print Mark
1 and Mark 2. um finally I have another
class called result and this if you see
this derives from marks now if you see
this relationship you'll notice result
derives from marks whereas marks itself
derives from student and this is is an
example of multi-level hierarchy and
even as a part of this third class we
have its own methods called calc and put
total calc will calculate the total as
we had seen earlier and put total will
basically print that total and we're
going to do a very similar operation
we're going to create an instance of
this third class uh result and store it
in R then we're going to do basically
we're going to set the student details
uh his uh student number and his name
we're going to give him his marks 50 and
60. we're going to calculate what are
the total we're going to say okay now
put the details of what is the student's
number and name we're going to also
store enter I mean display his marks
Mark 1 and Mark 2 and finally we're
going to display the total marks so
let's execute this and if you see um
it's basically the similar operation
that we did earlier but the only
difference is in the earlier example I
was uh our third class result was
derived from Marx and student together
so this was an example of multiple
inheritance whereas in this example the
result class derives from marks and
marks itself derives from students so
this is an example of multi-level
inheritance finally we have sorry not
finally penultimately we have as our
fourth example of inheritance called
hierarchical inheritance apart in my Ms
presentation it's hierarchical
inheritance so in this case a base class
basically will contain more than one
derived class so let's see a look at an
example of what we mean here so I have a
class called one where I have defined a
method called display where what I'm
going to do is I'm going to source set.x
is equal to 1000 and self dot Y is equal
to 2000 then what I'm going to do is I'm
going to print a statement saying this
is the method in class 1 and I'm going
to say after that I'm going to print
another statement saying value of x is a
self.x which is going to be 1000 uh then
I'm going to have another print
statement saying value of y is self dot
Y which is going to be 2000. finally uh
I mean next I have another class called
2 this this is going to derive from
class 1 as you can see here and in this
class too I have defined another method
called add and in this method add what
I'm going to do is I'm going to first
print a statement saying this is the
method in class 2 and then I'm going to
actually print the result of X Plus Y
which is 1000 plus 2000. finally I have
another class called 3 and this is also
deriving from one so if you notice we
have one parent class called one and
from this one uh parent class we're
going to derive two different subclasses
called 2 and 3. so this is an example of
hierarchical inheritance now in this
class 3 what I've done is I've defined a
multiplication method what I'm going to
do is print first of all I'm going to
print this when I invoke this method
that this is the method in class three
finally I'm going to say I'm going to
print the result of x times Y which is
1000 times 2000 so if you see I am going
to create an instance of 2 and I'm going
to create an instance of three and I'm
going to store them in T1 and T2 now
since uh T2 I mean T1 is an instance of
2 so I can access its methods add and I
can access this methods display so I'm
going to use t1.display and even into T2
I mean since it's a class it's an
instance of class 3 and this also
derives from class 1 I can also access
its method display but now I cannot
access add but I can access multiply so
if you see here I access add through T1
instance since add is a part of Class 2
whereas multiplies is a method in class
three so I access it in its respective
instance which is T2 so if you see here
now once I execute this what you will
get is basically the results so first of
all it will basically display the method
from class 1 which is the display method
it will display the values of X and Y
and since I've done this twice from two
different instances it will basically
show a repetition over here finally I've
done the addition and since this is a
method in class 2 it is going to say as
much that is the method in class 2 and
then it's going to say X Plus Y is 3000
and now multiply is a method in the
third class so it's going to say this is
a method in class 3 and it's going to
tell me what is the multiplication
result finally we have what is called
Hybrid inheritance and this is a
combination of multiple plus multi-level
inheritance that you saw earlier so
let's again understand this through this
example so we have a class called
student where we have a method called
set student
um again two attributes we can pass here
for student number and student name next
we have a another method part of the
class student called put student so this
will print us the student number and
student name next we have a class called
marks and this marks inherits from
student so we have a method in class
marks called set marks where we can pass
two attributes for Mach 1 and Mark 2
respectively and as we have seen earlier
we also have a put marks which will
display the marks for Marks One and
marks two we have a class called
practical this practical is basically a
another Super class if you see here
since this does not derive from anything
it is super class on its own and what it
does is it uh it has two methods get
practical
um and we can uh pass an attribute for
P1 here and we store that in self.p1 and
then we have an attribute for uh put
practical which will print us the
Practical marks whatever we passed for
this attribute in P1 finally see we have
a class called result now in this result
we have we are going to derive from mugs
and practical but if you notice here
marks itself is a subclass of student so
this is an example of multi-level
inheritance whereas since result uh
derives from marks and practical both it
is also an example of multiple
inheritance so if you see a notice here
this is an example of multiple and
multiple level inheritance which is
basically what we call Hybrid
inheritance and as we had seen earlier
this result class will have a calc
method to do a total of the marks in
this case Mach 1 plus Mark 2 plus the
Practical Mark P1 and we have a put
total method which is basically going to
print us the total so now we're going to
create an instance of this result and
through this instance of result we're
going to first invoke the parent class
method called set student which is the
the second level parent basically the
student the student class set student
method so we're going to set student
here we're going to say 60 is a student
ID and name is Ash then we have set
marks which is again the the second
level parent which is a student class
where we set the marks finally we access
this get practical now if you notice get
practical is part of um the Practical uh
super class so in this we store the
third subject or the Practical marks 100
then we calculate the total and we put
uh first the student details then we put
the individual marks then we put the
Practical marks and finally we enter
what is the total so let's execute this
and if you notice you will see here
student number 60 student name and all
the basically whatever details we wanted
um is shown over here in this video we
will continue our discussion on object
oriented programming with the topic of
polymorphism now the term polymorphism
in oop refers the ability of an object
to adapt the code to the type of data it
is processing polymorphism is one of the
key concepts of python and it is also a
built-in feature of python an example to
get us started on polymorphism would be
how we use the bus operator we use the
plus operator not only for arithmetic
additions but we also use the plus
operator for stuff like string
concatenations or joining two lists
together this example where we are able
to use the plus operator for different
different operations is an example of
polymorphism to show you what I mean I
have basically done a simple addition
operation here where I'm adding two
variables number one and number two when
I do it on integers it basically adds
one plus two now when I use it on two
strings str1 and str2 which contains
Python and programming to separate uh
strings and when I use the plus operator
on these you can see what it does here
it forms one string containing both of
these individual strings so this is
basically the plus operator showing
polymorphism and is one of the simplest
occurrences and yet most common
occurrences of polymorphism in Python
another example of polymorphism would be
through the lens function the lens
function in Python is something that we
use a lot and over multiple data types
depending on the data type that we use
the length function for we get a
different value or a different sort of
information from the length function now
if you see here from this diagram when
we use the length function on a string
it gives us the length of the string
when we use the length function on a
list it gives us the number of items
whereas if we use the length function on
a dictionary it gives us the number of
keys so this is well another example of
how we have polymorphism in a function
now what we're going to do is look at
the different techniques through which
we can enable polymorphisms in our code
our first example that we are going to
look at is through method overloading
now method overloading in its
traditional sense where we can have a
method with the same name more than one
method with the same name in the same
class is not exactly possible in Python
so if we have multiple methods with the
same name in a class in Python which may
differ in in types and number of
arguments are not allowed and not
supported in Python in fact if we did
something like this where we created a
method with a different uh with
different say types and number and
arguments but having the same name um in
the same class then what python will do
is it will only recognize the the last
defined method and uh it will not
recognize any of the earlier methods
with the same name but we can simulate
polymorphism through method over
overloading by using default arguments
in a method now for example what I'm
going to show you here is an example
where I have a method called sum Now by
default it has three attributes that you
can pass through this method a does not
have a default value B does not have a
default value but if you notice C has a
default value of 0. so this is a simple
example where I'm going to show you that
the sum method is going to be used in
two different cases in one case we are
going to Simply add two digits uh I mean
two numbers and in another case we are
going to use the sum method to add three
different numbers so we have this class
overload demo within it a method sum and
I have three attributes A and B are uh I
have are supposed to be given by the
user since they don't have a since they
do not have any default values whereas C
has a default value of zero so if you
see here in my first case I have I first
of all created a an instance called over
uh an instance called OD for the class
overload demo and I have what I'm going
to do is I'm going to store the value of
the sum of 7 and 8 in the variable sum
now if you see here I have not passed a
third argument so what this method is
going to do is is going to take the
value of C as 0 by default so it's
basically going to do uh 7 plus 8 and
it's going to give us the sum for 7 plus
8 and in the next instance I'm going to
give three ad arguments seven eight and
nine so now c will be replaced by 9
instead of 0 and then I'm going to get
the sum of 7 8 and 9. so in this this is
a not a very used not a very commonly
used thing but it's basically a method
just to show you that we can actually
simulate method overloading in Python by
using default arguments so I've
basically shown you how the same how the
same method sum has been used to do the
addition of two digits and then in in
another instance is doing the addition
of three digits it might look very
similar but you'll basically notice that
by having this third attribute C I have
a default value of 0 I have induced some
form of polymorphism through method
overloading now the next way that we can
induce polymorphism is through
inheritance which is called method
overriding as well now method overriding
gives us the ability to change the way
or the change the implementation of a
method in a child class which is defined
already in one of its super classes now
if there is a method in a super class
the method having the same name and same
number of arguments in a child class uh
then the child class method is going to
override the method in the parent class
so what we do is when a method is called
with the parent class object the method
of the parent class will be executed
whereas if we call the method using the
child class object the method of the
chart class will be executed executed
and it will override the method in the
parent class so the appropriate
overridden method is called uh is called
based on the object type which is an
example of polymorphism so let's look at
an example to understand this so we have
a class called person and we have
defined what we're going to define the
initializer is two attributes which we
have to pass called name and age and
we're going to store them in cell plot
name and self.h now we have a user
defined method called display data where
we are going to print if this display
data has been called through the parent
called person
um if it's going to be called through
the parent class object then we're going
to print in parent class display method
and when we're going to print the name
and age that we have entered now we have
another class called employee which is
going to be a derived class 1 person so
it's going to
um so it's also going to have an in an
initializer and this Constructor will
basically um what what this initializer
will have is it will have an uh
Constructor for the superclass where
we're going to do this uh the same
initialization that we do in the
superclass but we're also going to store
another attribute called ID in self dot
employee ID and if you see here we also
have another method called display data
which is the same name method from
person but now if you see in display
data I have every I have all the same
almost the same information I'm going to
print the name I'm going to print the
age but if you see the first statement
I'm going to say if I'm going to call
this method from the employee object
then I'm going to say in child class
display data method instead of in parent
class display data method to say that
basically I'm invoking this method from
the child class object and I'm also
going to print on top of the whatever
I'm printing before I'm also going to
print the employee ID so if you see here
I have created an object called person
which is uh an object of the class
person with the information of name John
and age 40. and then I'm going to
display this now next I'm going to
create an object called amp which is the
child class employee object which is
going to now have the same information
of John for the name and age 40 but now
is going to have an employee ID and then
I'm going to store this uh in amp and
I'm going to display the data for this
child class object and we will see the
difference in how the display data is
differing from the earlier earlier case
so when I execute this you see the in
the first case it says in parent class
display data method so this display data
has been called through the parent class
object and I'm only going to show the
information of name and age whereas when
I invoke this method from the employee
class object it's going to say it's
going to specifically say that it's a in
child class display method and then I'm
going to say the name age and also the
employee ID over here so this is the
difference between how display data has
been used in its parent and its child
class and this is basically the example
of method overriding now our next
example of polymorphism uh is going to
be through operator overloading and
operator overloading is the ability to
overload the operator to provide extra
functionality in additional to its um
real or core operation and operator
overloading is also an example of
polymorphism as the same operator can
perform different actions the earlier
example of where we use the plus
operator for different operations is an
example of operator overloading
polymorphism now when um when when this
operator overloading required well um
any time you want an operator to perform
a different function for you in your
custom objects you would basically do
operator overloading now an example of
this would be what I'm going to show you
below so if you see this class called
point it has an initializer where I'm
going to store two attributes X and Y in
sub.x and Y and subtle instep.x and self
dot y now I'm going to create one object
called P1 where I'm going to create
point one and two so you can think of
this object as basically like a
coordinate x coordinate one y coordinate
two this is one point and another Point
called uh x coordinate three x one four
I'm gonna call that P2 now I want to
print P1 plus P2 all right now if I try
to execute this you will notice an error
it says unsupported operand types for
plus point and point this basically
means that plus does not know what to do
when it's given an object of this type
it has no idea what to do whereas what
we wanted to do is add the the x
coordinate from this point and the x
coordinate from this point so we wanted
to do a 1 plus 3 and we also wanted to
do this y coordinate plus this y
coordinate or 2 plus 4 and then we want
to print basically like something like 4
comma 6 or the addition of the two
points or the the vector addition of
these two points so this is what we want
this plus operator to do but the python
does not have any inbuilt feature for
the plus operator and we are going to
have to basically do some operator
overloading to create a polymorphism on
this so let's see how we can do that so
to do that first of all we have to
understand that all operators in Python
have internally defined methods to
provide functionality for these
operators the operator or the special
method to provide functionality for the
plus operator in Python is the add
method and whenever the plus operator is
used we are basically internally
internally invoking the add method so uh
these these sort of internal methods
that provide functionality for The
Operators are part of a big a bigger
class of methods known as magic methods
and these magic methods are
automatically invoked whenever it's
corresponding operators are used so we
want to change the uh the operation for
the plus operator in this example we are
going to have to use the the add method
in this case and since it's a magic
method magic methods are also are
basically what we saw earlier in the in
the form of Dunder methods so magic
methods are going to be invoked using a
double underscore a prefixed and suffix
to it so similar early to how we defined
an init of an init method or an HDR
method we are going to also invoke the
add method using the same double
underscore before and after its name so
now let's see how we're going to do this
so if you see this class I have now my
class point and I have the same
initializer when I'm going to store X
and Y now I am going to Define on uh
this this add magic method I am going to
override the the normal functionality of
plus and I'm going to give it a very
specific function where I'm going to say
um for two two different objects you're
going to add its uh the first part the
first part or its so called x coordinate
with the other x coordinate and the y
coordinate with the other y coordinate
and you need to return return this to me
in the form of a similar object so now
when I pass 1 and 2 and 3 and 4 it
should return me 4 and 6 as you can see
here I have basically done what I wanted
to do by operator overloading I have
changed or I have overloaded this ad
this plus operator using this add magic
method and I have created a new
functionality for this add function for
these two points one and two three and
four now I'm able to add one comma 2 3
comma 4 in the way I want it to so now
that you saw how we did our operator
overloading I'm just going to show you
um a list of similar magic methods for
different operators that we are familiar
with so the plus operator already we've
seen has the add method then we have the
minus operator with the sub method and
similarly we have for all of these
operations such as multiplication
division we have its respective magic
methods these magic methods are again
prefixed with two underscores and suffix
with two underscores and they are
basically they are also called uh done
does in Python so this is how we would
do operator overloading in Python for
whatever operator we want similarly we
can do this for like comparison
operators and for urinary operators as
well so look at this example now where
I'm going to overload the multiplication
or the Asterix operator so I have again
defined a point I'm in a class called
point I'm going to Define an initializer
but I'm going to store some attribute X
and cell dot X now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to overload the
multiplication operator where I'm going
to basically allow the uh this Asterix
operator to multiply two objects uh from
like for example 12 and 5. usually I can
just do a normal 12 times 5 but in this
case my object is slightly different my
12 is being passed through an object of
a class called point and five as well in
another uh instance of the same class
now when I want to multiply these class
instances like the the multiplication
operator does not perceive these class
instances to be integer so by default it
would not be able to multiply what we
want to multiply but when we Define
um or we overload the multiplication
operator within our class it's now able
to understand what to do um using the
attributes of these classes in its
respective class instances so it's able
to say okay so I want this this
attribute from this particular instance
V1 12 and I'm going to multiply it with
the attribute 5 from instance P2
whenever I say P1 times P2 or P to P1 as
6 P2 so when I execute it it will give
me 12 times 5. similarly I can also do
this for the greater than operator over
here so I have a class called person
where I'm going to Define an initializer
where I'm going to pass name and salary
and store them in sub.name server.s
salary the GT method is basically the
greater than method magic method and
it's going to uh we're going to use this
to overload the greater than operator
and now again using this greater than
operator I am able to basically say
object 1 greater than object 2 and I'm
basically able to check through this and
if object 1 is greater than object 2 it
will basically tell us if it is true or
false or basically whatever like we want
to know so this is the the print
statement will check for object1.name
and it will say earns more than
objective.name if in case object 1 is
indeed greater than object two so when I
execute this is you can see here my
first information says John has is
earning 4 500 or some units Natasha is
earning 6000 of some units so it will
say uh John earns more than Natasha well
it's false because object one is not
greater than object two so uh since 4500
is not actually greater than 6000 and
this is the check that I'm doing by
overloading the GT operator over here
where I'm so when I'm returning the
Boolean value of uh what is greater self
or salary or other dot salary self being
the first uh object in any comparison so
in the if I'm basically any comparison
if I'm doing say if I'm doing 5 greater
than 5 greater than 6 so what the GT
will do is this will be the self object
and this will be the other object so
this is what I'm doing over here I'm
checking self dot salary with other dot
salary in in the form of these objects
and it's basically the same same way
that we we are able to do five plus five
through these class instance objects
that you saw earlier or 12 times 5 that
you saw earlier so this is all examples
of operator overloading in Python in
this video we will be taking a brief
introduction into what is a function so
a function in Python is a group of
related statements that performs a
specific task or tasks now functions
help break our program into smaller and
modular pieces of code and it's very
good and very convenient to use
functions to make our code organized and
manageable especially as our overall
program grows larger it also helps us to
avoid repetition and makes a code
reusable so let's look at the basic way
of defining a function so this is a
basic function that I am calling Fun
underscore name all right now the rest
of the function or whatever the task is
going to be performed by this function
will be my written over here within
indent of course as a standard when it
comes to python so I'm going to Define
this one something in triple uh double
quotes so don't worry about what this is
right now this is a doc string don't
worry about what this means and I'll
explain with you just in a short bit all
right now now the rest of the statement
the rest of it uh will obviously be what
this function will do let's include a
simple print statement all right let's
uh done here let's call this so of
course once you've defined the state
function to call the function you just
have to use its name like this this is
how you call a function so as you can
see when I call this function it should
print the statement hello now let's go
let's uh look at some of the uh like
what happened over here so we've used
the keyword def to define a function we
give it a unique name which makes it uh
which with which we uniquely identify
this function and also once we've done
this we
um we can give it we can give this
function a particular header it's called
a doc string so what this doc string is
basically something that we include in
triple quotes over here just after the
div the dev keyword and this is like a
brief we can use this to give a brief uh
and give brief information into whatever
function is doing so we can say this is
this function performs addition this
performs
um subtraction or whatever like some
basic information as to whatever
function does so we can use a doc string
for that of course this is an optional
thing this does not have to be we don't
have to include this as well all right
but for the sake of this let's just keep
it here after that of course rest of the
function uh will contain whatever tasks
we want to do with it and that will be
indented
um finally we can also include a return
keyword and what the return keyword does
is at any point you find the return
keyword in a function you immediately
leave the function you go back to where
this function was called okay so now
let's see
um now there's also one more important
component of defining a function and
that's parameter now if you noticed over
here within these parentheses I did not
include anything this is like an empty
path this is opening and closing what if
I said a if I included some A and B over
here so what this means is whenever I
call this function I need to pass two
parameters A and B these can be like
strings or numbers or whatever
um but now it becomes almost mandatory
that I pass these two things for my
function to uh to work so let's define a
function when I'm going to add a and b
so instead of this print statement let's
do this I create a variable C and in
that I'm storing a plus b all right and
then I return C so you can use a return
and you can you you can return certain
like variables along with the return
statement so I'm saying not only return
from this function but also given output
or return an output called C which is
the addition of A and B now how do we
use this well now instead of just
calling the function like this I'm going
to add para I'm going to include
parameters so I'm saying Pass 2 and 3 to
function name where 2 will take the
place of a and 3 will take the place of
B all right what will happen now is
addition will take place and we will get
return the result so let's see what
happens now as you can see two plus
three and I already got the data the
addition of two plus three and it
returned me five so yeah this was like a
basic uh usage of a function and
parameters so so of course we can if you
want to know like what a what the doc
string of a particular function does or
says uh you can use this particular you
can use this like statement so let's say
for so uh it's very important to like
just keep a note in your uh while you're
going through this while you're learning
that uh whenever we use some sort of a
function which has double underscore
right this is like a built-in a built-in
command provided by python
um within the python Library itself so
these are like built-in commands to
check certain details so I want to check
what is a doc string and this is how I
do it so let's do print let's print what
is the doc string over here this is a
doc string so this is basically what I
wrote over here I can change this to
this like this does Edition for example
all right now this will say this does
addition when I execute this line so
this is the way to check what is a dark
string anyways so now that you have seen
a basic a basic function two basic
functions that I defined for you and how
we use them what a parameter is let's
look at another concept that we call
scope and lifetime of variables so scope
of variable is the portion of the
program where the variable is recognized
all right now a parameter and a variable
that are defined inside a function are
not visible from outside the function
this is a very key thing so if we Define
something within the function we can
only use it within this function and we
cannot like we cannot use it once the
function has already been executed so as
to speak
um these variables and these parameters
uh have what we call as local scope
since they are only
um recognized within a particular
function now the lifetime of a variable
is the period throughout which the
variable exists in the memory itself and
it's very important to note that
lifetime of variables that are defined
inside a function
um are as long as the function executes
once we return from a function whatever
we have defined within it are destroyed
so when we use a function it will not
remember the values of a variable from a
previous iteration of a function call so
let's try to understand this example or
this concept using certain examples so
out here I have defined a function where
I'm going to create a variable my
underscore VAR my variable and I am
going to store the value 10 in this and
then I'm going to print so whenever I
call this function I will always create
this variable I will store 10 and I will
print the value of this all right now
what I'm going to do is I'm not only
going to create this my VAR inside this
function I'm also going to create a
variable outside so you see there now
you you might be confused as to okay how
is the behavior going to be because
outside the function I have created my
wire with a value 20 but inside the
function I will always Define my virus
10 okay now I'm going to print so my
first what I'm going to first do is I'm
going to execute this function that I
created initially where I store the
value of 10 in my bar and then I'm going
to pray and print the value of my wire
that was present outside the function
let's see what happens you can see two
different things happening so when I
execute this function it prints the
value inside the function as 10 but when
I print the next line which says um okay
now get the value of my bar it actually
prints a value of 20 and this is a very
key concept because What's Happening
Here is when I initially call my
function within this function it creates
a variable called my wire and it prints
the value as 10 and the moment my
function has been executed it destroys
this variable and the variable which
contain the value 10 is of course now
destroyed and all we have is the my wire
that contains 20 from the outside and
when we print that we get the suspective
value as 20. so you can also think of it
like this the my wire that is present
inside this function is different to the
my word that we create outside so the
scope of the my wire within this
function is local only to this function
and once the function is executed that
variable is destroyed all right now
let's look at a another case or the
other side of this case where um say
we're dealing with variables that have a
global scope how do we deal with them so
let's create a variable called my where
all right and I say I stored 100 in this
all right now if I Define a function
I've stored my where let's say I Define
a function define underscore say again
same name where what I'm going to do in
this is I am going to print the value of
whatever is there in my where Okay so
let's do print
um value of variable is value stored in
variable is okay it's uh my where so
let's see what happens when we do this
let's call this function on underscore
name see what happens here so as you can
see the value I stored a value 100 in Y
where and I've called it inside the
function and this is because since I've
defined it outside I can use it inside
as well now what if I try to change the
value of this variable inside the
function though so let's see
if I did this and now if I try to print
let's see do is this Allowed no it's not
allowed in fact I get an error it says
local variable my wire reference before
assignment
um and without going too much into
detail what it's saying is that the
variable inside over here is still local
to this function and I have not defined
this my where as a global variable so I
cannot make changes to it within this
function right now and uh to change that
I can use the global keyword what if I
did Global over here so if I did Global
and now if I said okay Global myware and
I declare this variable as a global
variable now if I do this now if I do
the same incrementation now let's see
what happens when I'm trying to do this
you see I get the value 101 it's exactly
what I wanted and that is because I've
defined my variable to be a global
variable within this function so I can
in fact make changes to it within this
function so this is how we use the
global keyword and Global variable uh
also just to make a quick note there are
three types of functions uh the three
types of categories in which we can
divide functions first one being
built-in functions these are the ones
that are built into the standard library
of python the other is user defined
functions that is the ones which we
Define ourselves and the third type is
called Anonymous functions they're also
known as Lambda functions and this is
something that we're going to cover in a
separate video now let's talk about the
arguments that we pass in Python so
there are four types of arguments that
python user defined functions can take
first one being default the other one is
required then there is keyword and then
there is variable number of arguments so
the default argument is when say
um if I Define the function where
underscore sorry fun or Discord name and
I'm saying a comma B right but what if
the user has not like save I I want a
default value of a and b each time when
I use this function so in the case where
if say I don't pass a value for A and B
like this will always be used so I can
just say a is equal to 2 by default and
B is equal to 3 by default and then
within this function I will say C is
equal to a plus b and then return C so I
do this and if I say found underscore
name and in case I don't pass any
arguments here let's see what happens by
default I get the answer 5 because by
default a is 2 and B is 3 but this is
not fixed and I can always change this
by passing my own values here 5 and 6
and in this case I should get 11 as you
can see here now the next type is
required arguments and when we are
defining a required argument we just
simply do not use the equal to sign for
the parameters over here and this
basically it makes it so that now
anytime we call this function we have to
pass something over here so now if I try
to pass like this I won't get a oops
Yeah I won't get a default value then
that's because
um that's because well there is no
default value and it needs an AM B so I
have to pass it at 3 and say 4. now it
should give me 7 as you can see the next
type of argument that we'll be talking
about are the variable number of
arguments so let's look at an example
here so what I'm doing in this
particular example is I'm defining a
function called my sum where I'm passing
some parameter called my integers and
I'm doing something out here and what
this does is
um it will take the values of a
particular like collection of objects
and that's called my integers and each
value I'm going to keep adding it to
each other and I'm going to result a
particular sum I'm just going to resolve
the sum of whatever is there so in this
case what happens is I'm creating a list
one two and three which contains one two
and three and then I'm going to print
the summation of whatever is there so it
should give me 6. now the problem in
this case is that each time when I'm
going to perform this function I have to
create a separate list where I'm going
to store these objects but what if I
didn't know I do not know like what
exactly I'm going to pass here what if I
don't know if it's going to be a list of
objects or like what is it going to be
exactly well in that case I can use a
variable variable key variable number of
arguments so it's it's like a variable
keyword argument so what we use here is
um a specific way of passing um keywords
and we do it like this so I say Define
my under underscore name and I use an
Asterix now I give it any name this can
be args this can be integers it doesn't
really matter what this is but it's just
this is the key the asterisks here and
this tells us that whatever we pass here
is now if we're supposed to create an
iterable out of this and then we can
perform whatever tasks we want so let's
just uh since I've already created one
here let's see how I'm going to use it
in this case so as you can see I'm doing
uh I'm creating a particular variable
argument function over here and I'm
doing the same task I'm just going to
keep performing at uh I'm going to add
whatever I pass over here but now when
I'm calling this function I don't need
to create a separate list as I did over
here I'm just passing all the numbers
that I want to in the form of like it's
pretty much like a tuple so I'm just
passing these numbers here and what this
function is going to do is it's going to
create an iterable out of this and then
we're going to iterate over it as you
can see that's happening over here and I
can keep uh I don't need I I can just
keep like uh so since I've done it for
one two three and seven the summation
should be 13 in this case I can add
another number here just explicitly just
like this and you can see the value will
change and that's because this is a
variable uh this is a variable argument
uh method of creating a function now the
fourth type of function arguments is the
variable keyword uh argument so let's
look at what is the keyword argument now
so I have defined a function here called
the concatenate function and let's see
what I'm going to do with this so in
this I have passed a keyword argument
I've said that okay this is going to be
a keyword argument function and what I'm
going to do in this is I'm going to
create a blank string and what I'm going
to do is I'm going to add or I'm going
to concatenate certain strings that I'm
going to pass to this function so I in
this example I have passed Python and is
and Google and an exclamation mark all
separate strings and what I'm going to
do in this function is I'm going to join
them together
um and I'm going to create one whole
string out of it let's see what's the
result python is cool so this is so of
course like uh if I had to add some
something else like python is a cool and
say I just wanted to say hello and say
one more string I can add I can add it
just like this I don't have to like
Define a fixed number of arguments I can
pass any number of arguments I want and
this works exactly the same as variable
in the only differences instead of
positional arguments we're using keyword
arguments over here hello by like this
it doesn't really make sense but just to
show you as you can see so this is how
we use keyword arguments in this video
we will be learning about X exceptions
exceptions are errors that are raised
during the execution of a program when
an error occurs python generates this
exception that can be handled which
avoids our program from caching python
has many built-in exceptions uh however
we can create many uh user-defined
errors or exceptions as well to catch
whatever errors we're looking for in our
program so when an error occurs python
interpreter raises an exception and
stops the current process and it passes
it to a calling process until the
exception is handled and if this is not
handled the program will crash some of
the built-in exceptions are like I O
error in the case when a file cannot be
opened or import error python cannot
find the particular module being
imported and there are so many similar
uh so many exceptions that are built in
Python for the appropriate cases now
before we move on and see how we raise
these exceptions let's look at the
difference between an exception and a
syntax error so for that I will be using
an example where I will be dividing
something by the number zero of course
this is not possible so let's see how
python handles this particular problem
well it traces something that it raises
what we call a zero division error and
this is an exception that is built in in
Python whenever we try to divide
something by zero now let's look at the
difference between this exception and a
syntax error so this is the same
statement except I'm going to add this
extra bracket which does not make sense
syntactically in this now if I try to
execute this as you can see we get a
different type of error known as the
syntax error when it says the unmatched
closing bracket so this is what a syntax
error looks like like an extra bracket
or a comma that basically makes the line
unreadable to The Interpreter in the
first place so the The Interpreter
doesn't even get to the point where it
needs to figure out uh that there's
something being divided by zero it
doesn't even get to that point because
it finds this extra bracket and it
cannot execute this line at all so that
is like the difference between an uh an
exception and a syntax error all right
now for our first case of how we raise
or how we handle exceptions let's look
at the keyword arrays so for this
example what I will be doing is I'm
going to take this variable X all right
and I'm going to store a value 10 and
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
check for a condition if x is greater
than 5 then I'm going to raise this
exception using the raise keyword like
this and in case this condition is met
if x is actually greater than 5 I want
this particular message to play out in
my uh exception so let's see what
happens when I execute this as you can
see the exception is raised because X is
indeed greater than 5 its value is 10
and the mirror message says so that X
should not exceed 5 the value of x was
10. so this is an example of how we can
raise an exception and as you can see
when a condition was met the program
comes to a halt and an exception was
raised now let's look at another type of
handling exception where we use the
assert statement so when we use base
command we waited until an error
occurred and our program crashed Midway
right what if we want to check if a
condition is met and if this condition
is met then then the program can
continue but if the condition turns out
to be false then we want a particular
error namely the assertion error
exception to be thrown to us so we can
use the assert command in such a case so
in our example we will be checking
whether the system that we are working
on is actually Linux or Windows 32. so
let's see first of all let's import a
library called sys this is the it's a
library which where we can access system
information one of the modules and that
is one of the functions and that is the
platform it basically tells us what
system are we working on so we're
working on a win32 system okay so um
let's now let's use the assert keyword
all right now we're going to check if
Linux is what we are working on and in
case it is not then we want an error
message and this will be the error the
error will obviously be an assertion
error because we are using the assert
keyword so this is how we use the assert
statement and if we execute this as you
can see we get the assertion error
because systart platform contains win32
and not Linux and so we got this
assertion error so if we change this to
check for Windows system we won't have
any error when we execute this as you
can see so this is uh the example where
we use the assert statement another way
of handling exceptions is by using the
try and accept block so this is probably
one of the most common ways of handling
exceptions in Python where we use a try
keyword and an accept keyword now within
the try keyword as you can see here we
have a chunk of code which we're going
to check and if everything is fine in
the try keyword then this is perfect so
we don't need to move on to what we call
the accept part of the try and accept
block but if say there was an error in
the try block then we move on to the
accept block where we're going to run
the part of the code in the case we find
an error in the try block so first we
check the channel the part of the code
that is under the try block and if if
there is an error we move on to the
accept block and we run that part of the
code over there and where we and in the
accept block where we that is where we
handle our whatever error that might get
thrown our way in the try block okay
let's look at an example and how to use
this technique so I have a basic
function out here all right it's a
defining a function called Linux
interaction what this is uh basically
doing is that when I call this function
I want to do an assert check I'm going
to check if Linux is the system I'm
working on and if it is not then I want
this error to be thrown okay and so yeah
let's see what happens in the case and
if if the search statement is actually
passed then we will move on to this
statement so you could look at it like
this if when I mean when I call this
function it will first check for this
assert statement in case something wrong
happens and we get an assert error then
we do not move on to this line so we
only get this printed but if this assert
statement passes then we move on to this
line and we get print doing something
okay so let's see I'm going to call this
function out here let's see what happens
here as you can see I get an assertion
error because obviously this is a
Windows system and not a Linux system
and I get this message okay now let's
see what happens when we use it in a try
and accept block all right so now I have
a try block over here in which I am
going to try the same this function
Linux underscore interaction if in case
I find an error I immediately jump from
the try block into the accept block now
you see the slight difference in how we
handle this like what happens so as you
can see when we use the function
explicitly we directly went to what we
call an assertion error but when we use
a try and accept block we will not use
the assertion error because we are
leaving the try block immediately and
we're going to go into the accept block
where the only thing we're doing is
printing the statement as you can see we
are not on Linux found some error okay
now what if we wanted to catch the error
within uh this function itself which was
the assertion error and we can do that
are explicitly like this so now what I'm
doing is I'm going to try all right and
it's going to catch an error in this
slide so now in the accept block I'm
going to say the assertion error that we
found in this function in the try block
we're going to use that in our accept
block so as you can see we're going to
print that assertion error it will
basically print the statement function
can only run on Linux systems as you can
see here function can only run on net
systems function can only run on Linux
systems and the next part of the thing
was the Linux interaction function was
not execute it okay so this is a a very
this is like this is a key there's a key
something very important happening here
when we use this assert statement the
whole program is actually getting
executed right but when we're using the
try and accept block we are immediately
jumping on like the moment we catch an
error we are immediately jumping onto
the accept statement and uh however and
all the handling of the exception is
done in the accept block and not in the
try block anymore so where to uh think
of it like this that the try block is
only check if a particular piece of code
is like does it have any errors or not
and in case it does then every like all
the handling that we do is uh in the
accept block of this particular
statement now let's look at another
example in this example I'm going to try
opening a particular file now this file
does not exist so I will be I will get a
file not found error and this is a
built-in exception and I'm going to
catch that and I'm going to print that
error over here in the accept block all
right so as you can see file not found
and whatever like error I have I printed
over here all right so this is another
like this is a file not found error that
we are going to that we we got in our
try block and we're handling it in the
accept block now let's use let's combine
both of the examples where we use this
Linux interaction and we also try to
open a particular file and we try to do
both things in the try block and since
both of these contain errors let's see
what happens when we try to what happens
when we have like multiple errors in a
triangle book so as you can see in my
cryblock I'm not only doing this Linux
interaction I'm also trying to open a
particular file that does not exist
obviously so now you might think will I
get two exceptions well let's see what
happens when we try to uh execute this
so uh it's important to note that in our
accept we have one except for uh
catching a file not found error and we
also have an except for finding um uh
the assertion error that that is part of
this Linux interaction function so so
since both of these are errorous
statements or they will throw exceptions
so now the question is will we get both
of these except blocks or we get both of
these exceptions where we get only one
of them where we get the first one so
let's see what happens so as you can see
my error statement is is very much like
the assertion error that I had that we
had done as part of this Linux
underscore interaction function function
can only run on Linux system the Linux
function will not execute it so as you
can see that that is the one that has
been God and for some reason the file
not found error has not been caught and
this is because this is a very important
feature of the try block the moment we
find the first error in our try block we
immediately leave and we do not execute
any of the further statements and we
jump into the exceptions and we handle
it using the accept blocks so the moment
an error is found in this function we do
not execute this part of the statement
and we directly jumped into the
respective exception that was the
assertion error exception so this is a
key takeaway so some of the some of the
other key takeaways when it comes to
exceptions is a try Clause is executed
up until the point where the first
exception is encountered and in the
accept clause or the exception Handler
we determine how the program responds to
this exception we can have multiple
exceptions and we can differentiate how
the program responds to each of these
and it's also very important to not use
accept clause on its own it's very
important not to use a bare except
Clause now finally before we conclude
this is a topic of exceptions let's look
at the else and the finally Clause so
the else Clause is used when we want to
execute a particular piece of code in
the case where we have no exceptions or
no errors found so let's look at this
just like we had the Linux interaction
function I'm going to define a win under
underscore interaction and this is going
to check whether our system is Windows
or not in case it is not then we get
this error message all right and in case
it is a Windows it is a Windows system
we print this in the case of when we
call this function so let's again use
our try and accept statement only in
this case we will be using an extra else
Clause so we first try this function in
case there's an error we catch it as an
assertion error and we print that error
but if there is no exception that we
move on to the else statement and we
print this so as you can see our we have
actually moved on to the else statement
and we print this line executing the
else clause and that is because we have
found no exceptions over here so again
it's Keto remember that the else Clause
is used whenever you want to execute a
particular statement in the case where
we do not find any exceptions in the try
block the finally Clause is used when we
want to execute something regardless of
whether we have an error or an exception
or not so no matter if an exception
happens I mean is raised or if it's not
raised we want this finally block to
always get executed and let's look at
how it's let's look at an example of it
being used so I have this block where
I'm doing a lot of things the first
thing that I'm doing is I'm going to
check for this Linux interaction
function which is going to check of
course whether it's a linear system or
not this is I'm doing the try block now
if I catch an error that I want to be I
want to handle it by simply printing the
error over here and in the event that
there is no error then I will move on to
the else statement and I will try this
particular block of my statement which
is again that when I'm trying to read a
particular file that does not exist and
it's very uh it is very important a that
you note that within the else block I
have another try and accept block and
this is perfectly legal and it's
perfectly valid in our program we can do
this so think of it like this I'm first
trying this if I have an error then I do
this and I don't execute this but if I
don't have an error then I execute this
whole statement which contains its own
try and accept block all right but
regardless of whether I get an error
here or not I will always execute this
portion of my statement or under the
finally Clause so let's execute this as
you can see of course the error is
raised in this try try block so we move
on to the exception and that is what is
printed over here and after the
exception is done we move on to the
finally we of course skip this else
block because the exception was actually
raised so after that is done we move on
to the finally block where we print this
particular statement well that was it
for an introduction into exceptions in
Python I hope you learned something from
this and um of course this is just the
beginning exceptions are something that
that you will be that you would probably
encounter a lot especially when you're
beginning and it's something that you
will learn to extensively work with and
that will also help you improve in your
programming in this video we will be
covering the topic of iterators now an
iterator in Python is an object that
contains a countable number of values or
it's a larger object it contains a
countable number of sub-objects an
iterator is an object that can be
iterated upon and what that means is we
can Traverse from each value and we can
manipulate or perform certain functions
or operations and tasks using each of
the sub objects or values within this
larger collection called iterator now
um when we're looking at it technically
an iterator is an object which
implements the iterator protocol in
Python which consists of the methods
iter and the method next so to begin
with let's look at a simple iterator
we're going to see the example of a list
where we're going to Traverse through
the objects of a list using the for Loop
so we have objects one two three four
and I'm going to print each of these
values one by one as you can see here
similarly we can also do the same thing
for another iterable known as the string
where we can go character by character
again using the for loop as you can see
here another example of an iterable in
Python is the dictionary so let's say I
have a dictionary where I have two
values two key value pairs uh key X
which contains the value 1 and key Y
which corresponds to value 2. now when
I'm going to do a for Loop through this
by default I will be traversing through
the keys X and Y as you can see over
here and of course the other types of
weight troubles in Python are like sets
and tuples as well all right now let's
look at um what this iterating protocol
is in Python so first of all we take an
iterable it's an object that contains uh
it's a collection of objects it contains
sub objects and when we use the eater
function it creates an iterator out of
it so we can one by one we can Traverse
through
um each of the objects and we can
manipulate each of the objects that is
contained in this and anytime we want to
move to the next object we use the next
function and when we have finally
completed all of the or we've
manipulated or Traverse through each of
the sub objects we encounter the stop
iteration exception which tells us okay
there are no more objects to be
manipulated or uh iterated upon so an ex
as an example I will create a list where
I will store the values some simple
values in teachers one two three four
one three four five okay I'm going to
create an iterator out of this where I
will use iter function and I'm going to
say this is let's say this is called my
my editor okay and I'm going to use iter
function as I had mentioned and I'm
going to pass my list in this
now if you see what is my editor it
should say it should be a list iterated
at a particular memory location now
let's use the next function to keep
going through whatever is there in this
so of course the first object should be
one as you can see now when I look at
the next it should be three then I
should get four and now I should get
five as I use the next uh successively
now since I've reached the last of my
objects in this collection now the next
time I use this next function I should
get a stop stop iteration exception that
is raised as you can see here so this is
the basic iteration protocol in Python
now you might have uh already gone
through the for Loop video and in that I
have spoken in quite a bit of detail as
to how a for Loop performs this um this
iterator protocol and how it creates an
iterative iterable object out of say a
list or a tuple and how we how it
internally performs the next function
and it um breaks out of the for Loop
once it encounters the stop iteration
exception so
um for Loops are like they're very very
similar to your standard iterator and
they use pretty much the same protocol
for its functioning now let's do a basic
comparison of what is a a basic
comparison between a generator and an
iterator in Python so in generator we
use a function we use like we Define it
using the def keyword and we Define it
under one function to create a generator
whereas in the case of iterators we use
two separate functions the iter function
and the next function the generator
makes use of the yield keyword whereas
the python iterator does not in
generators we save the states of the
local variables each time we use the
yield keyword and we pause the loop
temporarily whereas in iterators we do
not make use of any local variables all
we need is any triple like a list to
iterate upon we may use any number of
yield statements in generators and we do
not use Yale statements in iterators
generators are not memory efficient
whereas iterators are very memory
efficient so this is like basic
comparison between generators and
iterators in this video we will be
covering the topic of modules at python
now a module in Python to put it simply
is basically a python file that has
functions and classes written into it
and is saved with the dot py extension
to specify that it is indeed a python
file a Python program can use one or
more modules and modules can have one or
more functions they basically help us
organize our code and instead of having
one like one long python file we can
have several files for several modules
now my modular programming is the
process of breaking a large a large
event or task into smaller and more
manageable subtasks and we call these
subtasks basically modules now
individual modules can be grouped
together like building blocks to create
a larger application there are several
advantages to modulizing code in a large
application and we will be going through
them right now so first of all there is
Simplicity because instead of focusing
on a big big problem a big task we can
break down the problem into smaller
smaller portions or modules now
maintainability of code is much better
through module because they are designed
to create these sort of boundaries or
clear demarcations between different
problem domains there is usability
reusability in the sense that once we
create a module we can use it in
different parts of the code or even
different different applications itself
there is also scoping and what this
means is modules typically Define a
separate namespace and this helps us
avoid collisions between identifiers in
different areas of a program functions
modules and packages are basically all
constructs in Python that promote code
modulus modularization you might have
already come across a coordinate intro
into functions in this video we will be
going through modules and another video
we will also cover the topic of packages
to import a module we use the import
keyword and in this example what I'm
going to show you is a simple function
or a simple operation of importing the
OS module this is short for operating
system and as the name suggests we can
perform a system tasks through the
functions and methods that are part of
this OS module so simply executing the
statement will import this module onto
our program for us to use now if we
wanted to see all the functions that are
present in a module what we have to do
is use the dir function so if we print
the dir OS function it will print us
basically a directory of all the
functions that are present in the OS
module as you can see here that like all
of these are basically names to
different functions that are part of the
OS module finally moving on another
function commonly used with modules is
the getcwd function and what this does
is it will give us the current working
uh directory that we are working upon
right now so if I execute this it will
tell me what is the directory that I am
currently working upon right now as you
can see seed notebook dir stem if we
wanted to see all the files in a
particular directory what we can do is
use the list dir function followed by
giving a path by default if we do not
enter a path inside the parenthesis it
will basically give us all the files in
the current working directory which in
our case is temp so if I were to execute
this it gives basically gives me a list
of all the files that are presently uh
there in the directory that I am
currently working upon now a basic step
is
um creating a python module the simplest
way to create a python module is
basically creating a python script with
whatever functions and tasks that we
want and methods that we want inside uh
whatever module and saving it with a DOT
py extension
um so in in my example what I'm going to
do is I have already created a script in
notepad and I've stored it with a DOT py
extension that contains these four
functions add subtract product and
Division I have basically copied I
basically use this code and I've stored
it in a.py script and I'm going to be
using this as my uh as as a test module
for this particular example now how do
we import a module now once that I have
created a script in my example it will
be called my character UI and we've
stated stored it in our directory to
import the module all we have to do is
use the import statement so if I had to
import my calc all I have to do is say
import my underscore calc and now my
calc has been important um so we can use
the import statement or if we want to
import something particular from my
calculator we can do from my calc import
uh now we whatever like for example if
we wanted the ad uh the add function we
can basically just say only add or if we
wanted add and subtract we can say add
and subtract for example so this is
basically by using from we can say that
we want something from something but
only parts of it we don't want
everything we can also use from my calc
import and we can say asterisks to
basically say uh import everything that
exists in my calc right now so this is
another way of importing something from
a module now to access contents in a
module we have to use the dot operator
and I will show you how right now so
what I'm going to do is in my example
I'm going to import my calc as calc so
now what this since this is the original
folder or the original module but I'm
going to give it a shorthand name so
that I can easily use it in my code and
I don't have to type out my underscore
calc every time so now I'm going to
import this as calc so anytime I have to
refer to a particular method or function
inside the script or this module I will
just use this uh this placeholder this
variable name so now I have two
variables A and B and I'm storing 20 and
30 in them so my first func what I'm
going to do is basically four operations
I'm going to print the addition of A and
B then the subtraction multiplication
and the division of these two numbers
and each time to do this operation I am
going to use the add function that is
present in the my calc module so to do
that I have already imported my calc all
I'm going to do now is invoke these
functions using the dot operator that
we're already familiar with so I'm going
to say carrot.add and then I'm going to
pass these two arguments or these two
variables to say that I want to add
these two and similarly I'm going to do
it for subtraction um uh multiplication
and division as you can see these are
the results of my tasks now if I had to
do a directory uh operation on the
module calc it will basically give me a
bunch of inbuilt uh or Dunder methods
that are already a part of any uh python
script by default such as built-ins so
if I execute this just to show you what
happens when I use the dir function it
will basically give me all the functions
that are part of this python script so
these double underscores that you see
are basically uh denoting magic methods
or Dunder methods and these are like
inbuilt methods as a part of the script
and if you see here add division prod
and sub these are the methods that we
have defined earlier on in our script
ourselves now to go slightly deeper or
in more detail into what happens when we
do a module search
um let's let's actually look at what
happens so what happens is when for
example we execute the statement import
my calc as calc as we did over here so
the first the steps that actually take
place are the interpreter executes the
above statement and it searches for this
python script in a list of directories
assembled from these following sources
that you see here so it takes the
directory from which the input script
was run or the current directory if The
Interpreter is being run interactively
which is the case right now secondly it
will list all the directories contained
in the python path environment that you
set up uh that you can set up or you can
change later on as well and this format
for python path is OS dependent of
course but it should mimic the path
environment variable that we see in
Windows systems and then the other
source or the other directories is
basically an installation dependent list
of categories configured at the time
python is installed now the resulting
search paths that is accessible in the
python variable system.path and this is
basically obtained from a module named
sys so if I import it this is and I did
sys dot path now these are all the
directories that we are going to look
for when we want to search for any
particular module so if I am doing uh
import my calc or import OS it's not
only going to look at the current
directory that I am working on it's also
going to look at all of these
directories that have been set up as you
could say directories or paths in the
system.path in this video we will be
covering the topic of packages now what
if we developed a very large application
in Python that contains many different
modules and we have so many different
modules that have similar names and
functionalities and they're all kept in
like or dumped in the same location that
it becomes very difficult to track these
modules what if there was a way to
organize and access these in a much
simpler and more organized manner well
packages allow us to do just that
packages are a hierarchical structuring
of the module namespace using dot
notation and this is the same dot
notation that we use when we want to
access methods or functions that are
part of other classes or modules so
let's try to uh let's look at certain
examples to understand what we mean so I
have a directory called PKG this can be
basically treated as what we call a
package now in our package we have two
modules mod1.py and mod 2. P by and what
we're going to store in mod 1 and mod
2.py are the follows so I'm going to
define a function called Foo and I'm
going to print this particular statement
mod1 and then I'm gonna basically say
Foo and then I'm going to say in class
Foo I'm gonna have an empty pass command
similarly I'm going to define a function
called bar in mod 2 dot py where I'm
going to print this statement so
basically mod1.py has a simple function
where I'm going to print this statement
and mod 2.py has a simple function then
I'm going to print this statement
um and I'm going to store them in mod 1
and mod 2. Ty respectively and these two
modules I'm going to store in the
directory tkg in my local folder now
I've already done this so we can already
get to working with this now if I wanted
to access these particular modules from
the PKG folder I can simply use the
import command and use the dot notation
so I can say PKG dot mod1 so this will
invert in this will import the mod 1
module from PKG folder similarly I can
do the same thing for the mod 2 module
from the PKG folder in the same line so
now that it's been imported just simply
execute this and this Imports whatever
you needed now if we wanted to perform a
function that was a part of
mod1.py we can just extend the dot
notation and use the function as over
here as you can see it performs this
print command whatever it was supposed
to do similarly I can invoke the
function that was part of the mod 2
module by extending the dot notation to
it in the same way now another way that
I can invoke I can import a package is
by directly importing the package Itself
by using import pkz and not accessing
any of the specific modules within it
now let's see what happens when we do
this so just for this example what I'm
going to do is I'm going to restart the
kernel so that the PKG modules that were
already imported get cleaned away so we
see what happens when we execute this on
its own now if you see I haven't
imported this now let's see if I can
access my mod 1 and mod 2. now if you
see here it's throwing me an error and
this is because using simply using the
import command on a particular package
only Imports
um you could say the package namespace
but it does not actually import any of
the modules and files that were part of
this package so if I wanted mod 1 from
this package I would have to actually
say import pkz dot mod1 directly and I
cannot simply say import PKG and python
will not import everything that is part
of a package on its own I have to
specify it myself specifically now I'm
going to create and I'm going to I mean
I'm going to show you another type of
importing from a package using the star
operator so I have this package PKG once
again now I'm going to store
um three I mean four different modules
within this package
mod11.py mod 222.py and I've already
done this you don't need to bother about
seeing me doing it right now because
I've already created these files and
what I'm have done is within mod11.py I
have defined I've passed I've written
this statement and I've stored in the
python script similarly I've created
another Python scripts script called
mod22.py and I have basically written
this in the code and I've simply done
this for more 333.py and I've done
another for mod 4 dot py now once I have
done this I've stored these Python
scripts into my uh into my package or
PKG package so now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to create I'm going to
execute this command if you see this
from pkg.mod 333 import start so once I
execute this now I'm going to say print
directory and print directory basically
will tell me all the functions that
exist in my current directory if you see
here there's this bias function that was
a part of mod 333 module now if I change
this and if I imported mod11 and if I
did the same thing you will see Foo has
now been added as a part of this
direction directory and these are all
functions that are part of these
different modules where I am importing
from and that is what the star function
does what the star function will do is
it will basically tell python okay so
the statement is saying from pkz dot
mod11 so it's saying that okay look into
this directory or this uh package and
find this module and in this module
import everything that exists inside it
up until this point so this is another
another way of basically importing uh
files or functions from a particular
package and a particular specific module
within that package so yeah this was a
very brief video on packages in Python
uh the conclusion being that packages
are basically a an organized way of
storing many different modules that we
might have created in a very large
application and these modules can be
accessed using the familiar.net notation
that we have used in other examples such
as methods when we were working with
classes and objects in this video we
will be taking an introduction into the
concept of generators so python provides
a generator which is like a function
where we can create our own iterator in
a generator function we use the yield
statement instead of the return
statement that we use for standard
functions so let's look at a simple
Generator First of all so out here I
have defined a generator called my
generator where I'm doing uh like the
three uh like three
functions or three tasks that I'm doing
uh first one is when I'm printing the
first item and I'm yielding a value 10
then I'm printing second item using 20
then I'm printing last item using 30. so
let's see how do we use this
now since we know my generator is the
function it uses the yield keyword every
time we use the next keyword we will
keep getting what is next in this
function so let's store the generator in
my gen
so now we have stored the iterator in
this function variable called gen or gen
now let's see when we do next
and we use gen
what happens so the first task is
performed or the first iteration is
performed where we get this the first
year command is done all right let's see
what happens when we do next again
next gen
now
as you can see we get second item and we
get 20. let's do it for the next so
let's do it once more since there is one
more task team uh there's one more
iterable inside
you can see this now a very question is
what will happen if we do next gen again
since there is nothing after this
well let's see what happens
we should get an error as you can see
stop iteration error this is another uh
built-in exception
um that happens when we have like
reached the last object of an iterable
so we get a stop iteration error
so now a key difference between a
generator and a function is that when we
execute a function the moment we hit the
return statement in a function or any
execute a function like whatever
variables are stored inside are lost and
they are destroyed unless they were
defined as Global and the function is
completely done executing and we leave
the function completely whereas when it
comes to a generator when we hit the
yield function we don't actually
completely leave this function so the
first time the yield is found we get 10
but the generator remembers its position
inside this function so the next time we
use the next we actually move on to the
next iterable and then we move on to the
next hit Triple so you can think of a
generator as it sort of has memory if
that makes sense it's a way to like
create iterables in python or create
iterators in Python so to understand a
what the difference between the yield
command and the return commanders let's
take the same function all right
and let's put it return over here
after this particular the second yield
okay let's do the same thing we say gen
is equal to my generator
and
let's start uh yeah let's start
doing next gen and seeing what's there
so the first year will be standard first
item 10 the next one is again is going
to say second item and then 20 but now
if you notice there was a return I put
over here
so technically when I did the second
next it's not only yielded 20 but it's
also executed this return function or
this return statement so let's see what
happens if I do next again
as you see I have gotten the stop
iteration seemingly earlier than I did
before and that's because I have used
the return function and while in return
statement and what that's done is that
um if we've completely left this
function so as to speak and there is
nothing next so as to speak so we get
the stop iteration and that's uh the
difference between yield and return
now in the next example I'm going to
show you how we use a generator function
in place of the for Loop or for a for
Loop so let's take this whatever over
here and I have defined a function
called get sequence up to X and what
this will do is basically it will keep
printing the printing numbers up until
uh whatever we have entered in place of
X over here so if I said say sequence is
equal to Let's uh
copy this all right and say I want um I
want sequentially I want every number up
until 10 well not including 10 of course
because python starts with 0 right
so let's do this and um
now let's see so the first number will
yield 0
and now if I
did this again
it should give me one
two and I can keep going
until I will stop at the value 9. as you
can see here
so 8 9
now I should get the stop iteration
error because that we have reached the
end of our iteration so this is a way of
using generator functions for for loops
so another neat example where we're
going to use a generator is
um in the case of Fibonacci numbers so
let's use it let's see how we can
generate a Fibonacci series using
generator so I've defined the Fibonacci
function called Fibonacci where I'm
passing Max so max is basically the max
value that I want
um yeah like up until where I want the
sequence right so this is basically the
code which will uh give return me the
subsequent values of my Fibonacci
Sequence so let's pass this to fib
and see I want all the Fibonacci numbers
until 10.
so once I will pass 10 over here
let's see what happens when we do next
fib
well it should start with zero then when
we
do this again we get 1 then we do 0 plus
1 it should be one next number should be
one plus one which is 2 then we should
have two plus one three and then three
plus two five and three plus five should
be eight now eight plus five is thirteen
and since 13 is greater than what we
pass for our max value here now when we
try this we should get the stop
iteration error as you can see
in this video we will be learning about
the concept of list comprehension
Now list comprehension is it's a neat
way of creating a new list based on
values that are already there in an
existing list so you can think of it
like creating a new list using a much
shorter and cleaner syntax compared to
what you might traditionally be thinking
so let's go through some examples and
through those examples we will see how
list comprehension makes uh creating
these new this much simpler much easier
for us
so in our first example we will be
creating a new list which will contain
fruits that contain the letter a in
their name so we already have a list of
fruits over here as you can see it has
Apple it has banana Cherry kiwi and
mango now we want to create a new list
which has only the fruits that have the
letter A inside them so Apple would be
one of them banana would be one of them
and mango will be one of them so
traditionally
if you look at this piece of code
this would do what we want to do but
this contains a few extra lines but yeah
it does it does do what we want to do
now what if there was a way of doing the
same thing by just writing one simple
line of code and that exists as you can
see here
so I take the same
list now this is where you need to
follow so now my new list is equal to so
I'm creating a list over here as you can
see now within this list you have this
line this is what we call a list
comprehension so as you can see it says
each fruit for each fruit in fruits if
now it's checking for the letter or the
character a inside each fruit and what
this each fruit is that we're checking
each object in this list one by one so
first in the first iteration each fruit
will contain the string Apple then in
the next iteration it will contain
banana and in each each iteration we're
going to check if it contains the
character a and if it does then we store
that each fruit in the new list as you
can see here so if I execute this line
you see my my result is the same I have
my whatever I wanted and this was a much
cleaner way of writing uh or creating
this new list let's look at some other
examples now
so my next example what I'm going to do
is I am going to iterate through a
string so I have a string it can be
anything in this case I am using a
string called human
all right so I have a string called
human right now I want to store each
character of this string into a list
that we call H underscore letters so if
I use the for Loop this is how we would
do it if I execute this as you can see
the list contains H and then u m a and
then n now what if I wanted to do the
same thing but uh by using list
comprehension
so what I would do is
let's create
a list over here H underscore letters
and
um so as we know let's com so list
comprehension will uh it's it's a it's
you just basically need one line in this
case it'll just be like this
now this is my string
now let's see when I check what's in h
letters
let's see what is the output so as you
can see I have the output as what I
needed so this is a much cleaner way
let's go through some more examples now
now we can do more or less
comprehensions
um we can even use so we've already seen
uh one case where we checked for the
character a we've seen a case where we
uh went through where we we did a sort
of a loop through a string we can also
use this comprehensions in conditionals
so let's uh look at an example where we
use the uh this comprehension with an if
statement
so what if I wanted to store say the
first
10 even numbers so this would the so
this is an example that I'll be using so
in my list I want to store the first 10
even numbers so this would be a way to
do it
so I have in range 20 so what this is
going to do is X is going to take the
value of 1 2 3 4 and so on until 98 that
actually take it from 0 1 2 3 4 until
19. so when we do range 20 we're
creating an iterate in iterable where uh
we're going to Loop through our iterate
through the value of 0 to 19. so if I if
I do this and this what this statement
does is basically uh it checks if it's
divisible by two
so
if this is equal to equal to 0 that
means we have an even number and if this
condition is met if this condition is
met that means we store the X into our
number list so let's see what happens
when we execute this
this should contain uh 0 2 4 6 until 18.
so this is the first 10 even numbers as
you can see so this is an eighth wave
using if statement we can also use an if
else statement
so what if I I'm checking um each okay
so I'm going to create another list and
in this list I'm going to basically see
if
each of my num numbers either even or
the first let's say 10 natural numbers
so let's write this statement down
so I want it to be even
in case
the I that I'm checking I being every
number between so like say the first 10
natural numbers as I said let's check if
um if it is divisible by 2
because if it is divided by 2 of course
it's going to be even right else
we say that it is odd
and then we checked for I in say the
first let's say the first 20.
okay
so now when we do this let me check hope
you check what's in the list so as you
can see the list contains like even or
even orders basically saying the number
uh zero is even then the number one is
odd then number two is even and so on
and so forth so this is uh an example
where we used the list comprehension
with if else statements so another neat
thing that we can do with the list
comprehensions is that we can use it
along with functions so let's look at
this function in this example we have a
function called double X where we Define
this double X this double function to
take an input to take an argument X and
what we return is the square of the
argument so let's use this in uh in our
left list comprehension so what we do
over here is that we are we're checking
what we're doing is for every X
um bit in range 10 so we're taking the
value of 0 1 2 3 until 9 and we're
passing it to this function double X and
we're going to get the square of them
and we're going to store that in a in a
list as you can see here let's call this
list X so just call this list uh let's
just call it y so now let's see what's
in y and we check uh it should be 0 1 4
9 and so on so wait this let's check
again does this Square now this is
actually two times so let's make it
square
as you can see
so you can see zero one four nine uh for
the first uh 10 numbers 10 natural
numbers now what I've shown you is
obviously list comprehension
um but we can also do set and dictionary
comprehensions in fact set
comprehensions work exactly the same way
as list comprehensions the only
difference is the set comprehensions
will make sure that there are no
duplicates inside the set so you can't
have like duplicate items which you can
in the case of list comprehensions so
let's uh let's like let's take a look at
an example so here this example what
we're doing is we're going to check so
we have this string that we're storing
in the variable text and the string is
something like live finds a way so
whatever this is now what we're going to
do is we're going to
iterate through this string uh character
by character and we're going to check if
uh there are we're going to check for
vowels essentially so uh we're going to
see if the character a e i o or U is
present in the string and if it is we
will pass it into our set now if you if
you look you will find there are
multiple eyes right and there are
multiple A's as well so if we did this
through a list comprehension each time
that we find found find a vowel it would
be added to our list but since this is a
set and sets do not allow duplicates so
you will only have one copy or one
particular object for each of the
verbals so uh of course now uh set
comprehension is defined using curly
braces so let's keep that in mind so now
if I check what's in this I will see a e
i and U even though there are multiple
A's or multiple E's or I's and U's since
this is a set we don't have duplicate
copies of any copies of any of these uh
so this was just a small example for uh
showing you set comprehensions similarly
we can do the same thing uh this this
comprehension uh for dictionaries and if
we call the discrete dictionary
comprehensions the only thing the that
we have to worry about when it comes to
dictionary comprehensions is that we
have to define a key when it comes to
this so let's let's look at an example
in this what we're doing is again
dictionary comprehensions are also
defined using curly braces just like
sets except in this case we will Define
a key and that separates it from a set
comprehension
so in this case what we're doing is that
I'm checking I'm going through the a
list of numbers from 0 to 9 right so
what the range 10 function does and what
I'm going to do is I'm going to create a
key which is going to be like 0 1 2 3
and the value of each key would be H
squared as you can see here I'm doing I
times I or just to
make a little more clearer as you can
see I'm doing I Square over here for
every value from 0 to 9 so what I should
get is like a dictionary where the first
key is 0 and the value of the key should
be 0 as well because 0 square is zero
then for one it will be one and then for
two four and then three nine four
sixteen so let's see what happens as you
can see here this is the the result that
I wanted
so just to summarize let's go through
some key points uh to remember when it
comes to list comprehensions
um so it's obviously An Elegant way uh
to Define and create lists based on
existing lists uh it's more Compact and
faster than normal functions and Loops
but we should also keep in mind that we
shouldn't write like very complicated uh
list comprehensions because the idea of
a list comprehension is to be user
friendly and also it's important to note
that every list comprehension can be
written in the form of a loop but uh
every Loop cannot be written in the form
of a list comprehension and that is a
probably a very key point to remember
in this video we will be learning about
the concept of regular Expressions now a
regular expression is simply a sequence
of characters that defines a search
pattern for example if you see this
example here you can see a symbol called
the carrot followed by P and then five
periods then an n and a dollar sign and
what this regex pattern does is it's
searching for a seven letter string that
starts with B ends with n and has five
characters in between
let's look at this example now this is a
regex pattern that is looking for a five
character string that starts with a ends
with s and has three characters in
between now if we had to match this with
this string with these strings as an uh
as uh i o test strings the first one
would not match because it's a three
letter string and we're looking for a
five character string the second one
would match because it's a five
character string that ends with an s
starts with an A and has three
characters in between this will not
match because whatever pattern would do
is it would find the first s and it
would find that the string itself starts
with an A and it would say okay there
are only two characters between this
first s and this a and you would assume
that this is actually just a four
character string to actually Identify
two consecutive s's we would have to do
something special and what we would have
to do is what we will see later on so
again this is the same example since
this is case insensitive capital a uh is
perfectly fine when we're searching for
this and it will also match this is
um this is obviously two words and it's
not a five character string so this will
not be a match
now the regex pattern or the regular
expression module in Python can be
imported using this statement import Rd
now once we've done this we can actually
use the our regular expression tools and
methods to do a pattern recognition
character recognitions and to identify
different sequence of characters in our
strings Let's uh try to understand uh a
bit more in depth about regular
Expressions now so what you're seeing
here is one variable called pattern
which stores
something that looks like a reg X
and another variable that stores our
test string called abis now what we're
going to do is we're going to use the
match method of this module re and we're
going to check whether this pattern or
whatever we are trying to search using
this reg X is in fact does it match with
our test string and what we're trying to
look for is if you see here very similar
to what I just showed you a 5 character
string that starts with a and ends with
s
so if you see our test string it induced
is a match and when we use this uh this
command we should get a perfect match
so we should be basically it should say
that search is successful if I execute
this and this is what it does
now if I change the test string to this
now you will see that now this is no
longer what we're looking for a five
character string with a and starting
with a and ending with s and you will
see that the search will be unsuccessful
as you can see here now let's try to
understand what exactly do we mean by uh
when we use these different cert these
special symbols like for example this
carrot or this dollar symbol
um these are by the way known as meta
characters and now we're going to look
into all the uh or most of the different
meta characters that are used in Rec X
so to put it simply meta characters are
simply characters that are interpreted
in a special way by the regex search
engine now here's the list of meta
characters
let's go through them one by one
now the square brackets square brackets
simply specifies the set of characters
that we wish to match so we want to
match some combination of a b and c it
can be one a two a is Three B's four C's
we are not looking at a specific pattern
we just want to know if a b and c exists
in any form in our string so if we used
it on a the string a simply we would
find one match because the letter a is
found here AC would match twice because
we have a and C present here in this
string Hey Jude we will have no matches
because a b and c none of them are found
here and in this weird string we will
have actually one two three
four and five matches so we would have
five matches for this uh this bigger
string because we have five instances of
a b or c
now let's use re dot match to do to
actually search for this and to uh see
if we have our particular whatever
patterns that we're looking for now in
this input string this is just some
example string
um I'm going to test this I'm going to
match whether my pattern that um a any
of a b and c is it actually found in
this so let's see what happens when I
use re dot match for this
so the the format the syntax is simply
the regex pattern and then comma
whatever test string that we have
so
let's see what object gets created when
we try to do this as you can see it's
none even though you might be wondering
like I can see an a over here I can see
a c over here re dot match actually
gives us the result none
now
if I try to do it on this test string
which is slightly different instead of
the film Titanic was at least in 1998
what I'm saying here is all film Titanic
was released in 1998. now let's see if
the r match works or not
as you can see it actually does give a
turn when I execute this it returns as
an object called re.match object with a
span 0 1. the span zero one is basically
telling us that we have found a match
between the zeroth and the first
character which is basically this
character a which is what it has found
and it's saying that the match is indeed
the character a uh from amongst these
options
so what this is basically telling us and
what this means actually is that the re
dot match method will only find matches
if they occur at the start of the string
being searched once there is a space in
in our bigger string it will not search
for whatever comes after it so
what happened in the first instance was
it was actually only searching for
matches in this particular word in my
largest string and since it found no
match it basically gave us the result
none which was not the case in the
second example because it found a match
immediately in the first letter A
now if we want to actually check the
whole thing what we would be using is
the re dot search as you can see here
the ID dot search method will actually
check the whole string and it will
return us the first instance where it
finds a match now let's see this is a
test string now and we're searching
again for AR we're searching for a b and
c any any of these in our test string
but we're going to use re.search and not
match so now if you see it returns us
when I execute this it returns us a
match object again but this time it's
saying the span of 9 and 10. now the
spine panel 9 and 10 actually exists
over here this is the ninth character
and a itself is the 10th character over
here so what this basically is telling
us that the 10th character is where we
found a match which was the letter A
which was the first instance of either A
or B or C in this whole string and this
is basically how re.search works it will
not only search the beginning of the
string but it will search the whole
string and return us the first instance
of where whatever we find now what if we
wanted to find out all the instances
wherever a b and c were found and not
just the first instance well in that
case we would be using the method find
all over here so when we use find all it
will actually return us each and every
case where it found a b or c and you
might not it won't tell you the exact
position but it will tell you like
um so if I execute this you can see it
gives us a a list with AAC a and a and
what this basically means is it was
looking for the characters A or B or C
and it found a first and hence this for
the first item in the list then it found
a c and then it found two is
successfully so this is exact this is
actually how find all works where it
will actually find all the instances of
our regex pattern now that you've seen
how the square brackets work and how the
re dot search and re dot uh match and re
dot find of